Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Warte mal, hast du die ganze Woche jetzt Graeber gelesen?
Immer mal wieder, aber nicht durchgehend.
Wie viele Pausen hast du gemacht? Wie liest man eigentlich so ein langes Buch?
Wie liest man so ein langes Buch? Also bei mir ist es ja häufig so, dass ich mich mit einem Buch hinsetzen kann und dann kann ich vier, fünf stunden am Stück lesen. Vielleicht mit ganz kurzen Unterbrechungen.
Dann hast du ja Kapitel eins schon geschafft dann in der Zeit.
Dann hat man Kapitel eins schon geschafft. Nein, man kann natürlich in dieser Zeit auch mehr lesen und ich glaube, dass ich relativ schnell lesen kann. Nur bemerkte ich etwas. Ich begann dieses Buch zu lesen und dann erst einmal bekommt man ja so ein paar Thesen präsentiert. Wir reden mal noch gar nicht über das Inhaltliche. Und dann kommen die Autoren ins Erzählen und sie erzählen von anthropologischer Forschung, von archäologischer Forschung und von Thesen, Kulturtheorien, die uns weitgehend bekannt sind oder von denen wir zumindest mal gehört haben. Was dachte Hobbs über die Ursprünge der Menschheit? Was dachte Rousseau darüber oder was wurde ihm viel mehr in den Mund gelegt? Was er darüber dachte, das wird mal so aufgefächert. Das war für mich vertraut und dadurch kann man es natürlich sehr gut dann rezipieren. Aber dann haben die Autoren doch eine Art enorm assoziativ aneinanderzureihen. Schauen wir mal in jene Kultur, springen wir mal 10.000 Jahre zurück, jetzt mal 20.000 Jahre zurück, springen wir jetzt mal wieder zu den Indianern im 18. jahrhundert. Gehen wir dann noch mal zu den Iroquesen und und und. Und dann sind sie sehr faktenreich, sehr detailverliebt und schildern ganz viele Dinge, die man jetzt nicht kennt und die man sich aber auch nicht richtig behalten kann. Also ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, genau und da haben die ja dann 1200 vor Christus diesen Brunnen gebaut mit einem neuen System. Aber genau dieses neue System wird mir dann auf mehreren Seiten erklärt. oder irgendeine Art wie in Form von Knoten Abstimmungen stattfinden, in Schnüren. Also solche Sachen werden in aller Breite erzählt. Und ich habe mich dann gefragt, irgendwann was lese ich hier eigentlich, beziehungsweise was mache ich damit, wenn ich mit dir dann noch darüber sprechen soll? Dann habe ich gedacht, ist vielleicht meine Haltung, ich lese ein wissenschaftliches Buch oder ein Sachbuch, wie ich jetzt zum Beispiel Bullshit Jobs gelesen habe, ist das vielleicht falsch oder muss ich wirklich das Wort Geschichte, das ja im Untertitel ist, wirklich als die erzählen mir eine andere, eine neue Geschichte der Menschheit wirklich so verstehen, dass mir hier jemand eine Geschichte erzählen will. Also habe ich gedacht, ich müsste mir es mal anhören, wenn man es vorgelesen bekäme. Dann habe ich gesehen, auf Deutsch ist es noch nicht eingelesen, weiß noch nicht, ob es geplant ist, ist aber auf Englisch eingelesen. Dann habe ich mir bei Audible einen Probemonat genommen und habe mir dann, das war dann so ab Seite 300 oder so, habe ich mir dann zwei Kapitel mal vorlesen lassen. Das hatte den Effekt, dass das schön fließt. Ja, aber es ist auch nicht so, dass man sich dann mehr behalten kann oder man muss sich unglaublich konzentrieren, dass man dann die entscheidenden Thesen wieder rausnotiert. Also bin ich wieder nach den zwei Kapiteln zurück zur Lektüre gegangen. Und du siehst, es war ein doch nicht so leichtes Unterfangen für mich, mich diesem Buch zu nähern und daraus würde ich natürlich jetzt keine Selbstkritik, sondern eine Kritik am Buch schon mal ableiten und hier verkünden, indem ich sage, ich habe das Gefühl, dass hier ein Lektor manchmal ganz gut getan hätte, der ein bisschen ermahnt dieser Autoren, dass sie zu vielen Themen zu viel wissen und das auch ganz mitteilen wollen und dass es hin und wieder auch sinnvoll wäre, mal das auf eine These zu bringen beziehungsweise zu einer Conclusio zu gelangen, zu der sie auch ganz am ende noch nicht richtig in der Lage sind, dass sie sagen, so jetzt haben wir das alles gehabt und dann geht das drei Seiten, um dann noch mal zu sagen, ja, aber bei den so und so Indianern, da war das auch diese Weise geregelt und dadurch ist das so ein ständiges Abschweifen, da kann man sich vielleicht versenken drin, Aber für mich war es doch sehr mühsam bisweilen.
Also das, was du als Kritik anführst und was dich wohl auch ein bisschen ins Kars stürzte, war für mich das große Vergnügen. Denn in meinem Wikipedia Artikel steht ja, bevor ich zur FAZ ging, wollte ich in Bielefeld historisch promovieren zur Städtegründung im 12. jahrhundert. Und zwar soziologisch. Also nicht im Sinne von ich gehe mal zu den Historiker und mache Historik besser oder so, Geschichtswissenschaft besser, sondern ich wollte es soziologisch machen. Denn mir fiel auf, zum einen Historiker wissen unglaublich viel. Wie wurde der Acker vor 800 Jahren so aufgeschichtet, dass man ihn heute noch so vorfindet? Und warum wurden die Fundamente immer aufeinander gestapelt? Pipapo, dann lernt man ja alles in diesen Büchern. Da steht dann alles drin. Das Problem ist aber unter Historikern, sie trauen sich gar keine These zu. Gar nichts, null. Es gibt diese, wie ich finde, super Dessertation von Bruno Linen. Das ist der bruder von Ewald Linen, dem Fußballtrainer, der immer als Zettel-Ewald verunglimpft wird, weil er sich so viele Sachen aufschreibt während des Spiels, nach des Spiels und immer nur mit Zetteln und so weiter rumrennt. Und sein bruder Bruno ist genauso vorgegangen, als er über das Lippaland, also da oben Ostwestfalen, Lippe, Bielefeld und so, Gütersloh, rumzog und sich einfach Acker angeguckt hat. Alte Fundamente, wo er gesehen hat, ah so war das und so. Und dann sind das hunderte Seiten, tausende Seiten, ganze Büchereien voll Texte, wo festgehalten wird, was Ethnografen, Historiker, Geschichtswissenschaftler vorgefunden haben. Und dann steht mal ein Soziologe daneben und denkt sich, naja, aber es gibt doch auch eine Theoriearbeit. Und die fand in Bielefeld einfach nur ein gebäudezahn weiter statt. Ihr konntet aus dem Fenster gucken, habt sie gesehen, die Theoriearbeiter. Wolltet ihr nicht mal mit denen klären, was ihr da vorgefunden habt, wie man das so in irgendeinen Kontext, in eine Geschichte einbetten kann, wie man daraus Schlüsse ziehen kann. oder interessiert euch wirklich nur, dass da normal eine Acker aufgeschichtet wurde. Und es gibt die unendliche Geschichte, bei Michael ende ist es glaube ich, die ist ja in zwei Farben gedruckt. Ob das jetzt in Phantasialand spielt oder beim Dings im Dachgeschoss und so. Und das ist im grunde was fehlt. Ich finde nicht, dass hier ein Lektor hätte eingreifen müssen, sondern es hätte jemand mit einer zwei Farbenmarkierung nochmal dir zeigen müssen. Ja, hier kommen jetzt wirklich 28 Seiten. Keine politische These, sondern nur ethnografische Quellendarlegungen. Und dann blättert man das so Daumenkinomäßig vor und sieht, ah, hier hört der grüne Text auf, hier beginnt es wieder rot zu werden.
Hier wird es theoretisch.
Genau, und dann kann man es einfach überspringen und denkt sich, wenn ich es jetzt gelesen hätte, hätte ich es für fünf Minuten im Arbeitsspeicher gehabt, aber dann wäre es auch wieder verloren gegangen.
Aber dir geht das ähnlich. Also ich bin beruhigt. Du kannst uns das jetzt nicht alles referieren und sagen, na, das war ja folgendermaßen bei den Arzttägen. Und dann referierst du uns jetzt über Tempel und Organisationskulturen.
Ich finde, dass es der Verlag hätte aufbereiten müssen, wenn nämlich die Montag Nice Nascapi erwähnt werden und wie sie Nordamerika auf die Franzosen trafen und so weiter. Dann kann man das auch teilweise überblättern. Man muss das dann nicht so im Detail lesen. Ich finde es trotzdem super wichtig, dass das im Text drinsteht, denn am ende muss ja…
Man muss ja belegen, was man da macht. Die haben ja eine sehr große These. Genau. Die kann man ja nicht mal so ins Blaue reinschauen auf drei Seiten und sagen, so stelle ich mir das vor mit den Anfängen, sondern man muss schon Material herbringen.
Und die sollte nicht erst hinten stehen und die sollte auch nicht als Verweis stehen und die sollte auch nicht in der Fußnote stehen, sondern das muss in den Text. Das Buch kann man dann als sehr aufgeblasen ansehen, aber ich finde es in der Hinsicht ganz wunderbar integriert, dass sie sich diesen Raum einfach geben und vielleicht auch gegen den Verlag durchgeboxt haben, der nämlich eventuell tatsächlich kam mit, das ist zu viel, nicht nur weil die Druckkosten hoch sind, sondern auch die Leser, die werden da rausgeschmissen, so dieses typische, wir haben festgestellt bei Netflix, die Leute steigen immer bei Minute 57 aus diesem Film aus, also drehen wir den in drei Jahren nochmal und machen Arbeit, gestalten das dann anders und so und dem haben sie einfach nicht mitgemacht, das Spiel. trotzdem finde ich, für den Leser hätte man es zumindest, keine Ahnung, farblich oder so, man kann mit Büchern ja alles machen und das ist meine kleine Kritik am Buch, also was Gestaltung angeht, innerlich kann man natürlich viel kritisieren, was Gestaltung angeht. Man liest ein Buch über die moderne und wie wir in einer Sackgasse stecken und gleichzeitig ordnet sich das Buch aber genau dieser Sackgassenordnung unter als Buch. Also es sieht genauso aus wie alle anderen Bücher.
Und ich beschreibe dir, wie ich in einer Sackgasse steckte, als ich das Buch las.
Genau, da hätte man ja durchaus mal ein bisschen spielerisch damit umgehen können, um zu sagen, lieber Leser, wir machen jetzt hier unten mal ein kleines Sternchen auf die Seite, überblätter die 17 Seiten Sternchen und liest einfach dann unsere These weiter, weil die These ist denen ja auch wichtig. Die wollen ja auch, dass das so gelesen wird und die schreiben ja auch am Anfang, das ist ein 10-Jahres-Projekt, das ist aus der leidenschaft geboren, wir hatten noch viel mehr geplant, jetzt ist Graeber leider tot. In der Ansicht haben wir es leider dann doch mit einer quasi Monographie zu tun, die ethnografisch grundgelegt ist, aber sich durchaus mal was zutraut, was sehr vielen großen historischen Werken einfach fehlt. Klar, wir sehen das jetzt auch aus dieser populärwissenschaftlichen Richtung, das wird in großen Zeitungen besprochen, aber wenn man aus der anderen Richtung kommt, nämlich diese Regalkilometer der wissenschaftlichen Literatur, geschichtswissenschaftliche Aufarbeitung, Pipapo, Menschheitsgeschichte, dann ist es doch sehr gut, dass sich ein Autor auch mal was zutraut, eine These und so, und dass da mal einfach eine Politik da auch drin steckt.
Und es ist in gewisser Weise paradox, denn was sie ja fortwährend kritisieren, ist ja eine Geschichtsschreibung, die die großen Zeitverläufe in eine Erzählung bringen will. Und was hier stark kritisiert wird, ist eigentlich eine Geschichtsschreibung des 19. jahrhunderts, die ich sagen würde, auch heute nicht mehr an Universitäten gelehrt wird. Die ist irgendwo natürlich noch im kollektiven Gedächtnis vorhanden. Und in der Schule bleibt da auch noch einiges von über. Große Männer machen große Geschichte, das waren die großen Bögen, die zeichnen wir hier nach. Und dann sind wir hier bei uns in der Gegenwart irgendwann angekommen. Aber ich würde sagen, die Geschichtswissenschaft ist ja heute eher eine, die extrem spezialisiert ist und die tatsächlich nur noch Einzelstories erzählt, aber nicht mehr diesen großen Bogen spannt. Aber diesen großen Bogen, den sie kritisieren, spannen sie selbst. Aber in der Form, dass sie sagen, ja, wir können es aber auch mal alles ganz anders erzählen. Und das ist eigentlich ein ganz guter Kniff, denn ich mag es schon sehr, wenn da am Schreibtisch sitzende sich sagen, ich erkläre jetzt die Welt noch mal auf eine neue Weise. Und das ist ein ganz souveräner Gestus, der aber hier sehr transparent gemacht wird. Das heißt, hier wird das nicht so insinuiert, sondern ganz klar kann ich mich dann auch dazu verhalten. Und das werden wir jetzt auch gleich tun. Aber an sich finde ich diese Geste gut. stattdessen erleben wir, glaube ich, sehr stark in der Wissenschaft, dass diese Thesen scheu so sehr vorherrscht, dass man dann irgendwann nur noch Dissertationen als große Materialsammlungen versteht und man gar nicht mehr das haben möchte. Also ein Vorwurf, den ich tatsächlich häufig in der Wissenschaft, als ich mal kurze Zeit überlegte, dort tätig zu sein, gemacht bekam, war tatsächlich einmal vöhetonistische Formulierung und das Zweite war, müssen es dann so starke Thesen sein.
Ja, genau. Im grunde wollen die alle nur noch die Anhänge der Arbeiten. Also wenn wir sagen, ja, der Anhang ist auch wichtig, aber man kann ja auch vorher mal schreiben, begründen, warum man überhaupt sich mit dem ganzen Material befasst und nur dokumentieren reicht dann halt nicht. Ich finde aber, und da können wir ja mal einsteigen, es ist klar, wir gehen nicht in die Schule und kommen in die Uni und dann haben wir nur Hobbs und Rousseau und so gelesen. Aber was den beiden ja auch wichtig ist, ist, dass auch diejenigen, die das nicht gelesen haben, in der Falle sitzen. Also dass dieses Denken sich einfach überall niederschlägt. Und da würde ich sagen, das stimmt und es war auch dringend, das aufzuarbeiten. Ich würde aber auch wieder sagen, sie sind nicht die ersten und sie kennen leider die deutsche Soziologie nicht. Also wir haben eine Abklärung der Aufklärung, die einmal den ganzen Planeten in die Luft gesprengt hat. Und da ist auch dieses Buch Anfänge nur eine Axt, die mal kurz in den Wald reinschlägt. Also wir haben es eigentlich schon viel krasser, und deswegen dieser Verweis auf Luhmann, wir haben es schon viel krasser darlegen.
oder die Dialektik der Aufklärung. Also das ist ja nun eine unglaubliche Aufklärungskritik, die da geleistet wird von Horkheimer unter Adorno. Das ist ja auch keine Sache, dass man hier so eine Fortschrittsgeschichte uns erzählen will.
Also der Unterschied zwischen einer Axt und einer Bombe ist dann doch nochmal, ob man nur Personen austauscht, die als Autoren die Geschichtsschreibung dominierten und dann andere an die Stelle setzt. Also streng handlungstheoretisch bleibt im grunde. oder ob man wirklich sagt, Luhmann 84, ja wir machen jetzt mal den Paradigmenwechsel. Wir nehmen den Menschen mal raus aus der Gleichung. Sagen trotzdem was über die Geschichte der Menschheit, aber als Gesellschaftstheorie. Und dann wird auch mal, es ist ja keine Marginalisierung des Menschen oder so, aber man nimmt doch die Sozialität mal ernst als Eigenwert, als fast Lebewesen. Man bedient sich mit ganz vielen biologischen Konzepten, um mal die Gesellschaft zu beschreiben. Und nicht immer alles auf und der Mensch wacht übrigens morgens auf und dann geht die Gesellschaft los oder so. Die ist einfach mal schon da und da kommen sie eben auch nicht raus. Das ist allerdings einfach auch der englischen Sprache geschuldet. Luhmann wurde nie so übersetzt. Dadurch haben sehr viele kluge Leute noch nie Luhmann gelesen. Das ist auch ein echtes Problem. Aber da sehe ich auch Graeber und Wengrow hier einfach weiterhin in dieser Falle sitzen.
Nur, dass so eine Zivilisationserzählung gebracht wird, bei der alles teleologisch besser, auf was besseres hinausläuft. Das ist ja etwas, was seit spätestens nach 1945 nicht mehr eine weitgehend vertretene Denkschule ist. Also das wundert mich, diese These, die da aufgemacht wird. Also zu sagen, die Menschheit hat sich aus horden und kleinen Gemeinschaften irgendwann entwickelt, hin zu größeren Gesellschaften organisiert, in Staaten mit Bürokratie und so weiter. Das ist sicherlich eine Denkweise, die ja zu intuitiv viele erst mal abnicken. Und da sagen die, na Vorsicht, so war das nicht. Und dann bringen sie ihr ganzes Material. Aber zu sagen, dass man so eine teleologische Geschichtsschreibung hat und dass man sagt, das ist dann immer weiter Fortschritt und wir haben uns immer verbessert, verbessert, verbessert, das ist vielleicht bei einer gewissen hegelianischen Schule noch vorhanden. Aber das ist nach 45 nicht haltbar. Und deswegen erwähnte ich Horkheimer und Adorno, die sich ja fragen, ja wie, wir waren jetzt so aufgeklärt aus der Mündigkeit, sich befreien und dann kann so was wie der Holocaust passieren. Wie ist das eigentlich möglich? Wann ist die Aufklärung in ihren eigenen Mythos umgeschlagen? Und da frage ich mich auch, Luhmann ist interessanterweise nicht zitiert, obwohl er ja auch auf Englisch zum Teil vorliegt. Und auch die Frankfurter Schule fehlt hier. Und auch frage ich mich dann, ob das wirklich so sein kann, dass bei Anthropologen und Asiologen diese idee von Teleologie so dominierend ist, dass man dagegen jetzt ankämpft. Also um das ein bisschen zuzuspitzen. Ich habe manchmal den Eindruck, kann es aber jetzt gerade für diese Forschung, die ich ja nicht kenne, nicht nachweisen, aber manchmal den Eindruck, dass da auch der ein oder andere Stroman aufgebaut wird, gegen den man kämpfen muss. Und ob es mehr dann doch geht gegen so eine populäre Geschichtsschreibung. Also es gibt ja zwei Leute, an denen sie sich auch namentlich besonders reiben. Das ist einmal Harari und der andere ist Steven Pinker. Kommen wir aber vielleicht auch nicht zu.
Genau, wobei Harari ja nur einmal so erwähnt wird.
Und nochmal gegen ende kommt es noch mal.
Also ich finde, das, was du jetzt beschrieben hast, ist, das muss man dann auch sagen, ein echter Fehler in dem Buch. Denn das kennt man auch aus der Wirtschaftswissenschaft. Es bietet sich immer an, im Föhtor noch mal zu schreiben, dass die neoklassischen Denker der Wirtschaftswissenschaftler ja echt unrecht hatten. Der aufgeklärte Einzelne und der alles regelnde Markt. Nur dann denkt man sich auch so, gegen wen schreibst du gerade wirklich noch an? Die Leute sind doch vor 100 Jahren schon ausgestorben, die das noch so vertreten haben. Und das ist hier natürlich auch.
Als Hans-Werner-Sinn.
Ja gut, der letzte R, dem kann man es noch festmachen. Wenn man jetzt mit Anfänge in ein Uniseminar ginge, in welcher Uni in Deutschland auch immer, in der Geschichtswissenschaft, man findet dort alles schon vor, was die anmerken. Das ist im grunde dieses gesetzte Wissen. Ich finde, es lohnt sich trotzdem, sich dieses Buch mal so, wie sie es konzipiert haben, und auch aufbauen, durchzulesen. Denn es ist so dieses Transferangebot für die Allgemeinheit. Man kann bei so einem Buch davon ausgehen, dass es nicht nur 3000 Leute lesen in Deutschland, sondern das ist so allgemein. Wir sehen ja auch, wo die Besprechungen sind. Deutschlandfunk, Zeitfahrts, alle süddeutsche haben ihre Besprechung gemacht. Das ist natürlich bei den ganzen anderen Büchern, auf die man, es gibt so viele, auf die man jetzt verweisen könnte, da nicht stattfindet. Gut, also sie fangen an mit Ungleichheitsfragen. Das fand ich besonders gut, denn Graeber ist ja bekannt dafür, eigentlich so ein vordenker für ihr fühlt euch ungleich behandelt, ungleich ausgestattet, ungleich vermögend. Ja, dann bin ich euer Autor. Und es wird hier gleich mal vom Tisch geräumt. So im Sinne von, jetzt kriegen wir mal die großen Fragen an. Wir beginnen hier nicht bei der Ungleichheit. Denn dann sitzen wir ja nur schon in der Falle. Auch diejenigen, die nichts haben, nehmen ja am Kapitalismus teil. Und ich will ja nichts für die schreiben, die nichts haben, sondern ich will ja was gegen den Kapitalismus allgemein schreiben. Ungleichheit, Leute, da habe ich andere Bücher geschrieben. Da seid ihr hier falsch. Und ich verweise dann gleich auf den Ursprung der Polis, die kennen wir natürlich als die griechische Stadtorganisation. Also die antikgriechische 2000 vor Christus, jetzt wirklich super alt. Und er sagt nochmal, Politik, Politee, Police, überall steckt es drin. Also wir haben es bis heute mitgeschleppt, dass uns die allgemeinen Fragen, die Fragen für die Gesellschaft, die Gemeinschaft irgendwie dann doch kümmern. Und wir müssen miteinander klarkommen. Das ist der Sinn der Übung. Wir brauchen Impulskontrolle, soziale Gestaltung, irgendeine Art von Vernunft sollte auch noch. Und dann fassen sie sich relativ zügig, dass sie sagen, so 30.000 Jahre wollen wir jetzt nochmal neu erzählen. Ich habe ja in der letzten Folge schon auf Gunnar Heinsons Dissertation hingewiesen. Schon 10.000 Jahre ist eine echte Grenze. Also etwas über die Gesellschaft vor 10.000 Jahren. Da gibt es keine Dokumente. Da haben irgendwelche Frauen mit ihren händen an den wänden nochmal hinterlassen, dass sie da waren. So im Sinne von ich war hier. So, aber mehr wissen wir da eigentlich kaum. Da wird es dann auch archäologisch wirklich kompliziert. Und da muss man auch Erkenntnisse wirklich erstreiten im Disput. Sonst weiß man überhaupt nicht, mit was man es dazu zu tun hat. In der Sicht, ja, sie nehmen sich diese 30.000 Jahre, kommen aber gleich auf Russo und Hobbes zu sprechen. Und da würde ich sagen, ja, versucht ihr auch nochmal eure Kritik. Aber ich habe das bei Luhmann schon so spektakulär gut gelesen. Bemüht euch gern. Ich finde, sie machen es auch gut. Denn so langsam hängt uns allen zum Hals heraus, wenn wegen Klimakrise, wegen Demografie, wegen was auch immer, irgendwer in der Zeitung noch mal schreibt, wir brauchen einen neuen Gesellschaftsvertrag. So als hätten wir einen alten schon gehabt.
Ja, und das war auch nie von Russo so gedacht. Also das machen sie auch noch mal klar. Aber das ist mir auch nicht neu, was sie da klammern. Aber es ist gut, dass sie es mal vielleicht in einem populären Buch aufschreiben. Es ist ja nicht so, dass diese Urgesellschaft, die Russo da zeichnet, den Naturzustand, wie er es nennt, dass das etwas wirklich Existentes war, sondern dass es eine theoretische Prämisse, die Russo setzt, um darauf dann eine Theorie der Gesellschaft zu entwickeln. Aber es geht hier nicht darum, dass Russo sagt, so waren unsere Anfänge. Und das machen sie sehr deutlich. Aber sie sagen, die Rezeption von Russo war häufig die, dass man dachte, ah ja, genau, so war der Naturzustand. Da sind die alle wie wild rumgerannt. Und irgendwann kam dann tatsächlich da jemand und hat den Zaun gebaut. Und damit entstand die moderne Gesellschaft.
Ja, in der Hinsicht gehen sie da sehr unraffiniert. Bügeln sie so über das Thema drüber. Denn da hätte ich mir auch mehr gewünscht. Diese Grundlage kann man anders legen. Ich habe extra nochmal nachgelesen jetzt in den 1000 Seiten Geschichte des politischen Denkens, Rousseau und Hobbs. Und es ist ja tatsächlich so, beide haben diese vertragsideen irgendwie drin. Menschen stellen fest, ich bin hier nicht alleine und ich kenne den anderen gar nicht, ich muss trotzdem mit ihm klarkommen. Und du hast das richtig zu Rousseau gesagt. Bei Hobbs steckt das aber noch drin. Also der Professor, der hier im Text, also in dem Socomding über Hobbs schreibt, sagt auch nochmal, es wird missverstanden, der Mensch ist das Wolf ein Wolf. Denn es geht nicht darum, dass der Wolf so als das triebgesteuerte Wesen hergestellt wird, sondern Hobbs erklärt nochmal ganz deutlich, wenn es keine Regeln gibt, gilt der Egoismus. Und dann ist es einfach super klug und auch verständlich, dass man auf seinen ersten Vorteil, also dass man auf sich zuerst auf seinen Vorteil schaut und andere darunter auch leiden. Das haben wir ja bis heute, also Freiheit, Freiheit der andersdenkenden und so weiter, diese ganzen Regelungen. Das allerdings steckt dann bei Rousseau schon nicht mehr drin. Also beide Autoren stellen fest, also Gott ist irgendwie tot und trotzdem muss es geregelt werden. Also wir können jetzt nicht weiterhin, wie im Mittelalter den Herrscher immer malen mit so einer Bandarole und der Kopf ist eigentlich schon im Himmel und da kommen wir gar nicht hin. sondern wir müssen es aus sich, aus uns heraus begründen. Wir brauchen also irgendeine vertragsidee. Und da machen sich ja die beiden also in Anfängen sehr lustig über Rousseau. Und Rousseau wusste ja selber nicht, wie ihm geschah. Er hat halt diese komischen 70 Seiten damals vorgelegt, hat eigentlich viel mehr geplant, aber war dann auch nicht in der Lage mehr zu liefern. trotzdem hat er dann dieses Ding vorgelegt, Gesellschaftsvertrag, Pipa Po. Und es hängt dann trotzdem alles irgendwie in der Luft. Es ist ja trotzdem nicht verortet. Nur weil mein Gott aus der Gleichung rausnimmt, heißt es ja noch nicht, dass es geregelt ist. Und Rousseau hat sich dann auch hinter der idee versteckt zu sagen, ich brauche ja gar keine hopsche idee vom Naturzustand des einzelnen Menschen, weil die Gesellschaft ist ja da. Wir haben ja keine Einzelkämpfer. Auch derjenige, der nicht mit dem Vertrag einverstanden sich erklärt, wird ja trotzdem gemaßregelt und so weiter. Also die Gesellschaft ist erstmal da. Also hat er sie einfach gesetzt. Genau da beginnen ja eigentlich die Fragen. Wie ist denn jetzt diese soziale Ordnung möglich? Und dann sagt Rousseau, die ist halt einfach da. Und dann irgendwelche ideen von, ja dann regeln wir das jetzt mal mit einem Vertrag. Also einfach zu sagen, es ist halt einfach wie es ist. Das ist halt keine gute Antwort für den Staat. Und in der Ansicht machen sie sich sehr drüber lustig, dass Rousseau ja dann doch im grunde so von einem Fürsten durchgefütterter Typ ist, der halt an Schreibwettbewerben teilnahm. Seinerseits aber schon feststellte, so richtig überzeugt bin ich von meinem eigenen Werk auch nicht. Und die Leser damals waren halt noch nicht so, oh der große Rousseau und so weiter, sondern haben ihn ja auch ein bisschen drüber lustig gemacht. Ja gut, das ist halt so ein Text. Kann man lesen, muss man nicht, keine Ahnung. Gehen wir halt mal irgendwie mit um. Ist halt so Literatur im großen Kanon, aber jetzt nichts grundlegendes. Und da finde ich es dann aber ziemlich gut, dieses zweite Kapitel Sündhafte Freiheit. Also wie sie vorher das so ein bisschen abräumen. Wir stecken in der Rousseau-Falle, vor allem dann Francis Fukuyama, den sie da nochmal nennen mit seinen Origins of Political order.
Genau, Fukuyama ist einer der letzten Hegelianer, also ein rechter Hegelianer, wenn man so möchte, der auch eine Geschichtsentfaltung tatsächlich gesehen hat. Nicht im Sinne hin zu einem Sozialismus-Kommunismus, sondern er sagte, jetzt hat 89 die liberale Demokratie gesiegt, ende der Geschichte, These haben wir alle schon mal gehört. Aber das ist absolut Hegel weitergedacht, in einer sehr eigenartigen Weise zugegebenermaßen, damit jetzt nicht alle Hegelianer verrückt spielen, wenn ich das hier sage. Aber dennoch ist da noch diese teleologische Geschichtsschreibung präsent gewesen und nur deshalb konnte er überhaupt zu der These gelangen zu sagen, jetzt wo Ost-West-Konflikt beendet ist, haben wir das ende erreicht. Die liberale Demokratie hat gesiegt. Entfaltung der Geschichte. Nun drohen uns oder blühen uns langweilige Zeiten.
Genau, und sie gehen die Liste so durch. Jared Diamond hat damals 2012 auch noch The World Until Yesterday, so ein großes Diagnoseding vorgelegt. Steven Pinker hat zumindest schon von der Hobbesian Trap, also von der Hobbes-Falle, in der wir alle drinstecken. Das finden sie gut, widersprechen ihm aber auch wieder, wie man das so denken kann. Kritik an Harari kommt dann später, als er noch mal von den Affen horden früher sprach und so weiter. Und sie kommen ja dann auf dieses indigene Leben zu sprechen, das der Mensch ja irgendwann entdeckt hat. Also klar, man hat diese Aufklärungstexte der letzten 400 Jahre, aber man hat eben auch eine echte Welt, die man damals erobert hat. Nicht nur geistig, sondern auch physisch, also die ganze Kolonialisierung. Und das finde ich eigentlich dann ziemlich clever, es in diesem, also es war für mich auch das wichtigste Kapitel gleich zu beginnen. Wahrscheinlich haben sie es auch aus gründen gleich am Anfang gebracht, denn historisch gesehen hätte man auch erst über die Maya, Minka und Inka und wie auch immer. Das kommt aber relativ spät, da würde ich sagen, dieses Staatskapitel kann man dann auch überspringen als eines der längsten, während dieses Kolonialisierung, also wir entdecken die alte Geschichte, dass man gar nicht chronologisch anfängt, wie tatsächlich die Anfänge waren, sondern wie wir sie wieder entdeckt haben. Dass man das an Anfang zieht, fand ich ziemlich gut. Und sie legen es ja gleich drauf an und sagen, wir machen es mal nicht eurozentrisch. Da würde ich sagen, ja, das macht also kein gängiger Professor in Deutschland, der irgendwas mit Geschichte zu tun hat, sitzt noch in der eurozentrischen Falle, würde ich sagen. Also das haben jetzt alle irgendwie durchschaut, dass man das im Kontext der Welt immer sehen muss.
Nur mal schauen, zum Beispiel bei C. H. Beck gibt es ja jetzt ganze Reihen von Geschichtsbüchern, Geschichte des Meeres, Geschichte der Imperien, was weiß ich. Die denken alle nicht eurozentrisch in dem Sinne. Also klar beziehen die sich stark auf europäische Quellen auch, weil da die Quellenlage sehr gut ist. Aber wir haben ja nun auch Post-Colonial Studies gehabt und haben sie immer noch. Wir haben Leute wie Omi Kababa, Edward Said, François Noir, Gayatri Spivak. Also die sind ja alle an Universitäten präsent und werden in Seminaren gelehrt und haben natürlich den Blick auf die Geschichte verändert. Und niemand würde jetzt heute sagen, ich schreibe mal ein Geschichtsbuch, das beginnt und endet mit Europa. Und die großen Figuren sind Napoleon und Bismarck. Das würde in dieser Weise nicht mehr stattfinden. Also das wundert mich dann ein bisschen sehr. Das ist vielleicht so, wenn man Guido Knopps Weltgeschichten da im ZDF oder so schaut, da ist das noch vielleicht wie früher. Aber das ist ja nicht der Maßstab. Was ich ganz gut finde, ist, dass sie auch Thesen stark in diese Sachen reingehen. Also das ist noch ein paar Seiten früher, aber ich will es doch noch vorlesen. Da heißt es, das ultimative Problem der Menschheitsgeschichte ist, wie wir sehen werden, nicht der gleichberechtigte Zugang zu materiellen Ressourcen, Land, Kalorien, Produktionsmitteln, obwohl diese Dinge offensichtlich sehr wichtig sind, sondern die Frage, ob wir alle die gleiche Möglichkeit haben, an Entscheidungen mitzuwirken, die unser Zusammenleben betreffen. Natürlich setzt die Wahrnehmung dieser Möglichkeit voraus, dass es überhaupt etwas Sinnvolles zu entscheiden gibt. Was wir hier also sehen können, entfaltet werden soll auch eine politische Theorie. Und diese versucht man jetzt zu lancieren über diese Anfangsgeschichten. Und man möchte gleich in Frage stellen, ob Entscheidungen, so wie wir sie heute treffen, zum Beispiel mit der Wahlurne oder bürokratische Entscheidungen, ob das die richtige Art und Weise ist, wie wir entscheiden. oder ob noch andere Formen der Entscheidung, ich könnte jetzt auch sagen Mitbestimmung, möglich sind. Graeber kommt ja aus dem Occupy Wall Street Spektrum. Und manche werden sich vielleicht erinnern. Da war es ja so, dass diese Besetzer und Aktivisten keine Sprecher hatten. Also das war jetzt nicht. Fridays for Future will das ja auch nicht so richtig haben. Aber natürlich ist es Luisa Neubau. Die wird am ende gefragt. Und wie stehen sie jetzt dazu? Lehnen sie Gewalt ab, bla bla bla? Das gab es ja bei Occupy Wall Street in dieser Weise nicht, sondern es gab diese idee, dass alle gleich mit sprechen können. Dass also eine wirkliche Vielstimmigkeit ermöglicht wird. Inwieweit das wirklich gelingen kann. Wir sind da erst mal skeptisch. jedenfalls würde Graeber uns jetzt sofort um die Ohren hauen. Ja, jetzt lest mal das Buch. Dann könnt ihr mal sehen, man konnte auch anders Entscheidungen und Mitbestimmungen organisieren. Ich habe ja schon mal bedenkungen zum Thema Bürgerrette geäußert. Will das auch jetzt nicht hier in dieser Weise verflachen. Aber zumindest muss man ganz klar sagen, aus dieser Stoßrichtung kommt das. Also es wird hier überlegt, wie kann Gesellschaft anders organisiert sein und wie kann dann auch der Entscheidungsprozess anders aussehen?
Ich würde es noch ein bisschen anders formulieren. Die Frage, wie kann Gesellschaft aussehen? Da steckt ja immer dieses Lenin-Ding drin. Die Revolution beginnt nicht, wenn Menschen unzufrieden sind, sondern wenn sie eine bessere idee haben und die durchsetzen wollen. Und das drehen die beiden ja so ein bisschen um. Die sagen ja nicht, wir könnten uns dafür entscheiden, ein besseres Leben zu führen, sondern die sagen ja, eigentlich hat die Menschheit immer ein besseres Leben geführt, bis wir in die Sackgasse der modernität geraten sind. Und eigentlich müssten wir jetzt mal entscheiden, das nicht weiterzumachen, sondern einfach wieder die Stufe zurückzugehen, die wir– und deswegen diese Wichtigkeit dieses Kapitels am Anfang– die Realität, die wir uns wünschen, die wir vorfanden, dort wo wir kolonialisierten, bevor wir den unseren Lebensstil aufzwangen und über die Krankheiten, die wir mitbrachten, noch 90 Prozent der Leute dort ausrotteten. Das ist natürlich eine ziemlich scharfe These, die sie aber super ernst nehmen. Und in deren Sicht, finde ich, so ein Buch schwankt immer auch zwischen ist es noch ein Sachbuch, ist es eigentlich Literatur. Es ist ja einfach mal eine Belletristik. Also man kann das durchaus auch so lesen. Und dafür fand ich das richtig gut, so als These zu sagen, unsere Aufklärung, die wir uns erarbeitet haben, weil wir irgendwann feststellten, Gott ist ja gar nicht da, wir müssen es mit uns selber regeln. Also sammeln wir jetzt mal so brainstormingmäßig alle ideen zusammen und haben dann eine Geschichte des politischen Denkens. Diese Aufklärung ist gar nicht aus uns herausgewachsen, sondern Autoren haben in zwei Schritten zuerst die guten ideen aus den kolonialisierten Gebieten aufgegriffen. Menschen sind ja hingefahren, haben erobert und haben festgestellt, wie die da leben und haben davon erzählt. Und in dem zweiten Schritt haben wir dann die Arbeiten, die uns das dokumentieren, genommen und sie einfach umgedeutet. Wir haben einfach den Ursprung, dass da irgendwo anders noch andere Menschen lebten und zwar anders. Das haben wir alles rausmarginalisiert aus den Texten, sondern wir haben einfach behauptet, es ist unsere eigene idee von Freiheit, brüderlichkeit, Gleichheit, wie auch immer und so. Und das finde ich ehrlich gesagt ist ein scharfes, aber auch notwendiges Urteil an der Aufklärung, wie wir sie heute abfeiern, in irgendwelchen drei Satz-Philosophiesendungen zum Beispiel. Dass wir immer wieder darauf zu sprechen kommen, wie toll doch der Mensch plötzlich hat er die Augen aufgeschlagen, begann zu reflektieren und stellte fest, Freiheit ist doch super wichtig. Und dann kommen die Autoren und sagen, erstens mal war die Freiheit idee die idee der anderen. Als wir sie zerstört haben, haben wir sie zumindest noch in der Semantik mitgeschleift, aber in der Struktur hat sie sich nicht wiedergefunden. Und die beiden sind ja nicht zurückhaltend, sondern sagen dann, wir sitzen heute in einer Falle, es gibt keinen Fleck mehr auf der erde, wo man einem Steuereinzieher entgehen kann. Und das ist das Gegenteil von dem, was wir immer abfeiern als wir sind ja die kinder der Aufklärung.
Ja, ja, wir haben dann natürlich auch libertäre Geister, also linkslibertäre Geister. Und diesen Transfer, den du da jetzt gerade beschrieben hast, den machen sie sehr schön fest. Und ich würde auch sagen, das ist am besten nachvollziehbar, wenn es um die Jesuiten geht. Die Jesuiten sind ja ausgeströmt in die ganze Welt. Aber bleiben wir jetzt mal bei Amerika. Und dort waren sie und haben gesehen, wie die Kolonialherren sich aufführen, wie aber die Jesuiten sich auch zum Teil selbst aufführen. Und die Jesuiten waren an intellektuellem Austausch aber interessiert, haben also Kontakt aufgenommen zu diesen Leuten und haben dann sehr lange Berichte verfasst über das, was sie dort erlebt haben. Und diese haben eine gewisse Popularität genossen, dann im Europa, im alten Europa. Rousseau und viele weitere haben dann auch zu diesen Berichten gegriffen und sagten, da ist er erstaunlich, die leben da auf diese Weise. Aber wieso haben die jetzt gar nicht einen König? oder warum haben die nicht eine Verwaltung und diese ganzen Dinge? Warum regeln die das auf jene Weise? Und die These der Autoren ist nun, dass das also den Funken der Aufklärung eher entzündet hat, als das, was du jetzt gerade da beschrieben hast. Man wird morgens wach und denkt, Freiheit wäre eigentlich auch eine tolle Sache.
Diese ganze Säkologisierung wird ja komplett marginalisiert.
Das wird tatsächlich als etwas gezeigt, was einfach so migriert. Also es gibt ja das Stück, wir kennen das vermutlich alle, Die Physiker von Dürrenmatt. Da heißt es ja, wenn eine idee in der Welt ist, dann ist sie in der Welt. Und dann kann man die auch versuchen einzusperren, aber eigentlich ist das nicht mehr möglich. Und daran musste ich stark denken, und das fand ich auch wirklich das Stärkste an dem ganzen Buch, dass man sagt, na ja, wenn man in so Berichten liest, die organisieren Sexualität auf diese Weise, die organisieren kindererziehung auf jene Weise und vor allem Staatlichkeit wird ganz anders gedacht. Und man kann auch Freiheit absoluter setzen, als der Fall ist momentan in Europa. Dann hat man da so den ein oder anderen Samen gesät und der wird sich dann schon entwickeln. Nur was dann in Europa geschah, du hast es beschrieben, war, dass man die ursprünglichen Quellen einfach rausgelassen hat und das als was eigenes verkauft hat. Also in gewisser Weise Plagiat, könnte man sagen.
Das ist ein etikettenschwindel.
Ja.
Und da ist es auch wirklich wortgewaltig. Ich kannte diese ganzen Quellen auch nicht. Man kann ja durchaus mal reinlesen. Also die These ist wie folgt. Man fährt streng in der Hierarchie. Wenn man als Kolonialkraft losfährt, fahren ja nicht die kinder und Frauen, sondern dann fahren halt die Männer, die eingebunden sind in eine Befehlskette und so weiter und erobern dann irgendwo. Und dann stellen die fest, die leben ja hier ganz schön frei und die wollen ja auch was von uns. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass wir da hinkommen und die einfach ausbeuten, sondern man hat dann festgestellt, wir kommen hier mit Hierarchie und Befehl und stoßen auf Rhetorik und Empathie. Und dann sind die Leute aber da und kommen auch wirklich mit denen ins Gespräch. Und diese Jesuiten, also da ist ja diese eine Mission, sie fahren halt los, kommen Amerika an und stellen dann fest, erstens mal, das sind ja Kulturen, die wir hier vorfinden. Das ist ja nicht nur ein wilder Haufen von lebenden Biomasse. Und das beeindruckt uns auch so ein bisschen, wenn man sich das so anbietet. Und dann schicken sie Briefe nach Hause. Zum Beispiel von Pater Jerome lalemande 1644. Und er schreibt dann über die Völker, die man vorfand. Fast keiner von ihnen, der nicht in der Lage wäre, in Wissensangelegenheiten in passenden Begriffen äußerst geschickt zu sprechen und zu argumentieren. Ich kann wahrheitsgetreu sagen, dass sie den Europäern und den in Frankreich lebenden Menschen in keiner Weise unterlegen sind. Fast alle erweisen sich in ihren Geschäften, reden, Aufmerksamkeiten und umgangsfroren Kniffen und Feinheiten als Klüger, als die gerissenen Bürger und Händler in Frankreich. Man findet also Zivilisationsfonds vor und ist von ihnen so begeistert, dass die beiden Autoren dann auch noch mal schreiben. Mir kam so dieses Disney Paradox in den Blick, weil wir haben so Pocahontas und so weiter oder bis hin zu Avatar. Man immer die Geschichten erzählt werden, wie irgendwelche Völker erobert werden. Irgendwer findet das so faszinierend dort, dass er die Seite wechselt und plötzlich für die Unterdrückten mitkämpft und dann das große Happy End und so weiter. Während diese Geschichten selbst natürlich im krass marktwirtschaftlich durchorganisierten Hollywood einfach in Los Angeles zusammengebastelt werden, uns dann aber als die große Moral verkauft werden. Und es ist genau das nur als Menschheitsgeschichte. Also das, was uns Disney da produziert, genau das so wird uns hier als Menschheitsgeschichte dargelegt.
Nur ohne Happy End?
Ohne Happy End. Alle sterben im grunde. 90 Prozent sterben allein wegen den Krankheiten. Und dann werden noch viele einfach gewalttätig da aus dem Weg geräumt. Und aus Sicht der Eroberten, die in Freiheit leben, bis hin zu eigenen Familien, Sexualitätsformen und so weiter, stellen dann fest, nicht nur wir sollen hier unterjocht werden, sondern auch die, die kommen, sind schon unterjochte. Die hängen dann von irgendwelchen Befehlen, haben sie nicht in der Lage, selbst einen Gedanken zu äußern, trauen sich nichts zu. Kriegen dann die Erzählung, was bei euch im reichen Paris leben Bettler auf der Straße? Was seid ihr für ein unmenschliches Volk? Und kriegen die ganze Zeit diese Vorwürfe. Es gibt dieses Wendat-Volk in Amerika und Kanada. Die sich für die besseren Franzosen halten, nachdem sie hören, von wem sie eigentlich erobert werden.
Ja, es ist ganz erstaunlich. Auch da gibt es eine schöne Stelle. Laurentin hat in seinen Memoiren davon berichtet, er sagt, jene amerikanischen Ureinwohner nekten uns andauernd mit den durch den Geldverkehr ausgelösten missständen und Unordnungen, die sie in unseren Städten beobachtet hatten. Es hat keinen Sinn, ihnen entgegenzuhalten, wie nützt sich die Institution des Privateigentums als Stütze der Gesellschaft ist. Sie ziehen alles, was man dazu sagen kann, ins Löcherliche. Kurz, sie streiten und kämpfen nicht, noch beleidigen sie einander. Sie spotten über Kunst und Wissenschaft und lachen über die Rangordnung, die bei uns herrscht. Sie bezeichnen uns als Sklaven und nennen uns arme Seelen, deren Leben wertlos ist, weil wir uns selbst erniedrigen, indem wir uns einem Manne, dem König, unterwerfen, der alle Macht besitzt und durch kein Gesetz als seinen eigenen Willen gebunden ist.
Ja, und da habe ich mir das auch wirklich mal ausgeschrieben. Man kann es hier mal vorlesen. Es ist auch wirklich spektakulär. Also die Wen Dat haben einfach eigene Philosophen. Da gibt es einen Philosophen und Staatsmann und das heißt Kon-Dia-Rong, 1703. Ich kannte das alles nicht, aber es scheint wohl in irgendwelchen Büchereien gut dokumentiert zu sein. 1703. Ich denke, nachdem die Franzosen eine Weile da waren, seit sechs Jahren über den Zustand der europäischen Gesellschaft nach, also wir kriegen ja sozusagen eine Gegenaufklärung aus den kolonialisierten Gebieten. Ich versichere, dass das, was ihr Geld nennt, der Teufel, der Teufel ist. Der Tyran der Franzosen, der Quell, alles Bösen. Das verderben der Seelen und das Schlachthaus der lebenden. Zu glauben, man könnte im Land des geldes leben und seine eigene Seele bewahren, ist, als glaubte man, sein Leben im grunde eines Sees bewahren zu können. Geld ist der Vater von Luxus, Ausschweifen, schwindel, Lüge, Betrug, Unaufrichtigkeit, das schlechteste Verhalten des Menschen der Welt. Das schlechteste Verhalten der Welt. Also das hat man denen so entgegengehalten. Und gleichzeitig, was haben die Franzosen über die Wendat geschrieben? Sie erwidern Gastfreundschaft und helfen einander dergestalt, das für alle gesorgt ist, ohne dass es in ihren Städten und Dörfern einen unwürdigen Bettler gibt. Und sie hielten es daher für sehr schlecht, als sie wahrnahmen oder vernahmen. Es gab in Frankreich eine große Zahl solch bedürftiger Bettler und dachten, der Grund dafür sei unsere mangelnde Nächstenliebe, wofür sie uns schwere Vorwürfe machten. Also man kommt da hin und kriegt eine Lektion in Sachen Nächstenliebe. Was ihr lasst bei euch zu Hause, die Leute auf der Straße sterben, seid ihr bescheuert. Während man gleichzeitig, und das ist ja das Bild sozusagen, die Waffe auf die Brust gedrückt kriegt, weil wir erobern dich jetzt und so. Und dann kriegt man erst mal so einen moralischen Einwand davor gelegt. Also in der Hinsicht, hier kann man das mal nachlesen, das ist auch wirklich spektakulär. Und sie sparen ja dann auch nicht mit diesen harten Thesen. Und es ist im grunde diese These, also nicht nur die Aufklärung ist ein Betrug, es ist ein Plagiatsfall, sondern auch wir haben uns bewusst dafür entschieden, so zu leben. Es ist keine Aufstiegsgesellschaft im Sinne von wir haben irgendwann mal angefangen, entdeckungen zu machen und dann haben wir einen technischen Fortschritt und deswegen war einiges möglich, sondern irgendwann haben wir uns für Geld entschieden, Eigentum erfunden, plötzlich gab es Hierarchien, plötzlich wurde Macht daraus abgeleitet und so weiter und so fort und das hat uns alles in eine große Falle gesetzt. Ja und es waren also die wender zum einen, aber auch das andere Volk, diese Montagneis nascapi, von dem kam der Vorwurf, ihr Franzosen, die uns versklaven wollt, seid ja selber nur Sklaven. Ihr lebt ja in beständiger Angst vor euren Vorgesetzten. Das hat man denen so gesagt. Ja und klar, man hat halt nur erstmal die Soldaten und so vorgefunden, aber wenn man sich die Gesellschaften bis heute, was wir als Zivilisationsgeschichte anschauen, muss man sagen, ja das stimmt. Das kann man jetzt nicht so ganz absprechen. Und in deren Sicht, ja, man müsste jetzt echt noch mal fragen, die Jesuiten und so weiter, wie sieht die eigentliche, kann man noch mal die Ursprünge, die Quellenarbeit neu auswerten und die neuen Schlüsse daraus ziehen? Also die Aufklärung muss eigentlich noch mal wiederholt werden. Also die Aufklärung im Sinne von die Arbeit, die dahintersteckt, Auswertungen und Urteile zu fällen.
Das ist ja die idee dieses Großprojekts, das dann eigentlich hier fragmentgeblieben ist. Auch wenn es sehr umfangreich ist, ist es fragmentgeblieben. Nur würde ich jetzt hier mal einhaken wollen. Nun ist ja nicht in Zweifel zu ziehen, dass es diese Äußerungen und Beobachtungen seitens der Ureinwohner gegeben hat. Und die sind ja auch sehr richtig wohl. Nur frage ich mich, ob wir nicht hier eine eigenartige Selektion dann wiederum vorfinden in diesem Buch, dass wir ganz stark immer auf das gelotst werden, wo es dann tatsächlich eine pluralere Gesellschaft gab oder eine Organisationstruktur, die gut funktioniert hat. Und ob wir nicht doch auch anerkennen müssen, dass die Sackgasse, in der wir uns befinden, zwar eine Sackgasse ist, aber vielleicht doch auch ein angenehmes Leben oder einen gewissen Komfort mit sich bringen, der nicht ganz so von der Hand zu weisen ist. Also ich frage mich tatsächlich, ob wir so viel daraus lernen können, außer dass wir natürlich sehen, dass sich wo blanke Macht, oder man könnte auch sagen blanke Gewalt entscheidet, dass wir lernen können, da ist es selten so, dass sich unbedingt das Vernünftigere durchsetzt. sondern es setzt sich durch, wer gewalttätige auftritt oder mehr Gewalt inne hat. Und das waren in diesem Falle jetzt die Europäer. Und die haben sich da breit gemacht, ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste. Und haben dadurch viele Kulturen zerstört, viele Organisationsformen zerschlagen, Menschen umgebracht. Aber es heißt ja nicht zugleich, dass das, was wir hier skizziert finden, etwas erstrebenswertes in dem Sinne ist, dass wir sagen, ja, aber das sind eigentlich ganz gute Gesellschaftsformen. Ist das wirklich so, dass man sagen würde, die Alternative blitzt hier auf? Sie sagen ja auch immer wieder an einigen Stellen, sie wollen hier nichts verklären. Und natürlich gab es da auch Folter. Und da gab es auch Gewaltexzesse. Da gab es irgendwelche Rituale, die vollführt wurden, blutigste Art, also je dann aufgeteilt auf die verschiedenen Stämme, wird das ja dann alles mal durchdekliniert. Aber ich frage mich wirklich, liegt man hier nicht auch einer gewissen Illusion auf, wenn man glaubt, dass die anderen Gesellschaften, die da geschaffen wurden, wirklich bessere gewesen sind?
Also das haben wir ja beim letzten Mal schon mit dieser Frage geklärt. Angenommen, es wird ein Planet hinter Pluto gefunden, der so funktioniert wie die erde. Und man hat aber nur eine Rakete für 10.000 Leute. würde man alles an zivilisatorischen und technischen, vor allem was ja Komfort im grunde bedeutet, Fortschritt wirklich zurücklassen, um dann in so einer Kolonie unerobert nochmal neu anzufangen, wie wir sie hier idealtypischerweise vorfinden. Und da steckt ja hier ein Signalwort im Text, wo ich auch nochmal sagen kann, aber das wäre dann auch mehr für dich eigentlich. Sie haben Luhmann nicht gelesen und sind über das politische Denken so hinweggeflogen, dass sie eigentlich jedem Geschichtswissenschaftler, der an Unis tätig ist, vor den Kopf stoßen und kommen dann plötzlich auf den Basiskommunismus zu sprechen. Und sagen dann, das ist gar nicht das Gegenteil der freien Wirtschaft, sondern seine Grundlage. Und da dachte ich mir, schade, dass sie jetzt nicht wirklich mal mit Marx anfangen, da er ja auch ein gesellschaftliches entwicklungsmodell mit diesen Stufen, das hat ja Dietmar Daert in seinem 100 Seiten Marx noch mal ganz wunderbar auch zusammengefasst, für alle, die ansonsten Marx nicht lesen und im Original oder sonst damit zu tun haben. Aber diese idee von Marx ist ja zu sagen, ja wir haben Eigentum, Kapitalismus, Ausbeutung und kommen damit auf eine gesellschaftliche Stufe, auf der wir uns dann damit befassen können zu sagen, und jetzt nehmen wir mal ein paar Sachen, die wir als negativ erkennen und sagen, die nehmen wir jetzt mal raus, ohne dass wir wieder zurückfallen ins urmodell von Hobbs. Und jetzt müssen wir alle selber kämpfen.
Frage, Gesellschaft und sowas.
Genau. Wir haben einfach es hinbekommen, technische Geräte zu entwickeln, die es erlauben, dass 95 Prozent der Leute sich nicht mit getreide befassen und trotzdem welches haben. Das kann man ja als zivilisatorischen Fortschritt festhalten und trotzdem nochmal neue Fragen stellen. Und ich finde, es ist ja nicht ohne Grund, dass die beiden am Anfang sagen, es schreiben ganz schön viele Leute ganz schön viel diagnostisches Zeug über unsere Gegenwart und alle stellen irgendwie fest, die unzufriedenheit ist groß. Und jetzt bietet es sich, finde ich schon an, dieses Anfängerkapitel, also dieses über die Kolonialisierungsgeschichte zu nehmen und sich zu fragen, wie organisieren wir jetzt Familien? Ganz konkret in Deutschland. Was sollte die bundesregierung machen? Und wir haben eben die Stagnation jetzt gehabt, das ist Vater, Mutter, Kind oder Vater, Mutter, Kind, Kind. Das war so die einzige Variation. Bei Vater, Mutter, Kind, Kind, Kind, Kind wird es schon schwierig, weil man kein Auto findet, in das vier kinder reinpassen. Das ist ja die Zwangslage, in der wir drinstecken und wir fragen uns, warum eigentlich Autos? Wir bauen 70.000 verschiedene modelle und es gibt aber nur drei auf dem Markt, wo mal drei kindersitze hinterein passen, nebeneinander und die Türen noch zugehen. Das ist doch bescheuert. Und jetzt haben wir halt so eine FDP, die da im Familienministerium, Justizministerium sitzt und einfach sagt, wir machen es jetzt mal neu. Und genauso haben wir ja auch die ganzen Überlegungen, wie gehen wir mit unseren Städten jetzt um? Ulm, wir haben ja auch über Ulm gesprochen, wo man einfach sagt, ja, es gibt kein Gott mehr, aber deswegen müssen wir das ja nicht gegen Geld austauschen, sondern wir können einfach sagen, ne, die Stadt regelt jetzt mal hier, wie Grund und boden vergeben wird, sondern nicht der höchstbietende wie in Hamburg. Ja, und all das bietet sich eigentlich an, jetzt mal zu machen.
Ich würde auch übrigens zu der Stadt Ulm noch gerade hinzufügen, es ist ja keineswegs so am Immobilien- und Grundstückmarkt, dass da tatsächlich nur die Marktkräfte walten. Also es ist ja nicht einfach so, dass es etwas gibt wie einen Markt für Immobilien und Grundstücke und der teuerste und der, der am meisten bietet, der bekommt das Grundstück, sondern das sind ja gar keine freien Märkte, weil da ganz viel unter der Hand passiert. Korruption in irgendwelchen Räten, die entscheiden über Bauland und so weiter. Ich möchte gar nicht wissen, wie viele Millionen im Jahr in Deutschland hin und her fließen an irgendwen, damit jemand an Grundstücke gelangt oder sie früher informiert wird, wenn irgendwo ein Haus frei wird und so weiter und so fort. Also mit einem freien Markt hat das ja eh nichts zu tun. Insofern ist es eine wirklich moderne Einrichtung, wenn man sagt, ja, die Stadt entscheidet uns zwar transparent darüber und sagt auch noch, ja, folgende Leute werden jetzt bevorzugt behandelt oder es gibt ganz klare Wartelisten, auf denen man steht und nicht, ja, wir sagen ihnen mal irgendwann Bescheid, aber man weiß nie, auf welchem Platz man da eigentlich ist. Also da kann man es eigentlich sehr gut dran sehen, dass wir da überhaupt nicht in der moderne sind. Also ich würde sagen, bei Immobilienmarkt sind wir eigentlich in einer Stammesgesellschaft, wie sie immer so gezeichnet wurde, wie es sie offenbar nie gegeben hat. Also da ist tatsächlich so horde und Gemeinschaft, wie man immer früher glaubte, wogegen jetzt hier Wengroff und Graeber anschreiben, das ist da ganz stark vertreten. Und um auf diese idee des Basiskommunismus zu kommen, es ist ja doch erstaunlich, dass sie Marx nur paar Mal erwähnen, aber eher despiktierlich und dass sie nicht erkennen wollen, dass man jetzt, wie du es gerade skizziert hast, auf einer Wohlstandsgrundlage über die Gesellschaft nochmal anders nachdenken kann. Denn das leuchtet mir bisweilen bei diesen dort geschilderten Gesellschaften aus der Vergangenheit nicht so ein, dass da eine materielle Überflussgesellschaft vorherrschte, wo man dann frei über alles Mögliche entscheiden konnte, sich treffen konnte und so weiter. Das kann ja nicht gewesen sein, sondern wir wissen ja da tatsächlich, dass Mark hin und wieder ganz gut organisiert gewesen sei. Und das wird sicherlich nicht so gewesen sein, dass das in irgendeiner Weise mit dem Wohlstand, den wir heute erreicht haben, vergleichbar ist. Und dass da aufgrund einer so niedrigen materiellen Grundlage eine wirkliche Freiheit in Form von Entfaltung stattgefunden haben soll, das ist mir doch etwas schleierhaft, denn ich glaube, unterschätzt wird, dass man für die Reproduktion des eigenen Lebens und der Familie und so weiter doch sehr viel Zeit und Kraft aufbringen musste, um damals zu existieren, als normaler Mensch, sag ich mal, der nicht irgendeinem spezieller Herrscher war. Und da ist doch eine gewisse Verklärung, die ich mir nur so erklären kann, dass Graeber und Wengrow ja tatsächlich so ein bisschen in diesem Postwachstumsgesellschaft, wir müssen mal auch mal wieder gucken, ob wir unser Brot nicht selbst machen können und so, dass sie doch ein bisschen dieser Fantasie zu sehr anhängen, dass wir uns mal wieder alle selbst organisieren. Das war ja auch bei Occupy Wall Street sicherlich ein Problem, diese Organisation. Und wir beide sind ja, deswegen war ich so gespannt, was sagt Stefan zu diesem Buch, wir beide sind ja doch Leute, die gute Organisation schätzen und eigentlich nicht am Nachmittag uns treffen wollen, um über die Wasserverwaltung abzustimmen, um dann nachher zu diskutieren, wer die Früchte erntet, um dann am Abend noch mal irgendwas selbst einzumachen.
Ja, und damit, das ist die blutige wunde dieses Buches, denn da wird die Sozialität im Eigenwert nicht erkannt. Also das autopoetische System, das nach eigenen Regeln Sozialität gestaltet. Und wir Menschen sind dann sozusagen die Teilnehmer. Jetzt ganz vulgär ausgedrückt. Also da fehlt einfach, da finde ich, ist man in Deutschland mit Luhmann und so sehr viel weiter. Aber sie kommen aus dieser handlungstheoretischen Sicht zumindest dann noch mit scharfen Thesen, wie zum Beispiel, dass sie eben wirklich sagen und das ist ja dann auch im klaren widerspruch zu dieser idee, wie du sie auch gerade noch mal in Erinnerung gerufen hast. Die Menschen früher, vor unserer moderne, haben nicht ihren ganzen Tag damit verbracht, ums Überleben zu kämpfen, sondern sie hatten Freizeit. Und die Freizeit wurde ihnen erst genommen, als sie dann ums Überleben kämpften und sich die ganze Zeit in Krisen stürzten. Und da muss man sagen, haben sie ja absolut recht, wenn sie sagen, die Demografie, die Klimakrise, wir reden zu Recht von menschengemachten Krisen. Das sind Krisen, die haben wir selbst verursacht, Menschen vor uns und jetzt müssen wir sie ausbügeln. Ohne uns als Menschen gäb's diese Krisen nicht. Mit allen Paradoxien, die dahinter hängen. Und die zweite streng handlungstheoretische Sicht, die im System theoretisch total banal und auch zu vernachlässigen ist, aber hier dann noch eine große Rolle spielt. Nämlich die idee, Entwicklungsgeschichte bedeutet, am Anfang waren es ja nur wenige Menschen, also brauchte man auch nur wenig getreide, aber irgendwann waren es ja ganz viele, also brauchte man ganz viel. Und damit brauchte man auch eine ganz komplexe Sozialstruktur. Bis hin zur Frage, müssen wir uns jetzt die ganze Zeit mit allem befassen oder können wir Repräsentationen und so weiter? Da war ja auch so ein ganz großer… Also wenn repräsentiert werden muss, dann ist eh vorbei. Der Mensch muss so richtig direkt demokratisch, so mal vulgär ausgedrückt, daran teilnehmen können. Und dem widersprechen sie ja und sagen, die Größe ist gar nicht das Ding. Denn und das Ulmer Beispiel zeigt es ja, diejenigen, die betroffen sind von dem Ulmer modell, also die Häuser im Angebot haben und die Häuser kaufen wollen, das sind ja nicht viele Menschen. Das sind ja hier ein paar hundert und da ein paar hundert. Und die könnte man ja auch durchaus an einem wochenende in einem großen gemeindesaal bringen und eine Immobilienbörse veranstalten. Also die könnten das auch mit sich klären.
Gut, in diesem Falle mag das stimmen. Aber gehen wir mal auf unsere aktuellen Fälle. Wir brauchen Masken, wir brauchen Tests. Und diese Tests müssen auch vielleicht noch innerhalb von 24 stunden mal ausgewertet werden. Wäre ja schön. Da ist ja Organisation, das A und O. Und das muss auch ganz groß organisiert werden. Also da können wir jetzt nicht mal gucken, ob sich da jeder Ort noch mal selbst zusammenrauft in irgendeiner Weise. Das mag auch in den kleinen Strukturen stattfinden. Aber wir brauchen ja da einfach flächendeckend eine Organisation essen. Und was ich bei den beiden Autoren doch vermisse, ist, dass sie das anerkennen, dass das eigentlich sehr gut ist, wenn Prozesse zentralisiert und anonymisiert stattfinden. Und ich habe manchmal bei ihnen den Eindruck, dass sie uns zwar aufzeigen wollen, dass es keineswegs so war, dass man nur in kleinen horden und Gemeinschaften sich selbst organisieren konnte, sondern dass das auch größer möglich war, dass sie aber verkennen, dass wir es dann heute mit doch noch mal bedeutend mehr Menschen zu tun haben. Also das ist einfach extrem viel mehr als das, was dort geschildert wird. Da geht es dann um Städte von 5.000 oder 10.000, aber wir haben jetzt auch einfach Städte, die 500.000 Einwohner haben. Ja, dann muss ich doch mich fragen, was ist damit gewonnen? Also was wäre damit gewonnen, wenn wir da in irgendeiner Weise basisdemokratischer das organisiert hätten oder jeder ein bisschen mehr da mitmachen müsste? Ich verstehe diese Art der gemeinschaftsidee, die da aufscheint, nicht so recht. Also diese idee einer fast wärmenden Gemeinschaft ist mir eher fremd. Und ich habe auch da wenig Verständnis für, wenn man zum einen zwar so ganz genau ist, was jetzt die Darstellung der Indigenen anbelangt, dass man aber dann dort so merkwürdig ungenau wird, wo es dann darum geht, naja, aber wie will man dann eine Gesellschaft mit zum Beispiel 80 Millionen Deutschen vernünftig organisieren?
Wer Gesellschaftstheorie sucht, findet bei in diesem Buch nichts. Die Funktionsweise von Geld, die bedeutung einer Wahrheitskommunikation in der Wissenschaft und wie sie legitimiert wird, wie Macht funktioniert, die Anbindung ans Recht. Ich meine, in Deutschland studieren so viele Leute Jura und haben die Gesellschaft aus dieser Jura-Brille im Blick und finden bei Graeber und Wengrow nichts dazu, während sie gleichzeitig sagen, aber das ist doch das grundlegende der Vergesellschaftung. Und wir sagen, ja, das stimmt. Die ganze Positivierung begann übers Recht und dann hat man das sozusagen als Prinzip auch hochgeholt und gesagt, ja, es können auch wissenschaftliche Wahrheiten wie ein Richterspruch funktionieren, wenn nur die Legitimation eben ein bisschen anders dann funktioniert und pipapo. Wie setzt man Recht durch all diese Fragen, all dieses gesellschaftstheoretische, da muss man dann zwei bände Gesellschaft der Gesellschaft lesen. Da allerdings findet man wieder nichts über die empirischen Grundlagen, über die du dich so beschwerst, weil die das Buch so dick gemacht haben, was ja auch stimmt. Also in der Sicht, wir müssen irgendwie mit beiden. Also wir haben hier kein universales Grundlagenwerk, sondern wir haben eben ein Geschichtsbuch.
Nein, das haben wir nicht. Aber lass mich mal eine Frage stellen. Glaubst du, dass es stimmt, dass es nicht so sehr auf die Verteilung und Organisation von Ressourcen angekommen ist, sondern wichtiger ist die Frage, kann man entscheiden? Ich habe den Eindruck, dass das nicht stimmt. Und ich will ein anderes Beispiel dafür aus dem Buch nehmen. Es wird sehr lange über Kanada, über die Natchez in Kanada geschrieben. Da gibt es auch Jesuitenberichte und da gab es auch ein Oberhaupt große Sonne. Und über dieses Oberhaupt wird gesagt, dass er natürlich seine Untertanen direkt hatte, seine, ich würde mal sagen, Hofschranzen und die mussten alles für ihn machen und so weiter und so fort. Aber das Einzugsgebiet, das eigentliche Reich von große Sonne, war natürlich viel größer als der Hof, an dem er gelebt hat. Und da ist jetzt die Argumentation der Autoren, und das deklinieren sie auch für andere Beispiel nochmal durch. Der Einflussbereich ist also zwar namentlich so besonders groß, aber de facto nicht. Das heißt, große Sonne ist ja dann nicht 100 Kilometer oder 200 Kilometer weiter irgendwo und haut seinen Untergebenen auf die Finger. Und die können dann dort sehr frei für sich auch leben, können sich in irgendeiner Weise organisieren, können das so oder so machen. Und da habe ich mich gefragt, ist das nicht bei uns ganz ähnlich? Du hast hier den Sloterdijk uns vorgestellt, der Staat streift die Samthandschuhe ab, in der pandemie haben wir den Staat gespürt. Da sagte er, Stefan, du musst, wenn du heute joggen willst, bis 21 Uhr fertig sein, denn wir haben eine Ausgangssperre oder so etwas. oder du darfst das nur mit Maske tun, oder du musst dich testen lassen, blablabla. Aber sonst, wenn wir jetzt keine pandemie haben, wo spüren wir den Staat? Natürlich spüren wir ihn, wenn wir Steuern zahlen müssen. Du musst die kinder zur Schule bringen, kannst dich dem nicht entziehen. Aber ich würde mal sagen, wenn man jetzt so für sich zum Beispiel alleine lebt und sich mit den Steuern irgendwie organisiert hat und sagt, das ist irgendwie Steuerberater Finanzamt, aber da sehe ich ja auch keine Personen oder so. Bei mir kommt ja auch nie ein Politiker vorbei. Also ich habe noch nie, hat ein Politiker bei mir geklingelt und gesagt, machen sie das mal lieber so und so. Da kommt vielleicht mal die Polizei, wenn man falsch geparkt hat. Aber eigentlich spürt man den Staat auch nicht und kann zum Beispiel im Konsum sehr stark aufgehen. Natürlich gehört zum Staat auch der Kapitalismus. Wir haben einen kapitalistischen Staat, insofern muss ich nach dessen Regeln spüren. Nur dieses, ich spüre die Herrschaft nicht, was da geschildert wird. Da würde ich sagen, die spüren die meisten Menschen auch nicht. oder es ist halt ein Grad an Repression oder Restriktion vom Staat, den wir in dem Sinne nicht wahrnehmen. Und genau das kann ja auch da der Fall gewesen sein. Große Sonne muss nicht erscheinen, aber de facto weiß man, es gibt große Sonne. Und es gibt hier in diesem Stamm irgendwelche Regeln. Und an die hält man sich fast intuitiv, wie wir es auch als fast intuitiv empfinden, zu sagen, naja gut, kinder müssen schon zur Schule gehen. Und ich selbst muss auch irgendwie was arbeiten und Steuern zahlen.
Ja, gut, du bringst mich gleich zu meiner großen Kritik an diesem Buch. Aber wir können es durchaus. Denn es gibt ja ein eigenes Kapitel dafür, Kapitel 8. Imaginäre Städte. Vorgelegt kommt dann im Kapitel 10 der Staat zur Sprache. Das längste Kapitel. Und das ist wahnsinnig schwach, weil die Theoriearbeit hier fehlt. Und sie kommen eben aus dieser, wir kritisieren einfach mal Hobbs und Rousseau Ecke, in dem sie sagen, naja, der Rousseau sagt einfach, es gibt halt einen Staat, das ist ja auch. Und der Hobbs macht irgendwas mit der Naturzustand. Der Naturzustand ist, auch wenn überhaupt, ein ganz anderer, nämlich dem, dem man da vorfindet. Also Menschen gehen durchaus mit Menschenverstand an die Sachen ran. Und es ist auch nicht so, dass man erst in der Aufklärung beginnt zu reflektieren und plötzlich baut man ganz komplizierte Gesellschaften, sondern reflektiert hat der Mensch schon immer. Und damals, nur weil es kleiner war und technisch nicht so ausgerüstet war, das trotzdem eine super raffinierte Sozialität, die erfunden wurde. Und dann fragt man sich die Frage, die du gestellt hast. Ja, aber wir leben jetzt in großen Städten und müssen ja ein bisschen was regeln. Und dann sagen sie einfach in dieser Hoppschen, wir wischen das mal vom Tisch, wie wir es so ergibt, einfach sagen sie schon in der Überschrift des Kapitels imaginäre Städte. Die sind ja gar nicht echt. Wir leben ja nur in Familienzusammenhängen, in Clans, in Stadtteilen. 150 Menschen, was man halt so überblickt. Eine theoretische idee, die hier hinterfragungswürdig ist, aber die sich ja bis in die facebook-ideologie niederschlägt. Das Mark Zuckerberg einfach sagt, sind 150 Leute, sind damit wichtig. Das kann man dann bei Instagram mit. Das sind meine engen freunde. Und der Rest ist halt so Publikumsbeifang irgendwie. Alles darüber hinaus sind imaginäre Gesellschaften. Wir leben in unserem Stadtteil, aber– und das muss man dann empirisch, stimmt es wieder– es gibt in Frankfurt Stadtteile, in denen bin ich seltener als in Berliner Stadtteilen, obwohl ich in Frankfurt lebe. In der Hinsicht kann man alles empirisch so sagen, nur die Funktionsweise von Frankfurt hängt trotzdem nicht davon ab, ob ich da jetzt bin oder wer wo wie und so. Da gibt es auch noch einiges zu sagen. Und da reden sie sich halt auch so ein bisschen raus. Sie sagen halt einfach, die Territorien, die früher überspannt wurden von den vormodernen Gesellschaften, waren größer als unsere Nationalstaaten heute. Da fragt man sich, wie haben sie funktioniert? Und dann sagen sie einfach, Freundschaftsnetzwerke. Also einfach ihr Begriff sind halt Freundschaftsnetzwerke. Man kommt so rum, sagt dann, ich bin so und so. Und dann wird man da aufgenommen und kriegt irgendwie Kost und Logie und Essen und was und dann lebt man halt so weiter. Da fragt man sich, da gibt es noch ein paar Fragen, die man echt mal klären müsste. Und die werden aber hier nicht aufgegriffen. Da kommen dann immer nur die Thesen zum Vorschein, indem sie sagen, der Mensch hat eigentlich immer ziemlich frei, auch regional super mobil gelebt, bis er die Stadt erfunden hat. Plötzlich hat er nur noch auf 8 Kilometer Radius gelebt. Und dann schließen sie halt zu Thesen an, die ich wieder faszinierend finde, aber die halt wirklich keine Frage klären. Wie zum Beispiel, haben wir die Städte erst gegründet, nachdem wir landwirtschaftlich dafür bereit waren, die Städte zu versorgen? oder, und das ist dann ihre Gegenthese, die Städte haben sich erst mal gegründet und aus der Notwendigkeit heraus gab es dann einen landwirtschaftlichen Fortschritt. Der war aber nicht mal so nötig im Sinne von der Willikation, wie wir es haben. Der Fürst, das Kloster hatte ganz viele ländereien und hat sich dann versorgen lassen und im Gegenzug den Bauern das rechtgegebenes Land zu benutzen. Die Hälfte durfte man behalten und der zehnte musste dann abgegeben werden. Und die sagen einfach, ne, brauchten die Städte eigentlich gar nicht. Man konnte fast, wie man es heute so in modernen Gewächshäusern und so weiter macht, die Stadt aus sich selbst versorgen lassen. Und da würde ich auch wieder sagen, hm, das widerspricht aber nun einigen geschichtswissenschaftlichen Texten, die man so kennt über die Abhängigkeiten von Land und Stadt, bis hin zu theoretischen Arbeit von Luhmann, zu Zentrum und Peripherie und so weiter. Also da fliegen sie halt so drüber und verstricken sich dann auch in, was weiß ich, die Sonne, indem sie dann auch in diesem Staatskapitel noch mal ewig lang, die Inka und die Maja und man fragt sich so, ja gut, okay, das habt ihr wirklich in euren Büchern jetzt alles drinstehen gehabt. Hilft uns jetzt hier nicht weiter. Also das ist dann, schluder das Buch so ein bisschen vor sich hin. Das muss man dann auch wirklich so sagen.
Und das hätte es gar nicht nötig, denn ich finde andere Thesen viel interessanter und auch viel stichhaltiger und die geben einem jetzt zu denken. Und eigentlich ist die Menschheit einem ein viel größeres Rätsel nach dem Buch. Und das will ich als Kompliment verstanden wissen. Denn es gibt ja diese auseinandersetzung nun mit Harari an zwei Ställen. Und Harari sagt ja, ja, wir müssen uns die frühen Menschen da, die da gelebt haben, also die Stämme, von denen wir fast nichts wissen und die untergegangenen Reiche ja im Prinzip so als bessere Schimpansen als Bruno Bos oder so vorstellen. Also er ist ja da sehr abwertend. Und die These von Wengrow und Graeber ist ja, und da liefern sie auch gewisse Anhaltspunkte, der Mensch war, als er dann Mensch wurde, hatte ja das Gehirn, das wir heute auch haben. Das heißt, das waren nicht Menschen mit anderen Gehirnen, die in irgendeiner Weise schlichter waren oder die nur in eine Richtung dachten oder sonst was. Du hast es ja mit der rede gewandt, halt schon erwähnt. Es heißt ja ganz klar, verabschieden wir uns von der Kindheit des Menschen und sehen wir ein, dass unsere früheren Vorfahren uns nicht nur kognitiv, sondern auch intellektuell ebenwürdig waren. Höchstwahrscheinlich hatten sie genauso heftig wie wir mit den Paradoxen von Sozialordnung und Kreativität zu kämpfen und verstanden sie wenigstens die nachdenklichsten unter ihnen genauso gut als auch genauso wenig wie wir. Sie waren sich vielleicht mancher Dinge mehr oder anderer weniger bewusst. Sie waren weder unwissende wilde noch weise Söhne und Töchter der Natur. Sie waren, wie Helena Valero von den Janu Mani sagte, einfach nur Menschen, genau wie wir, genauso wahrnehmungsfähig und genauso verwirrt. Und daraus lässt sich ja schon die Frage ableiten, wieso hat es so lange gedauert? Also warum sind oder hat es gar nicht lange gedauert? Du merkst, jetzt habe ich gerade selbst teleologisch gedacht. Also ich wollte jetzt noch hinzufügen, warum hat es so lange gedauert, bis wir hier über Zoom miteinander sprechen und einen Podcast aufnehmen, den dann bald ganz viele hören können. Aber das wäre ja schon wieder die Fortschrittsgeschichte. Und hier würden sofort Wengrow und Graeber sagen, ne, es hat ja gar nicht lange gedauert. Die haben ja auch Podcasts vielleicht gemacht, nur in einer anderen Art, die Einstheken.
Sie sagen ja ganz konkret und häufig in dem Buch, es hat nicht lange gedauert. Und wenn man meint, es hätte lange gedauert, dann muss man sagen, sie haben sich halt bewusst dagegen entschieden. In diesem Sinne modern zu leben. Es flammte ja immer mal auf. Es gab Städte, die eben dann doch von außen regiert wurden. Und es hat nie funktioniert. Diese Städte wurden dann zerstört. Die waren als lebensunwörtlich. Man wollte da nicht mehr leben. Sie wurden aufgelöst, je nach Geschwindigkeit. Das haben wir ja bis heute. Das amerikanische Städte einfach sagen, Washington regiert hier nicht. Wir machen sogar unsere eigene Asylgesetzgebung und so weiter. Bildungsfragen sind ländersache und all dieses Kram. Also dieses Prinzip der Subsidiarität begann recht früh. Man stellte einfach fest, da kommt jemand mit Ansprüchen von außen. Ja, wir kennen den doch gar nicht, also werden wir den erstmal ab. Sie haben ja dann dieses Beispiel, wo wir eben schon im Städtekapitel waren. Nebelvika, eine Mega-Stadt in der ukrainischen Waldsteppe, die man auch gut kennt. Und dann schreiben sie, definitiv produzierte man einen Überschuss, weil Synergieeffekte und so weiter und schuf damit die Möglichkeit für einige, die Kontrolle über Vorräte und bestände an sich zu reißen, über andere zu herrschen und sich um die Erträge zu streiten. Doch über acht jahrhunderte hinweg finden sich kaum Hinweise auf Kriege und den Aufstieg sozialer Eliten. Die wahre Komplexität der Mega-Städte liegt somit in ihren Strategien, derartiges zu verhindern. Also man musste sich dann, als man gesehen hat, oh, da hat aber jemand ganz schön viel Macht, weil er den Speicher des getreides und so weiter, musste man dagegen anarbeiten und hat daran raus wahrscheinlich Lehren gezogen, bis hin zu, dass man dann, als die Kolonialkräfte kamen, sagte, also hört mal zu, wir kennen euch im grunde, wir haben euch schon abgelehnt. Ihr stoßt hier nicht auf ein wildes Volk, sondern auf eine Gesellschaft, die sich schon entschieden hat, nicht so zu leben, wie ihr uns es aufzwingt. Und man konnte sich dann aber nicht wehren. Aber dieses, die Menschen haben sich bewusst dagegen entschieden, das steckt ja ganz häufig als These immer wieder in dem Buch, egal aus welcher Richtung man da argumentiert.
Und das ist das eminent Politische an dem Buch, denn man ist ja von dem, was du gerade geschildert hast, ganz schnell beim Kartellrecht. oder man könnte auch jetzt bei der Taxonomie, du uns vorgestellt hast, ja sagen, wir entscheiden uns gerade für gewisse Wege, die wir bestreiten oder nicht bestreiten. Und wir haben uns vor 10, 20 Jahren schon falsche entschieden. Sonst müssten wir jetzt gar nicht noch mal mit Gas und noch mal mit Atomkraft in irgendeiner Weise was zu tun haben, sondern dann hätten wir uns vielleicht schon dazu entschieden, dass es heute so aussieht, dass alles mit erneuerbarer Energie geregelt wird. Und das ist eigentlich dieses entscheiden und dass sich dadurch die Geschichte verändert. Das ist für mich das Interessanteste überhaupt. Und das ist eigentlich so eine Grundlage dieses Buch für ungeheuer viele Gedankenspiele. Und was ja glaube ich auch deutlich wird in dem Buch, ist, dass es ja immer um Machtverhältnisse geht. Ja, also es ist nicht so, da entscheiden sich einfach nur Leute falsch oder richtig, sondern das hat natürlich mit Machtkonstellationen zu tun. Wenn da plötzlich Armeen anrücken und unterdrücken und unterjochen, dann führt das zu einer gewissen Entscheidung auch wieder. Also es ist keineswegs so, dass es immer nur darum geht, dass das aus dem Menschen heraus geschaffen ist, sondern es sind immer Machtkonstellationen, die irgendetwas dann auch bedingen, warum dies oder das sich durchgesetzt hat. Also es ist nicht so, dass die Menschheit, kann man sagen, sich falsch entschieden hat in diese oder jene Richtung, sondern einige Menschen haben sich dann falsch entschieden, andere richtig. Und oft war es aber so, dass die, die sich falsch entschieden haben, sehr viel Macht hatten und damit haben sie dann die, die hätten richtig entscheiden können, unterdrückt. Und ähnliches können wir natürlich laufend erleben. In gewisser Weise ist das keine neue Erkenntnis in dem Sinne. Aber wenn man es noch mal so illustriert bekommt, an historischen Beispielen, dann wird einem schlagartig bewusst, wie verrückt eigentlich diese Gegenwart gerade mit ihren Entscheidungen ist.
Genau, als ich das so las, habe ich immer gedacht, und man kann ja mal Beispiele nennen, wo es gescheitert ist. Also jeweils 2000 vor Christus. Die amoretische Lim-Dynastie im syrischen Euphrat-Gebiet, also wir sind hier im Nahen Osten, wo das Stadtleben dadurch zerstört würde, dass irgendwelche autoritären Herrscher von außen durchregierten. oder, und das ist dann häufiger, denn sie sagen, die egalitären Städte waren überraschend häufiges Muster, so steht es im Buch, aber es gibt viele Gegenbeispiele. Auch vor allem in China, 2000 v. Chr. die Königsdynastie Shang, die einfach über das Land hereinkommt und in der Provinz Henan einfach alles an sich reist und damit auch dieses Paradies zerstört, aus dem wir ja angeblich immer kamen. Und als ich das dann immer so las, dachte ich, ja das ist so dieses Star Wars Mythos. Also jemand steigt in sein Raumschiff, fliegt irgendwo hin und das ist ja immer das gleiche Bild, egal welcher Film, welche Serie. Man geht in so eine Kneipe oder so, in so eine Ecke und dann sieht man so, wie sie alle zusammen und dann kriegt man relativ früh mit, ist das jetzt hier Geselligkeit oder ist das so eine Armee, die sich da irgendwie besorgt, geht es hier lustig zu oder wird es gleich gewalttätig. Und das aber im großen Rahmen. Also man hat so ganz verschiedene sozialmodelle, lässt sich auch auf die ein. Und da gibt es einen Punkt, der liegt so quer über dem ganzen Buch. Irgendwann hat es die Menschheit geschafft, sich vom Wetter unabhängig zu machen. Und das finde ich ist auch so eine Fragestellung für durchaus Dissertationen, die man mal machen kann, diese These zu überprüfen, die hier im Buch drin steht. Als sich der Mensch von seiner Natur unabhängig machte, Tagesrhythmus und Sessionalität, begann der Untergang. Denn dann musste man Speicher anlegen, um auch im Winter wie im Sommer zu leben. Und wurde richtig sesshaft. Sommer wie Winter, also man zog nicht einfach immer weiter, je nach Lage. Und das war im grunde der Startpunkt, wo man sich von der Natur verabschiedete und die Sozialität so richtig durchstartete. Hierarchien, Planung, wie auch immer. Also alles, was wir heute kennen an der modernitätsgeschichte. Der Holocaust war nur möglich, weil es unglaublich viel Bürokratie gab, bis hin zu Wannsee-Konferenzen und so weiter, wo man ganz nüchtern das einfach mal durchgegangen ist. Ja, und das, finde ich, ist irgendwie so eine These, über die man mal reden könnte.
Ich würde halt sagen, dass der Mensch schon immer aus der Natur herausge- Also ich weiß nicht, was dieses sich vom Wetter unabhängig macht. Also was ist das für ein- Wann ist dieser Punkt wirklich erreicht? Jetzt kann man sagen, ja, wenn der Kornspeicher angelegt wird, wenn man dann nicht das erntet, was jetzt gerade zu pflücken geht. Aber sobald man den Regenschirm aufspannt, macht man sich von der Natur unabhängig. Denn man könnte sich auch nass regnen lassen, macht es aber aus irgendwelchen gründen nicht. Und der Regenschirm zur Zentralheizung ist nur ein kleiner. Da sind wir sicherlich noch nicht beim Geo-Engineering. Aber ich würde da als Vertreter der Zivilisation und der verzerrtelten Zivilisation möchte ich hinzufügen, doch ganz klar meine bedenken äußern, was das denn da eigentlich meint.
Also im vierten Kapitel, für alle, die jetzt sich denken, oh, das klingt interessant und ich wollte ja eh Promotionen schreiben. Sie reden von der, Zitat, ganzjährigen, hierarchischen Sozialordnung, die plötzlich über die Menschheit kam. Und sie sagen sogleich noch in diesem Satz, dass das ist die Sackgasse. Und im nächsten Satz sprechen sie von der Stagnation durch die Unabhängigkeit von der Natur. Darf man nicht falsch verstehen. Sackgasse und Stagnation bedeutet, meint hier nicht genau das, was man auch als Gegenteil, und damit könnte man dann spielen, aufzuziehen, ist nämlich, dass die Unabhängigkeit vom Wetter, also zum Beispiel ein getreidefeld, winterfest zu machen und im nächsten Jahr wieder zu benutzen und dann im Winter auch dazubeiben, aus dem Speicher zu leben, den Speicher anzuhäufen, darüber Macht zu generieren. Wie auch immer, dass wir hier den Startpunkt haben, ab dem, und das ist so 18. jahrhundert, die Menschheit tatsächlich nur noch damit befasst war, ihren eigenen Lebensunterhalt zu bestreiten. Schon allein, weil irgendwann das Überleben gesichert war und man sich nur noch im Wettbewerb mit anderen Menschen sah und die Natur zum Werkzeug wurde. Das machen sie als ganz großen Punkt. Und die Aussage, der getreide Anbau sei für den Aufstieg solcher Staaten verantwortlich gewesen, käme der Behauptung gleich, die Erfindung der Infinitisimalrechnung, wie auch immer im mittelalterlichen Persien, habe die Entwicklung der Atombombe angestoßen. Also da greifen sich so vulgär diese ideen, die wir davon so haben, auf. Machen sich aber nicht ganz frei davon. Und da finde ich, kann man dieses Buch wirklich mal hinterfragen und diese These aufgreifen. Inwieweit wir diese Art Säkularisierung von der Natur als zweiten Schritt, die Aufklärung, unsere Aufklärung ist ja das Zurücklassen von Gott und die Selbstfindung der Menschheit. Und ob man hier die, also die gleiche Arbeit, Gedankenarbeit nochmal machen kann, aber nicht Abwendung von Gott, sondern wirklich Abwendung von konkreter Natur, die anders als der imaginierte Gott, so ein paar Rituale und so weiter, von der Natur war man ja wirklich materiell abhängig. Also wenn das getreidefeld nicht funktionierte, ging es halt nicht. Aber irgendwann ging es halt und dann zack, ja, geht so die Zivilisationsrakete los, kann man empirisch ganz fest verankern mit Bevölkerungswachstum und so weiter. Also das 8% der Menschheit, 300.000 Jahre Menschheitsgeschichte jetzt gerade gleichzeitig leben, hat ja nun sehr viel mit Versorgungssicherheit zu tun und diese Versorgungssicherheit sehr viel mit. Ja, dann müssen wir es aber jetzt auch mal juristisch regeln. Und damit wir das juristische klar regeln, dann müssen wir das jetzt auch politisch regeln. Also man hat ja im grunde immer nur, wie sagen wir das richtig, nicht Ungleichheiten, sondern so Hierarchien, sagen wir mal so, irgendwie eingefangen. Zuerst war die Eigentums-Hierarchie-Differenzierung. Manche hatten viel, manche hatten wenig. Dann wollte man das juristisch einhegen. Dann musste man das juristische aber auf eine Regelbasis, also eine Legitimation aus sich heraus. Also hat man dann Politik und dann schließt sich der Kreis, wenn man in Korruption denkt und sagt, ja, aber mit Eigentum kann man ja auch die Macht. Und das sagen sie ja ganz deutlich am ende des Buches. Eigentum bedeutet Macht. Das ist ja eines der ganz großen Schlüssel, den sie so uns dalassen für, wie wir jetzt die Gesellschaft beobachten sollen. Und ich finde, aus diesem Kongnummerat kann man noch mal ein paar Fragestellungen entwickeln, weil ich finde, diese These von, und das gibt es ja häufiger, der Krieg und Krieg oder diese Schlacht wurde so entschieden, weil es halt durch Zufall gab es Nebel, ja. Napoleon konnte sich da gut verstecken im Wald, weil es war halt Nebel. Also da ist ja völlig gesetzt, dass man sagt, ja, da hatte das Wetter einen echten Einfluss. Aber dieses, ja, das Klima, Sie sagen ja auch, man konnte jetzt erst die Zivilisation starten, weil es eben nur zwei Warmphasen in der Menschheitsgeschichte gab. Und in einer sind wir gerade. Ja, dass da auch das Klima eine Rolle spielt. Also in der Ansicht steckt da doch einiges im Buch drin, wo man es als inspirative Quelle für die eine oder andere Fragestellung mal nutzen kann.
Ich will was ganz lobendes sagen und das würde ich jetzt nicht besonders verwundern. Es gibt ja eine ganz kurze Passage zum Thema Tabak. Und du weißt, am Abend rauche ich schon mal gerne eine Zigarette. oder wenn die Bars geöffnet haben, dann auch eine Zigarre. Und da heißt es, was Jesuiten aus dem Nordosten berichteten, scheint auch hier zuzutreffen. Sie glauben, also die Einwohner, dass nichts so geeignet ist wie Tabak, um die leidenschaften zu besänftigen. Deshalb nehmen sie nie an, einem Konzil teil, ohne eine Pfeife oder ein Kalomet im Mund zu haben. Der Rauch, so sagen sie, verleiht ihnen Weisheit und ermöglicht es ihnen selbst, die komplizierten Angelegenheiten klar zu durchschauen. Jetzt, Graeber und Wengrow, dies alles klingt verdächtig nach einem Kaffeehaus der Aufklärung und ist kein Zufall. Tabak etwa wurde um diese Zeit von den Siedlern übernommen und dann zurück nach Europa gebracht, wo er sich rasch wachsender beliebt hat, erfreute. Dort pries man ihn als Droge an, die in kleinen Dosen einzunehmen sei, um den Geist zu fokussieren. Offensichtlich fand hier keine direkte kulturelle Übertragung statt. Die gibt es im Übrigen nie. Doch wie wir gesehen haben, wirken die ideen der nordamerikanischen Ureinwohner, von der Befürwortung persönlicher Freiheiten bis hin zur Skepsis gegenüber Offenbarungsreligionen, entschieden auch auf die europäische Aufklärung ein, auch wenn diese Gedanken, wie das Pfeife rauchen, im Laufe des Prozesses viele veränderungen erfuhren. Wir haben diesen Diskurs im Übrigen auch in der Kunstwissenschaft, denn der Kunstwissenschaftler der Alten garde hätte natürlich gesagt, und dann gibt es die großen Meister, Dürer, Rembrandt und so weiter, und dann gibt es die vor allem die moderne, also Leute wie Braque oder Picasso. Und dann hat man ja auch im Zuge der Postcolonial Studies und so weiter und so fort darüber nachgedacht, naja, wo kommen eigentlich diese Formen her? Und da sind doch sehr viele französische modernisten mal nach Afrika gereist und so weiter. Und dann hat man sich plötzlich angesehen, welche Werke dort entstanden sind und inwieweit diese Werke dann oder ich möchte fast sagen, diese Formen migriert sind. Ja, also da haben wir schon die ganze Zeit Massenmigration, wenn man so möchte. Ja, also wie diese Formen migriert sind in die bilder der Europäer, wurden dann dort klassische moderne. Und inzwischen gibt es auch viele Ausstellungen, die das gegenüberstellen, aber nicht in der Form, dass man sagt, hier ist die primitive Kunst und hier ist die hohe Kunst, sondern man sagt, ja, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich das beeindruckendere Kunstwerken? Wenn man sich mal so eine Ausstellung ansieht, dann sagt man oft, naja, eigentlich ist das doch beeindruckender, als was dann eigentlich da als migrierte Form draus gemacht wurde. Das ist hochinteressant, wenn man sich ansieht, wie eigentlich eine gewissen Formensprache migrieren kann und wie schnell sie sich auch dann über einen Globus verteilen kann. Und ähnliches scheint hier mit dem Tabak geschehen zu sein. Und das finde ich doch eine schöne Anekdote, dass ich eigentlich jeden Abend einen Hauch Aufklärung atme, der mal zugleich rückgebunden ist an die nordamerikanischen Ureinwohner. Gibt es ein besseres Plädoyer als so Zigarette zu kreifen?
Ja, dass du das so vorbildhaft findest, finde ich natürlich auch immer amüsant, weil die daraus ja auch ein Argument machen, nachzuspielen. Wie viel Zivilisation ist eigentlich nur ein Nachspiel, so wie die ganze Aufklärung im grunde ein Plagiat ist. Man hat einfach etwas nachgemacht, was man vorfand. Als ich die Abschnitte dazu las, dachte ich auch so, im grunde hat ja Donald Trump seine präsidentschaft gespielt. Wir haben ja Bruno Marquez gelesen. Genau, er hat dann gesehen, wie er vor der Kamera funktioniert, dachte ich, präsidentschaft findet auch vor der Kamera statt, also spiele ich ja einfach den präsidenten. Ich erlebe das immer mal wieder. Es kommt immer seltener vor, dass ich in Corporate Deutschland an irgendwelchen Konferenzen teilnehme. Also Arbeitskonferenzen, wo sich ein Team morgens trifft und irgendwas bespricht. Und wenn man da aber mal neu ist oder nur zu Gast oder so, dann merkt man ja auch, dass hier nur gespielt wird. Also der Chef spielt halt, so wie man den Chef halt so spielt. Man geht ins Krankenhaus und spielt den Patienten, so wie man halt im Fernsehen sieht, dass sich Patienten verhalten im Krankenhaus usw. Und diese idee machen sie ja auch ganz scharf. Und da kommt ja dann sehr viel, man guckt sich das voneinander ab. Es lebt über die Nachahmung. Und jetzt stecken wir halt alle in so einer, wir haben halt, ja man kauft sich halt ein SUV, wenn man das Geld dafür hat. Ja und dann spielt man das halt so durch. Und da steckt da so eine Art Spieltrieb drin, der wir nachgehen, ohne dass wir gleichzeitig darauf verzichten, damit unseren Lebensunterhalt zu verdienen. Also so ein bisschen um die Ecke gedacht. Aber so machen sie es ja, bis hin zu der Spielkönig hat zuerst angefangen zu spielen und dann war er tatsächlich irgendwie König. Also man hat sich so darauf eingestellt. Und dieses Spiel findet statt, wenn Freizeit fehlt. Und jetzt haben sie ja vorher schon das Argument gemacht, zu sagen ja eigentlich hatte die Menschheit viel Freizeit. Und das ist ja auch das, was wir immer sagen, ist uns wichtig. Wenn ihr mit Teilen eine Umfrage macht, was ist euch wichtiger? Gutes Gehalt oder ordentliche Arbeitszeit? Sagen die ordentliche Arbeitszeit. Und da haben sie hier so ein Zitat, das muss man mal vorlesen, glaube ich, über den Freizeitmythos der Wildbeuter. Also in diesem Kapitel, das heißt freie Menschen, der Ursprung der Kultur und die Entstehung des Privateigens. Wo sie dann nachdem die Kolonialisierung vor allem bedeutet, man hat der Menschheit die Freizeit geraubt. Hier noch mal schreiben, das uralte Freizeitethos der Wildbeuter, die Zennstraße zum Überfluss, brach jedenfalls laut Salins. Der Bericht erst zusammen als Menschen, aus welchen gründen auch immer, das ist dann die offene Frage, war es das Wetter, sesshaft wurden und die Strapazen der Landwirtschaft auf sich nahmen. Sie zahlten einen schrecklichen Preis. Also vorher war Landwirtschaft nicht so sehr Selbstversorgung, sondern mehr so Gartenarbeit, so schreiben sie es auch. In dieser Stadt Uruk wollte man mehr den Göttern gefallen und hat deswegen die Stadt in Ordnung gehalten. Es ging gar nicht um sich selber, sondern man hat einfach gesagt, ihr habt uns die Stadt geschenkt, liebe Götter, also machen sie wir für euch schön. Dann hat man sich auf sich selbst bezogen, Landwirtschaft erfunden, aus welchen gründen auch immer, die werden dann zu klären und dann schreiben sie, was dieser schreckliche Preis, den das der Menschheit bedeutet hat, eigentlich, wenn man es sich mal ausformuliert bedeutet, nämlich Arbeit, Armut, Krankheit, Krieg, Sklaverei. Also so ist dieses Buch angelegt.
Das ist sehr stark und man muss sich ja nur mal damit beschäftigen, mit der Entstehung der Industrialisierung nur. Dann weiß man ja schon, was da für Arbeitszeiten plötzlich auf Menschen zukam, was von kindern abverlangt wird. Das ist ja auch bei Marx zum Beispiel nachzulesen, aber auch bei einigen anderen im 19. jahrhundert. Und das, glaube ich, ist auch etwas, was man als das Wichtigste in dem Buch überhaupt herausstellen sollte. Also ich will noch mal eine ganz kurze Passage lesen. Ziemlich am ende, da heißt es, in mancher Hinsicht mag die neue Perspektive sogar noch tragischer erscheinen als unsere bisherige standarderzählung von der Zivilisation als unvermeidlichem sündenfall. Sie bedeutet, wir hätten mit radikal anderen Konzeptionen von dem, was die menschliche Gesellschaft eigentlich ausmacht, leben können. Sie bedeutet, Massenversklavung, Völkermord, Straflager, ja sogar das Patriarchat oder die Produktion durch Lohnarbeit hätten niemals geschehen müssen. andererseits jedoch lässt sie auch vermuten, die Möglichkeiten menschlichen Eingreifens seien auch heute noch weitaus größer, als wir zu denken geneigt sind.
Ja und da kann man das harte, harte, harte Urteil, am Anfang spielen sie ja in dem eigenen Kapitel mit der Aufklärung und sagen, ist vielleicht nur ein Plakett, ja zwei, weiter unten Kapitel vier und fünf, da bricht es ja dann richtig aus ihnen aus. Wir haben kolonialisiert und zwar Menschen, die sich als Teil der Natur sehen und mit ihr leben, also saisonal abhängig. Man zieht hin und her, man verbringt den Sommer da, den Winter da, wie auch immer. Und dann kamen wir, die europäischen Kolonialkräfte, und haben gesagt, alles, was wir hier sehen, wie in König der Löwen, ja alles, was das Licht berührt, gehört uns. Also wir haben, was wir uns immer anrechnen, den Gott aus der Rechnung rausgenommen und haben damit aber alles andere in die Rechnung reingepackt und haben gesagt, das gehört uns. Während die Kolonisierten sagten, nee, das gehört weder euch noch uns. Das ist einfach Gott oder der Gemeinschaft, was wir hier vorfinden. Dann kam die Europäerung und sagte, nee, das gehört alles uns. Und in der Hinsicht ist diese Vorlandwirtschaftszeit, die wir heute so als Fehlstaat, sagen sie ausdrücklich Fehlstaat, es ist kein Fehlstaat, sondern wir beobachten das nur falsch. Hier brauchen wir eine Glottokronologie, ist nochmal was anderes. Aber sie schreiben dann, die Geschichte des Eigentums ist die Geschichte des Verlustes von Grundfreiheiten. Und damit entklammern sie auch das ganze Buch. Am Anfang Ungleichheit, Ungleichheit, ja, schön und gut, gibt's viele Bücher, kann man auch darüber reden. Aber das eigentliche Thema ist Freiheit. Und zwar nicht nur dieses Buches, sondern der Menschheitsgeschichte und wie wir sie verloren durch unsere falschen Anfänge. Also eigentlich ist die Zivilisation, wie wir sie haben, der Fehlstaat der Menschheit. Man sollte, man hätte auch Reset drauf schreiben können, wenn man es politisch übertreibt.
Ich denke schon, ja, und wir brauchen vielleicht dieses Buch gerade deshalb, weil wir heute vor allem im Zuge von Corona so einen ganz vulgären Freiheitsbegriff im Diskurs vorfinden, der nur darauf abzieht zu sagen, ich als Konsument will aber jetzt noch mal richtig Spaß haben. Und alle anderen müssen darunter leiden. Und dass hier Freiheit vollumfänglich mal und ganz substanziell gedacht wird, das ist etwas, was absolut fehlt im Diskurs und was auch über so einen vulgären Liberalismus weit hinausgeht und auch hinausgeht über so ein bisschen, ach, wir treffen uns mal wieder alle in der Mitte der Gesellschaft, überwinden die Spaltung und deine Freiheit muss da enden, wo meine beginnt und was das nicht und aufhört. Aber hier geht es wirklich mal ganz ans Eingemachte. Und das ist vielleicht auch noch mal so eine kleine Anregung, dass man sich diesen Freiheitsbegriff nicht wegnehmen lässt, jetzt von irgendwelchen Rechten oder Neoliberalen oder sonst was, sondern dass Freiheit durchaus ein linkes Anliegen ist. Das ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen in Vergessenheit geraten.
Genau, aber eine Freiheit jenseits der Freiheit für seinen Lebensunterhalt jetzt zu sorgen. sondern nochmal die Stufe darunter. Ich finde, es steckt noch eine zweite Anregung für linkes Denken dahinter. Klar, es muss ja nicht immer Wachstum sein und so, das hat man jetzt schon verstanden, dass das da drin steckt. Aber auch diese Rückwendung zur Natur. Du hast ja schon dich sehr despiktierlich über die Natur geäußert, woraufhin du auch schon YouTube-Kommentare geerntet hast, die noch mal darauf hinwissen. Natur ist ja nicht nur der Wald, sondern auch alles andere, was man so vor sich findet. Und diese Hinwendung zur Natur, die kann man ja auf einer Seite so romantisch machen. Wir brauchen das Grün in unseren Augen, damit wir uns noch mal und so weiter als Menschen fühlen. Aber dadurch, dass wir uns jetzt so verstrickt haben durch unsere eigene Menschheitsgeschichte und sie ja auch ganz explizit schreiben, also klimawandel und Demografie, womit wir es zu tun haben, das sind jetzt eigen gemachte Probleme. Und wir sollten uns mal wieder mehr der Natur wenden. Hinsichtlich Sessionalität, auch tagsüber. Ich meine, viele Menschen leiden darunter, dass sie einfach bis 23 Uhr das Licht anlassen. Also viele Krankheiten könnte man einfach dadurch, da gibt es von Peter Spork ein ganz tolles Buch übers Schlafen, man könnte relativ viele Zivilisationskrankheiten einfach dadurch ein bisschen abmindern oder auch den IQ in der Schule steigern, indem man einfach mal für natürliche Lichtverhältnisse sorgt. Und die kinder nicht morgens ab neun Uhr sechs stunden lang unter so einer Leuchtstoffröhre da irgendwie betreut. Mit der besonderen These, der Pisa-Schock wäre alleine dadurch auffangbar. Man könnte besseren Unterricht machen oder besseres Licht sorgen. Und schon wäre der Pisa-Gap, den wir in Deutschland gemessen haben vor 20 Jahren, gleichmäßig könnte man da negieren. Na ja, wir stürzen jetzt jedenfalls, wir kommen ja gerade durch diese pandemie. Und diese pandemie zwingt uns ja gerade wieder die Natur auf. Das haben wir ja alle, diesen Standardspruch, wir können mit dem Virus nicht verhandeln, die Natur ist einfach mal da. Und jetzt machen sie ja dieses große Argument, dieses ganze Buch durch. Wir müssen aus dieser Starrheit, in der wir uns sozial festgefangen haben, wieder raus. Wir müssen uns wieder, es gibt halt einfach mal im Winter keine Orangen, nur weil das mit Weihnachten verknüpft wird.
Das sehe ich im Übrigen ganz genauso nicht, dass das jetzt missverstanden wird, dass ich derjenige bin, der im Dezember Leute schickt, um Erdbeeren zu kaufen oder zu ernten. Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht der Fall.
Komfort heißt für Wolfgang nicht, im KDW im Winter noch die Premium Erdbeeren zu kaufen oder so. sondern da gibt es linke Argumente, das aber noch mal richtig raffiniert zu formulieren. Und zwar zu sagen, wir haben jetzt pandemie erlebt. Wie wäre es denn, wenn wir uns nicht nur, wenn uns die Natur mit dem tode bedroht und nicht auf Verhandlung einlässt, einfach mal ein bisschen der Natur ergeben. Wenn es einfach heißt, ne, mit 400, also mit 400 kann man sich nicht, also mit 400 kmh kann man sich nicht auf bewegen, auf der erde. Das geht einfach nicht. Und die idee von, naja, dann bauen wir mit unserem Steuergeld eine Straße und irgendein tschechischer Milliardär fährt da trotzdem mit 450 kmh da drüber. Dann sehen wir daran, das geht so nicht. Wir müssen uns hier wieder der Natur ergeben. Da gibt es natürlich ganz viele Beispiele. Angefangen bei Harald Lesch, der sagt, also die Begegnung des klimawandels bedeutet als allererstes mal Strom sparen, nicht neue Stromquellen finden, sondern einfach mal keine Energie mehr in diesem Maße benutzen. Es ist einfach viel zu viel. Und da finde ich fast so wichtig wie diese Occupy-Wallstreet-Argumente von damals, dass man heute einfach einsieht. Damals war es der, wir konnten ihr nicht ausweichen Finanzkrise, die Staaten haben diktiert, wie die Realität ist, also mussten wir uns fügen und Graeber hat gesagt nein. Und ich finde, jetzt kann man zehn Jahre später das Anfängebuch nehmen und sagen, die Gesellschaft hat gesagt, es muss so und so sein und die Befehle kommen jetzt aus dem RKI. Und das heißt, drei Monate lang bist du, nee man kann jetzt einfach mal die Wissenschaft da auch wieder gewähren lassen, sich das Virus wirklich angucken, was es im Körper macht und sagen, nee, wir wissen es besser als die Politik entscheidet, wir müssen da auch wirklich mal widerspruch üben. Und wenn ein Immunitätsstatus sechs Monate mindestens hält, dann hält er halt mindestens sechs Monate, egal was die Politik dazu sagt. Und daraus ausgehend so ganz viele Fragestellungen zulassen, bei denen einfach der, und da greife ich jetzt Graeber direkt auf, der gesunde Menschenverstand mit der Natur in Synchronität mal wieder gewähren lassen sollte, anstatt jetzt sich nur noch in so sozialen Problemen zu verstricken, wie zum Beispiel, ganz aktuell, Putin möchte die Ukraine überfallen. Weiter weg von der Natur und weiterhin an irgendeiner sozialen Verstrickung, also einfach nur kommunikatives Chaos sozusagen, kann man es gar nicht treiben und alle befassen sich aber nur damit. Und das ist ganz schön schade, dass wir uns da immer so verfangen. In deren Sicht auch ein klares Plädoyer.
Und wir plädieren für die Lektüre, oder? Trotz all unserer einwände würden wir schon sagen, wer sich die Zeit nehmen will, wer sich auch diesen ganzen Details aussetzen möchte und zugleich aber ein kontraintuitives Denken lernen möchte, ist da jetzt auch nicht ganz falsch aufgehoben.
Unbedingt. Und ich plädiere auch unbedingt dafür, sich ein paar von diesen schilderungen der Arzteken oder was auch immer, sich dann doch einfach mal durchzulesen. Man muss das weder sich merken noch verstehen, was es damit auf sich hat noch sonst irgendwie, sondern nur um so ein Gefühl zu gewinnen, dass das tatsächlich ging. Ich will mal nicht sagen geht, sondern dass es wirklich so ging, dass es irgendwie anders möglich ist. Also eine andere Welt ist möglich. Wer diesen Satz anhängt, der sollte in der Geschichte noch mal nachlesen, was möglich ist, statt immer nur so in diesen Träumen. Man wünscht sich irgendwas zu verfangen und in deren Sicht steckt sehr viel Kluges in dem Buch, sehr viel Streitbares. Und es ist halt häufig schade, dass es laufende Debatten gibt, an die dann nicht angeschlossen wird. Aber die grundlegende These, also t-senden, mit denen kann man ja auf jeden Fall sympathisieren. Eigentum ist kein Recht, sondern Macht. Ich meine, das ist so ein Satz, wenn man einfach sagt Eigentum ist, dann ist man ganz nah bei Gunnar Heinsson, Eigentum, Zins und Geld, was er da geschrieben hat, diese ganze Eigentumseconomik. Und dann aber zu sagen, ist kein Recht, warum man sich fragt, der Recht ist doch eh das falsche Funktionssystem, wir sind ja in der Wirtschaft sozusagen. Und dann sagen die aber einfach, nee, es ist sogar Macht. Also die blenden der Wirtschaft komplett aus und sagen Eigentum, Recht, Macht. Das ist so grundlegend, da kann man jetzt so viel, wenn man die Gesellschaft der Gesellschaft Luhmann und so weiter da im Hinterkopf hat, könnte man jetzt so viel daraus ableiten, sich an Fragen stellen, zulassen oder überhaupt nur mal diese These annehmen, Eigentum ist gefährlich. Ja, dass man das einfach mal ernst nimmt und sich dann fragt, wo ist es am gefährlichsten? Da packen wir mal als erstes an und dann ist man ganz nah bei Immobilien und so weiter und so fort. Na ja, und ansonsten, für alle, die das Buch zu lang ist, würde ich sagen, dieses zweite Kapitel über die Kolonialisierungsgeschichte, das ist ja fast ein eigenständiger Text eigentlich. Den kann man ja fast, ich habe jetzt die Tage den Benjamin von Stuttgart-Bacher bei Nils in der Nils Buckelberger Erfahrung im Podcast gehört, wie er über sein eigenes Schaffen spricht und dann immer wieder die Kritik von Leuten bekommt, die ihm sagen, wieso hast du das in ein Buch geschrieben, das hätte doch für drei gereicht. Also wenn man so mit ideen ineffizient umgeht. Und ich finde, wenn David Graeber hier gesagt hätte, hör mal zu, dieses Kapitel über die Kolonialisierung, mach mal unter eigener Überschrift und publizieren das und stoßen damit eine Debatte an. Weil jetzt geht es fast so ein bisschen unter in so einem, ja die Anfänge der Menschheit und überhaupt. Und dann ist man schon verfangen in so einer, ist das jetzt zu scharf formuliert, geht es hier zu politisch zu, ist das zu viel Ethnografie. So ein bisschen schade, dass dieses Kapitel dann so ein bisschen verschlungen wird von seinem eigenen Buch. Aber das lohnt sich dann wirklich mal zu lesen, glaube ich.
Anfänge ist eine hervorragende Diskussionsgrundlage und ein sehr streitbares Buch. Es lädt dazu ein, kontraintuitiv nicht nur über unsere Anfänge, sondern auch über unsere Gegenwart nachzudenken. Es hätte auch alles anders sein können. Sehr materialreich, sehr assoziativ, manchmal zu assoziativ, aber immer geistreich, argumentieren die Autoren.
Und wer der Darstellung anhängt, wir müssen hier mit ein bisschen Flickschusterei einen miserablen Zustand verbessern und die mit dramatischen Maßnahmen, die absolute Katastrophe verhindern, der schaue bitte, und das waren Zitate aus diesem eigentlich historisch angelegten Buch, das aber so krass politisch ist, dass wir es eigentlich als das verstehen müssen, was es ist, nämlich eine Streitschrift, egal was irgendwelche akademiker dazu sagen.
Verschickst du eigentlich noch Gifs oder hast du jemals Gifs verschickt? Also diese Graphics Interchange Format.
Ich bin Emoji Guy.
Bist du?
Ja. Ich schicke nur Emojis. Gifs rauszusuchen?
Nee. Ja, du bist dann jetzt schon wieder an der Sperrspitze des Fortschritts, denn es gab in Weiß einen Artikel Gifs are for Boomers now. Und ja, das ist auch die These. Junge Leute finden das irgendwie ein bisschen komisch, wenn sie Gifs geschickt bekommen. Das macht man vor allem dann nicht, wenn man jung ist. Also da gibt es einen Bericht darüber, dass Taylor Swift offenbar ein Gif postete, um irgendeinen Erfolg zu feiern mit ihrem neuen Album. Und dann hat sofort jemand drunter geschrieben. Ja, alles in Ordnung, Oma. Aber warum verschickst du noch Gifs? Naja, es heißt dem Artikel Gifs mögen derzeit uncool sein, aber das bedeutet nicht, dass sie unpopulär sind. Zu Beginn der pandemie meldete die Gif Bibliothek Giphy oder Giphy, Giphy sagen wir lieber, das erinnert uns so sehr an Berlin, Giphy, dass die Gif Nutzung in einem einzigen Monat um 33 Prozent gestiegen ist. Vielleicht haben sie das in ihrer Familien-WhatsApp-Gruppe auch beobachtet, zumindest anekdotisch scheint es, dass viele Mütter, Väter und Großmütter während des Lockdowns zum ersten Mal Gifs entdeckten. Und auch wenn dies noch nicht offiziell bestätigt wurde, dann gibt es doch einige Hinweise dafür. Die Generation Z mag denken, dass Gifs von Millennials geliebt werden, aber gleichzeitig beginnen viele Millennials Gifs als Spielerei der Boomer zu betrachten. Also wir haben hier wieder einen Generationen-Konflikt und der wird ausgetragen im digitalen Zeitalter dadurch, was ist jetzt gerade die entsprechende Kommunikationsform, die man wählt. Wir haben ja solche Abgrenzungsversuche der einzelnen Generationen sehr stark früher über die mode gehabt. Ich glaube, das ist immer schwieriger möglich, da die mode sich so ungeheuer angepasst hat. Das heißt, was du jetzt gerade trägst, kann ja auch genauso ein 14-jähriger oder ein 22-jähriger tragen oder könnte auch ein jung gebliebener 75-jähriger tragen. Da gibt es eigentlich keinen großen Unterschied. Jetzt gibt es vielleicht ein paar Trendmarken und ein paar so außergewöhnliche Sneaker, dass damit vielleicht nicht der 60-Jährige unterwegs ist. Aber doch gibt es da so eine große Angleichung, dass also die Distinktion stark darüber zu laufen scheint, wie man kommuniziert. Wir haben das, glaube ich, auch schon mal in dem Facebook Buch besprochen gesehen gehabt. Und zwar hat Mark Zuckerberg sich da unterhalten mit dem damaligen Instagram-Chef, glaube ich, per E-Mail. Und Mark Zuckerberg hat noch die E-Mail geschlossen mit das, was ich jetzt auch z. B immer noch tue, indem man am ende den Namen schreibt. Irgendwie Best Wishes, Wolfgang oder so. Und das hat Mark Zuckerberg gemacht. Und damit war aber für die Instagram-Leute wieder klar. Ich glaube, es war Instagram. Ah ja, gut, der ist jetzt auch schon so ein älterer Herr. Der macht ja am ende noch so eine Grußformel. Und genauso finden wir das jetzt hier auch mit den Gifs. Die Funktion hat Twitter 2016 eingeführt, dann auch sehr schnell WhatsApp und iMessage. Alle, die verfügen über Gif und Giffy. wurde ja von Facebook erst im Jahr 2020 gekauft. Und zwar für 400 Millionen. Ah, 21.
Oktober 21, 60 Millionen.
Ja.
Und auch gestern hat das Wiener Gericht geurteilt, ja, es ist zulässig. Die Briten stellen sich immer noch quer. So ist ganz komisch. Ich weiß gar nicht, in welchem Zustand das da gerade ist. Aber als ich hörte, dass Facebook Giffy kauft, da habe ich auch so gedacht. Ja, ja, Max Sagerberg, der schreibt ja auch seinen Namen unter E-Mails. Das war so ein richtiger Boomer-Beruf eigentlich.
Linda Kaye, Professorin für Cyberpsychologie, sagt, das sieht es gar nicht so sehr wundert, dass Gifs jetzt bei der jungen Generation aus der mode gekommen sind. Denn man kann ja inzwischen sehr leicht personalisierte Gifs versenden. Also Gifs war ja erst mal noch originell, als man vielleicht erst zum zwanzigsten Mal dieses eine Gif mit Leonardo DiCaprio erhalten hat, wo er dieses Cocktailglas in die Höhe hebt. Aber das hat sich ja dann doch schnell abgenutzt. Heute im TikTok-Zeitalter, wo wir diese Kurzformate gewünscht sind und jedes Handy das alles kann, kann man doch selber gerade so ein Gif versenden. Also du schickst mir, was ich will mich bedanken vor meines Gifs und zeichne selber da gerade irgendeine Kremasse oder was auch und schick dir das. Und das ist die jugendliche Form des Gif-Kommunizierens. Und damit löst man sich also von einer standardisierten Gif-Datenbank, wo man einfach dann das eingibt, heulendes Kind, und dann bekommt man das entsprechende Gif. Man kann es ja selbst mal gerade nachahmen. Und das ist die neue Form, also wie man reagiert, wenn man dann selbst mal die Kamera einschaltet. Man braucht gar nicht mehr dieses Gif, sondern kann das jetzt wieder individualisierter machen. Das ist zumindest eine These in diesem Weiß-Artikel. Ich habe vielleicht fünf Gifs in meinem Leben versendet, mehr glaube ich nicht. Und ich werde es aber jetzt auch sein lassen, damit ich da nicht zum alten Eisen zähle, wenngleich ich aber auch keine kurzvideos von mir aufnehmen möchte.
Nein, ja, also ja, ich stimme dir natürlich zu. Aber ich wollte noch sagen, zum Glück hat der Text am ende noch abgebogen. Denn ja, das iPhone und auch die Android-Telefone nehmen ja Live-Fotos auf. Also du kriegst ja für jedes Foto immer so ein 2-sekunden-video. Das bietet sich natürlich sehr an, in ein GIF verwandelt zu werden. Und unter iOS gibt es unter den Kurzbefehlen eine App, die kaum jemand nutzt, die aber wahrscheinlich eine der spektakulärsten Erfindungen der modernen Menschheit ist. Auch GIFs herstellen ist standardmäßig schon vorgesehen. Also es gibt ein paar Kurzbefehle, die gibt Apple schon mit von Werkseiten und das zum Beispiel das GIF erstellen dabei. Man kann also irgendwelche bilder oder videos, also Live-Fotos oder videos, die man hat, aus seiner Bibliothek auswählen, den Kurzbefehl durchlaufen lassen und hat dann ein GIF. Und so stelle ich auch ab und zu GIFs her. Das letzte, was ich in die Familie verschickt habe, war, wie meine Frau den kindern vorliest, während sie gleichzeitig Hula Hoop macht. Und da habe ich sehr lang gebraucht, genau zwei Reifen um Drehungen abzuwarten, sodass es möglichst im Loop durchläuft, ohne dass man sieht, wo Anfang und ende ist. Also es lohnt sich sehr, mit GIFs zu spielen, aber wie gesagt, nicht in den Boomer-Datenbanken rumsuchen. Also das Facebook GIFi gekauft hat, fand ich war einfach bescheuert. Da haben sie sich wieder rumgeschlagen mit irgendeinem Blödsinn und das ist einfach bekloppt.
Ja, Facebook geht es ja auch nicht so gut, aber darüber sprechen wir vielleicht ende des Monats. Mal schauen, was sich da noch so ergibt.
Wenn es noch da ist.
Naja, ich bin da. Naja, ich würde mal sagen, man sollte nicht sofort hier schon was ausrufen, denn Facebook hat sich ja häufiger schon berappelt. Ich will noch neben diesem Artikel auf was ganz anderes hinweisen. Da habe ich jetzt keinen Text mitgebracht, aber das ist mir wirklich ein Anliegen, auf diese Seite hinzuweisen. Und zwar heißt die thecryptosyllabus.com ist natürlich verlinkt in der Beschreibung, da kann man das finden. Und zwar auf dieser Seite erscheinen Interviews und Texte von Wissenschaftlern, vor allem Ökonomen aus aller Welt, die sich in irgendeiner Weise kritisch mit Kryptowährungen, Metaverse und NFT und allem, was damit zu tun hat, auseinandersetzen. Ich bin darauf gestoßen, weil ich ein Interview im Freitag las mit Edimilson Parana. Der hat den Krypto-Hype in Brasilien untersucht. Und man kann sich denken, dass das unter Bolsonaro auch blüht. Und da war dann im Freitag ein Hinweis, dass das eine gekürzte Form eines Interviews ist, das bei The Crypto Syllabus erschienen ist. Und dann habe ich diese Seite geöffnet. Und es ist großartig, was da alles zu lesen ist. Also ich habe erst mal angefangen zu sichten. Adam Toos ist da auch mit einem Text vertreten. Viele, viele weitere. Und man kann wirklich einen globalen Überblick über das bekommen, was da so in der Kryptoszene los ist über die libertären ideologien. Also von ganz verschiedenen Seiten wird drauf geplägt. Also wer sich auch nur annähernd dafür interessiert, sollte auf jeden Fall diese Seite aufsuchen, die das sehr gut sammelt und kuratiert, was es dazu alles gibt. Und das ist ein ganz, ganz großartiger Ort, wo man sich richtig austoben kann und sich vertiefen kann in Lektüren. Deswegen habe ich jetzt gar nicht einen Text mitgebracht, sondern wirklich auf diese Seite hinweisen, dass man sie besucht. Denn das ist großartig, was da alles gesammelt wird.
Sehr gut, bleiben wir mal ganz in der moderne. Denn das Autofahren war Thema in diesem Januar. Bei Zeit Online zum Beispiel lautet die Überschrift soziale Kosten des Straßenverkehrs. Was Autofahren wirklich kostet. Klar, wenn man jetzt in die originale Studie reingucken kann, mache ich hier auch nicht. Ich verlasse mich auf den Journalismus, der hat es gut aufgeschlüsselt. Demnach subventioniert die Gesellschaft jedes Jahr jährlich Autos mit im Schnitt 5000 Euro. Und wie man dazu kommt, Jessica Keyes und Todd Littmann haben diese Studie dazu gemacht, um die Kosten eines 50-jährigen Autofahrerlebens anhand von 33 Faktoren zu berechnen. Und da geht es erstaunlicherweise nicht nur ums Geld, sondern Geld war nur dieser Aufhänge auch für die Debatte. Aber auch beim Geld ist schon interessant. Typische deutsche Fahrleistungen sind 15.000 Kilometer, von denen ist man ausgegangen, pro Auto. Das bedeutet für ein Opel Corsa, dass das Autofahrerleben 599.082 Euro kostet. Bei einem mercedes GLC sind es bis zu 956.798 Euro, die dann jährlich runtergebrochen werden können. Da kommt ja die Zahl auch her. Bei diesem mercedes auf 5273 Euro. Die Kostenpunkte sind Luftverschmutzung, Landverbrauch, Infrastruktur, Lärm und dann kommt erst der klimawandel. Luftverschmutzung alleine bei einem Corsa 1495 Euro im Jahr. Irgendwann, glaube ich schon, wird diese Zeit anbrechen, indem wir, so wie wir rauchen, indoor verboten haben. Auto fahren, outdoor mit einem Auspuff. Einfach als das ansehen, was es ist. Nämlich einfach eklig. Und Landverbrauch, das kennen wir. Infrastruktur, Autobahnbau, wie auch immer. Und jetzt geht es ans Eingemachte. Jenseits der Geldargumentation zeigen diese veröffentlichten Daten, zum Beispiel der Global burden of Disease Study, dass die Luftverschmutzung Krankheit natürlich bedeutet, aber auch im Schnitt ein Jahr Lebenszeit für uns alle. Also Autofahrer klauen uns ein Jahr Lebenszeit. Also nicht nur sich selbst, sondern auch uns Unbeteiligten. Und Lebenszeit meint da nicht nur früher tot, sondern 40 stunden stand der typische Autopendler 2021 im Stau. Das entspricht also einer Arbeits- oder Urlaubswoche. Genau, kann man mal genau so formulieren. In München sind es sogar 79 stunden. Also zwei. Das sind schon crazy Zahlen. Das Problem ist so ein bisschen und das ist die Sackgasse unserer modernität. Hat sich ein Haushalt einmal ein PKW besorgt, wird er für fast alle Wege genutzt. Und zwar weil es so gewollt ist. Das ist der Erfolg des Marketings. Und das ist natürlich ein echtes Problem. Und dann rechnen sie es mal durch für das konkrete Leben, das ein Auto braucht, um zum Beispiel zur Arbeit zu kommen. Und die sozialisierten Kosten werden dann auf die Biografie als Last der Erwerbsarbeit draufgeschlagen. Zitat. würde ein ungelernter Arbeiter auch die gesellschaftlichen Kosten tragen, müsste er 60 Prozent seines Lebenseinkommens aufbringen, um einen Opel Corsa zu fahren. Also wir können uns das eigentlich gar nicht leisten. Und wir haben nur einen riesigen Subventionsbetrieb, der es ja auch immer intransparent und unsichtbar macht, dass wir das überhaupt alles haben. Und sie schlagen so gleich die Alternative vor. Alternativen wie ein Jahresticket für den ÖPNV in Kombination mit Carsharing und anderen Mobilitätsangeboten sind natürlich weitaus günstiger.
Aber nur, wenn es ausgebaut ist.
Ganz genau. Und man könnte ja dieses ganze Geld, was eh in Bewegung ist, um das Autofahren zu subventionieren, was im grunde Geld ist, das direkt dieser Autoindustrie zugutekommt, einfach umwidmen. Das wäre auch so eine idee für eine kommende Regierung. Und dann kann man es auch ausbauen. Also das sind ja unglaubliche gelder, die da zur Verfügung stünden. Allein die sozialen Kosten sind 5.000 Euro pro Person. Das ist schon eine Bankart 100 für jeden. Und wenn tatsächlich Bankart 100s mal in diesem Umfang gekauft werden, dann sind auch bei den Bankart 100-Verkäufern extrem viel gelder da, um irgendwas zu organisieren. Wir wissen alle, man hat zwar dann die Möglichkeit, eine Bankart 100 leer zu fahren, aber wer fährt wirklich zweimal die Woche von München nach Berlin? Also es ist dann sozusagen dieses Luxusgut, ständige Mobilität mit dem Topping. Sie bleibt Möglichkeit, man muss sie gar nicht. Also man radiert diese einfach aus dem Kopf raus, dass man denkt, jetzt habe ich es ja investiert, jetzt muss ich es auch machen. sondern dann wäre es einfach gegeben, dass wir mobil sind und zwar unabhängig von irgendwelchen Autos und das, was es für unser modernes Leben bedeutet, nämlich dass man und das kennen wir ja an den bildern, eine Häuserzeile komplett ausspart um Parkgelegenheiten im einen Stock. Also es ist ja nur ein Stock Park, ist ja Parken an der Straße. Ja, das ist ja totale Landverschwendung eigentlich. Also in der Ansicht in die Richtung.
Ich sehe das Problem und würde das auch gar nicht leugnen wollen. Ich frage mich nur immer, wie müsste Deutschland gestaltet sein, damit wir ohne Auto auskommen? Und damit meine ich jetzt nicht, wie lebe ich in der Großstadt ohne Auto? Die meisten Leute, die ich kenne, die in der Großstadt leben, haben kein Auto. oder die haben noch ein Auto irgendwo in der Garage stehen. Und wenn die mal zu ihren Eltern fahren, dann fahren die da mal mit dem Auto hin, weil sie die kinder mitnehmen wollen und was weiß ich was. Aber die meisten Menschen in Deutschland leben ja nicht in der Stadt. oder nicht in Städten, die entsprechend so groß sind, jetzt wie Frankfurt, Köln oder Berlin. Und ich könnte zum Beispiel, auch wenn ich sagen würde, ich gebe alles aus für öffentlichen Nahverkehr, wie ich will. Also das wäre ja jetzt nicht die Sache. Also wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, ich kaufe mir da alle Monatskarten, die es gibt, alles, was geht und kaufe mir noch eine Bahnkarte, 100 wegen mir, dann würde ich trotzdem mit meinem Auto sehr viel weiterkommen. Beziehungsweise könnte, wenn ich all diese Tickets hätte, damit oft gar nichts anfangen. Also ich fahre zum Beispiel jetzt diese Woche. Mir drei oder vier Filme im Kino ansehen. Da mache ich da manchmal zwei zusammen auf einmal. Ich habe es damit im Kino zu tun, dass es im Industriegebiet liegt. Da komme ich nicht anders hin. Also ich könnte laufen, aber dann wäre ich halt eine stunde unterwegs oder so. Das mache ich natürlich nachts, laufe ich nicht durch ein Industriegebiet. Aber es gibt keine andere Möglichkeit. Ich könnte jetzt viele Beispiele nennen, die nicht gehen, wenn ich jetzt von Koblenz aus auch nur irgendjemanden im Umfeld besuchen will, der nicht in Koblenz ist, also nicht in der Innenstadt ist. Wird das eine Lebensaufgabe fast. Und da bin ich ja noch in Koblenz. Also ich lebe ja jetzt hier nicht in der Wallach hei. Ja, wenn ich jetzt mal in die Eifel, in den Hunsrück, in den Westerwald gehe, da ist es ja zum Teil so, da denkt man ist ja erstaunlich, dass überhaupt noch ein Auto da hinfährt, dass überhaupt Straßen ausgebaut sind.
Ja, also es ist der Gipfel, hoffe ich zumindest, einer 50-, 60-, 70-jährigen Lobbyismusgeschichte, die uns mit entsprechendem trägen sozialen wandel dahin führte, dass wir nicht von heute auf morgen einfach wechseln können. Das ist ja klar, aber ich glaube, der Einstieg in die neue Mobilität liegt auch in der Erkenntnis, dass man mit dem Auto als Privateigentum nicht die individuelle Mobilität abschafft. Also dieses von Haustür zu Haustür. Das kann man auch. Und dann ist es nicht nur das Auto, sondern auch noch der Fahrer, der mit in die Rechnung reinkommt. Taxi ganz konkret billiger machen, als mit der Anschaffung eines privaten Autos für jeden einzelnen Menschen. Also selbst ein Taxiverkehr wäre noch kostengünstiger, unsozialverträglicher und umweltverträglicher, weil dieses Taxi setzt sich irgendwo ab und fährt dann direkt weiter. Und da müssen nicht noch zehn andere Taxis hergestellt werden, sondern klar, es gibt eine Rush Hour. Man sagt ja immer, die Autos stehen zu 90 Prozent rum. Ja, aber wenn sie sich bewegen, alle gleichzeitig. Das gilt für die Arbeitswelt auch nicht mehr als zu sehr. Also die Rush Hour in Frankfurt ist von 7 bis 10 Uhr. Die Leute fahren ja teilweise so spät zur Arbeit, dass man sich denkt, so hätte man das in der DDR nicht gemacht. Und gerade diese Vergnügungsreisen, die du dann abends machst zum Kino, die sind hochindividuell. Du bist auch bereit, zehn Minuten zu warten auf einem Parkplatz, bis dein Taxi kommt. Also das sind alles so soziale Konventionen, die kann man wunderbar, gerade mit der digitalen Technik, die wir haben, wo man einfach alle Synergieneffekte nutzen kann. Ich brauche nicht viel Fantasie, um mir das vorzustellen.
Und man müsste auch fördern, dass es geförderte Taxis geben.
Ja, ich finde es auch ganz wichtig, die idee, die Menschen vom Fahren des Autos zu entlasten, sage ich jetzt, weil ich keinen Führerschein habe, und trotzdem am individuellen Straßenverkehr teilnehme, nämlich übers Taxi, wenn ich dann mal eins brauche. Und das finde ich eine noch viel wichtigere Komponente. Und da finde ich, ist auch das Einfallstor für den großen wirtschaftlichen Nutzen, dass nämlich relativ viele Leute dann kombinieren, bewegt zu werden und gleichzeitig die Welt zu bewegen, indem sie nämlich frei haben zu arbeiten. oder, und das ist ja die neue idee, warum fährst du eigentlich mit einem Taxi ins Kino? Warum guckst du den Film nicht einfach im Taxi?
Nein, man möchte ja schon jetzt nach zwei Jahren pandemie vielleicht auch mal wieder Erlebnisse an Orten haben. Und das muss ja nicht immer nur Kino sein, das kann ja zum Beispiel auch Museum sein. Ich wollte dir nur sagen, wie offen meine ich bin. Ja, ja, aber ich wäre jetzt auch mal gerne wieder irgendwo präsent und würde auch mal gerne wieder irgendwo hin. Und ich sehe natürlich das Problem, aber es ist, wie du sagst, es ist eine Geschichte des Lobbyismus und es ist eine Geschichte der falschen Entscheidungen, kann man hier auch noch mal ganz deutlich sagen mit Bezug zu Graeber und Wengrow. Denn das müsste so nicht sein und natürlich könnte vieles viel besser organisiert sein. Und es könnte auch carsharing-modelle geben, die sehr viel praktischer werden. Denn es ist natürlich so, dass die meisten Autos einfach nur rumstehen und sehr lange rumstehen und das ist sehr eng mit ideologie verknüpft, dass man sagt, ja das Auto, das ist das eigene Reich und das muss auch besonders gehegt und gepflegt werden. Das sind ja alles Dinge, die für mich vollkommen irrelevant sind. Ich fand das schon immer toll bei den Franzosen, dass die so gegenseitig die Autos anditchen, um so in die Parklücke reinzukommen. Das wäre ja in Deutschland, ich wüsste gar nicht, gibt es hier ein größeres Verbrechen, als so was zu tun? Und das ist aber reine ideologie, wenn man einfach sagt, naja das ist halt wie so ein Einkaufswagen, den schiebt man ein bisschen hin und her, kommt dann besser rein. Das ist etwas, was lange eingeübt ist und das muss auch erst mal wieder ausgetrieben werden.
rumstehende Autos sind die Pest. Meine kinder erschrecken sich immer, wenn sie in so eine Kistanie kicken und dann haut die plötzlich gegen das Auto. Ich denke, es ist nur ein Auto, entspann dich, schimpf dich nicht an, nur weil du einen roten Lack berührt hast. Es ist ja nicht mal was passiert. Und rumstehende Autos. Ich habe gelesen, der neue Batman dauert drei stunden. Und um Mitternacht, wenn wir dann alle aus dem Kino abgeholt werden müssen, stehen die meisten Autos wirklich rum. Da ist das Argument dann gegeben zu sagen, fahrt sie bitte nach Hause, die Batman-Gucker. Gut, haben wir schon wieder ein Problem gelöst. Das ist doch sehr gut.
Ja, vielleicht auch nicht. Wir leben in merkwürdigen politischen Zeiten. Und zwar gab es ja mal diese These, die auch lange Zeit stimmte. Irgendwie ist jetzt Postpolitik angesagt. Wir haben schon Fukuyama erwähnt. Und diese postpolitische Stimmung, die hat doch die 90er Jahre sehr stark geprägt. Das ist ein Text erschienen von Anton Jäger im Jacobin-Magazin. Der ist übertitelt mit Von der Postpolitik zu Hyperpolitik. Und was kann das sein? Zunächst einmal bezieht er sich da auf einen Roman, auf eine Autobiografie von Annie Arnault, die Jahre. Und die Autoren beschreibt da die 90er. Und da heißt es, eine politische Endzeitstimmung breitete sich aus. Eine neue Weltordnung wurde ausgerufen. Das ende der Geschichte sei nah. Das Wort Kampf wurde als Überbleibsel des Marxismus entsorgt, den niemand mehr ernst nahm. Und mit widerstand war nur noch der widerstand der Verbraucher gemeint. Und diese postpolitische Stimmung, die hat dann sich breit gemacht. Wir kennen dann diese Politik der Neuen Mitte, Tony Blair, Gerhard schröder und, und, und. Alle gehen in so einem Konsumrausch auf. Und wir können das noch sehr gut nachvollziehen. Aber Anton Jägern sagt, das ist eine Beschreibung, die trifft irgendwie heute nicht mehr zu. Er sagt dann, biden wurde mit einer ungewöhnlich hohen Wahlbeteiligung zum präsidenten gewählt. Das Brexit-Referendum war das größte demokratische, die größte demokratische Abstimmung in der Geschichte Großbritanniens. Die Black Lives Matter-Proteste waren ein Massenereignis. Viele der größten Unternehmen der Welt starteten Marketingkampagnen, unter deren Deckmantel sie Vorgaben des Anliegen der Proteste zu teilen. Eine neue Form von Politik ist entstanden. Sie ist auf jedem Fußballplatz präsent, in populären Netflix-Sendungen und der Selbstbeschreibung von Menschen in den sozialen Medien. Aber was ist denn das jetzt? Er sagt, die Ära der Postpolitik ist eindeutig zu ende. Aber das heißt nicht, dass wir jetzt wieder in die Politik des 20. jahrhunderts zurückkehren. Heute nämlich ist alles politisch. Und er schreibt, und obwohl viele Menschen stark politisiert sind, sind nur sehr wenige von ihnen in organisierte Interessenkonflikte eingebunden, die wir vielleicht als typisch für das 20. jahrhundert bezeichnen können. Was er dann sieht, ist eigentlich eine Politik der flachen Hierarchien, der Bewegungen und keine Parteien, keine Organisationen sind mehr das entscheidende. Wir können das besonders bei den Parteien erleben. Also die flämischen christdemokraten zählten 1990 130.000 mitglieder, heute nur noch 43.000. Dann kann man sich die Sozialisten in Belgien ansehen. 90.000 mitglieder vor 30 Jahren, jetzt noch 10.000. Die SPD hatte 1986 eine Million mitglieder, heute noch 400.000. Und das wahrscheinlich auch nur noch so viel, weil es mal diesen Schulzzug gab und Kevin Kühnert und so weiter. Und die sozialdemokraten in den niederlanden schrumpften von über 100.000 auf 41.000 mitglieder. Es gibt nur eine Ausnahme, das war die Labour-Partei unter Corbyn, diese kurze episode. Da stieg die Zahl von 150.000 plötzlich wieder auf 600.000. Aber sonst können wir erleben, dass eigentlich diese Organisationen zurückgehen. Wenn wir jetzt Zahlen von den Gewerkschaften hätten, dann könnten wir wahrscheinlich Ähnliches beobachten, vielleicht noch dramatischeres. Jelga schreibt, seither sind eigenartige neue Formationen an die Stelle der Massenorganisation des 20. jahrhunderts getreten. Von La France Insoumis und podemos auf der Linken bis zu Macron's La Republique en Marche in der Mitte und Italiens Fünf-Sterne-Bewegung auf der Rechten versprachen zahlreiche sogenannte digitale Parteien, weniger Bürokratie, mehr Partizipation und neue Formen der hierarchiefreien Politik. In Wirklichkeit verschafften sie vor allen den Persönlichkeiten, um die diese Projekte herum aufgebaut worden waren, geballte Macht. Und er verweist noch was, war mir auch nicht so klar. Der vorsitzende der belgischen sozialistischen Partei feierte kürzlich das Aufbruchsklima in der Partei, in dem er die frische Start-up-Atmosphäre in seiner Partei begrüßte und seine Followerzahlen auf Instagram stolz präsentierte. Parteien stellen nun regelmäßig Social Media Managerinnen und Manager ein und verbreiten ihre Botschaften über Influencer. Macron, also das war mir natürlich nicht neu, aber dass das so weitreichend in ganz Europa zu beobachten ist. Macron empfing kürzlich etwa zwei YouTube-Vlogger in seinem präsidentenpalast. Letztlich zeigt sich in den neuen digitalen Parteien und den Bewegungen, aus denen sie hervorgingen, keine Ablehnung der postindustriellen Wirtschaft. Sie sind vielmehr deren Ausdruck hochgradig informell und temporär organisiert, ohne langfristige Verträge um flüchtige Start-ups und Projekte herum organisiert. Das heißt, diese modernen Arbeitsweisen drücken sich auch in der Form aus, wie Protest organisiert wird. Und jetzt kommt etwas, was er sehr geschickt macht. Er vergleicht jetzt mal doch sehr unterschiedliche Strömungen, um es mal vornehm zu formulieren. Dieser Voluntarismus spiegelt sich auch in der anhaltenden Proteststimmung wider, die in der heutigen Politik so verbreitet ist. Oberflächlich betrachtet lässt sich zwischen den Protesten von Black Lives Matter, QAnon und den Unruhen vom 6. Januar in Washington DC kaum eine Gemeinsamkeit ausmachen. Und sicherlich liegen moralisch betrachtet Welten zwischen ihnen. Die eine Bewegung protestiert gegen Polizeiprotalität und Rassismus, die andere gegen einen fingierten Wahlbetrug und eine vermeintliche Verschwörung. Organisatorisch ähneln sich die Bewegungen jedoch. Sie haben keine mitgliederlisten. Es gibt kaum Möglichkeiten, die mitglieder zu disziplinieren und sie haben keine formalisierte Form. Und das ist es, was Jäger nun Hyperpolitik nennt. Die Hyperpolitik zeichnet sich jedoch auch durch ihren spezifischen Fokus auf zwischenmenschliche und persönliche Gepflogenheiten aus. Also die identität spielt jetzt eine ganz große Frage. Und das können wir ja überall beobachten, im Prinzip auch jeden Tag auf Twitter bei all diesen Kämpfen. Er sagt dann auch, das drückt sich vor allem in Moralismus aus und in der Unfähigkeit, die Dimensionen kollektiver Kämpfe zu durchdenken. Das heißt, dadurch sind diese Bewegungen zwar oft laut und finden irgendwie statt, aber was verändern sie wirklich? Da muss man sich ja schon Fragen stellen. Das heißt, auch so ein revolutionäres Subjekt ist natürlich weit und breit nicht zu sehen. Er schreibt dann die Hyperpolitik, tritt an die Stelle der Postpolitik. Die Frage, was die Menschen besitzen und kontrollieren, wird dabei zunehmend durch die Frage ersetzt, wer oder was die Menschen sind. Und der Kampf der Klassen wird durch die Gegenüberstellung von identitäten ersetzt. Und wenn ich das nochmal verknüpfe mit unserer Lektüre eben, dann hast du ja gesagt, Eigentum. Darüber müssen wir nachdenken. Darüber müssen wir reden. Und aufgrund dessen muss sich eine andere Politik realisieren. Dann können wir hier mit dieser Diagnose, der ich zustimme, gerade weil ich die ganzen SIN-Fluencer ja auch verfolgt habe, muss ich sagen, ja, das ist natürlich sehr schade, dass genau das, was Menschen besitzen und kontrollieren, nicht in Frage gestellt wird. Und stattdessen macht man dann irgendwie, ja, diese komischen Selbstbespiegelungen, die da bei Instagram stattfindet und verkauft das auch noch als Politik.
Genau, wir erinnern an den großen deutschen Philosophen Felix Lobrecht in der sternstunde Philosophie, wie er noch mal darauf hinwies, dass ja Armut nie eine Rolle spielt, obwohl wir so viel darüber wissen, aber dass eines akademisches Denken und das andere politisches handelt. Und nirgendwo könnte die Welt getrennter sein als da. Passend dazu, ich schließe direkt an, du hast jetzt thematisiert, dass die Politik weniger organisiert im außerparlamentarischen stattfindet. Also Parteien sind in kleiner Gewerkschaften fast nicht existent als politische Betriebe. Und beim Redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland kam ein Text, querdenkerszene, radikal und einsam. Wir haben es also gar nicht mehr mit Organisation, egal in welcher Form oder Vergemeinschaftung zu tun, sondern nur noch mit imaginierten Gruppen. Also in David Graeber Sinne. Das sind jenseits des sozialen Horizontes. Irgendwelche, keine Ahnung. Sie zeigen sich quasi nur im Internet. Und der ehemalige Leiter des Verfassungsschutz Nordrhein-Westfalen, Burkhard Freyer, wird hier zitiert. Wir müssen ganz grundlegend ansetzen und uns fragen, welche Emotionen sind die triebfeder für die querdenker? Es sind natürlich die existenziellen Nöte. Es geht um Angst. Man hat auch Angst vor der Krankheit oder weiß es nicht so genau. Und es ist aber auch die Angst vor der Einsamkeit. Man hat beispielsweise mal untersucht, wer dem bayerischen ministerpräsidenten Markus söder eigentlich die Hassbriefe schreibt, die er da ständig bekommt. Und es stellt sich heraus, es sind Männer über 50, überwiegend alleinstehend, die ja dann auch Gewalt, und der Gewaltbegriff kann ja früh beginnen, als Schreibtischtäter, wo man so eine Eskalationsgeschichte hin zur Gewalt, wo Gewalt sozusagen die soziale Beziehung noch ist, die man sich vorstellt. Also wenn Kontakt zu, dann ist es sozusagen die Gewalttätige. Aber zu denen, mit denen man da eigentlich sympathisiert, hat man gar keinen Kontakt, sondern die kennt man nur so aus dem Internet. Es scheint da doch welche zu geben. Man imaginiert sich so in so eine Gruppe hinein. Und ein Beispiel für so ein Exemplar ist dieser Täter, der in dieser Tankstelle damals gebeten wurde, eine Maske aufzusetzen und der dann den jungen studenten da erschossen hat, der da gearbeitet hat. Das scheint so ein Einzelgängertyp gewesen zu sein. Nun ja, was also wenn, so hier die These, die Irrsinnigen, so steht es im Text, die Irrsinnigen einfach nur niemanden mehr zum reden finden und damit auch niemanden, der sie bremst. Also so verstrickt im Internet das typische Rabbit Hole Problem, dass man hier Einsamkeit als Ursache ausmacht. Nils Minkmann hat sich wohl in der süddeutschen auch dazu geäußert, da wird ein bisschen zitiert. Es sind die, Zitat, stundenlangen Solo-Sessions vor Radikalisier- Radikalisierungs-Filmchen und dann angebunden eben Chatgruppen, wo man auch so ein bisschen in Interaktion tritt, aber quasi doch nur mit seinem Computer kommuniziert.
Und das ist hyperpolitisch, aber nicht im Sinne einer richtigen Politik dann. Also hyperpolitisch ist das dann in der Form, dass alles politisiert wird. Da wird ja dann auch jede jede Auftrittsweise von Baerbock politisiert in irgendeiner Weise. oder es wird alles als politisch erklärt. Wer ist noch Fleisch? Wer ist kein Fleisch mehr? Und das können wir auf der anderen Seite dann auch tatsächlich bei diesen Sintfluenzern oder so erleben, die auch dann Fridays for Future natürlich supporten. Aber mehr so als ach, das ist eigentlich eine ganz schöne Kulisse, die diese ganzen Schüler und studenten mir bieten, wenn die da in Berlin demonstrieren. Da könnte ich mich doch auch noch mal mit meinem Plakat hinstellen und ein bisschen sagen, ja, hier ist mir alles ganz wichtig. Und hier findet ihr den Link für den Nachhaltigkeitsshop. Also das ist dadurch, dass alles politisiert wird, ist natürlich auch ganz schwer dagegen noch irgendwie Partei zu erkaufen, weil man sagt, ja, wir sind doch, wir sind doch auch hier für mehr Klimaschutz oder so. Und es wird gar nicht mehr über die eigentlichen Sachen, also besitzen, kontrollieren. Wer tut das eigentlich? Über das wird alles nicht gesprochen. Und das ist eine ganz, ganz tragische Entwicklung. Und ich will mal hier die, wir sind hier unter uns im Salon, die Prognose waren, das wird mit Fridays for Future nicht mehr richtig Fahrt aufnehmen, ist meine Theorie. Also das bleibt jetzt diese Hyperpolitik. Das heißt, da werden einige aus den Fridays for Future entweder in Parteienkarriere machen oder vielleicht dann tatsächlich in Aufsichtsräten oder irgendwelchen Nachhaltigkeits-Startups. Aber da wird sich jetzt nichts draus bilden, sonst würde man jetzt viel mehr schon über Besitzung, Kontrollieren sprechen und würde aufgrund der hohen Energiepreise nicht irgendwie sagen, wir müssen mal einen dicken Pulli anziehen, wie das so manche Influencer getan haben und dann irgendwelche sinnlosen Tipps geben zum Heizgeld sparen, sondern man würde jetzt sich auch tatsächlich mit denen solidarisieren, die wenig haben und würde da gemeinschaftlich eine Allianz bilden und das würde aber auf Solidarität hinauslaufen. Das heißt auch, sich mit dem anderen auseinandersetzen und ich glaube, hier sind auch sehr viele Vereinshinter unterwegs. Ich bekam heute morgen von einem Online Shop eine E-Mail, die mir mitteilte, dass sie den Valentinstag jetzt mal anders begehen, denn vor allem geht es ja darum, sich selbst zu lieben, wenn du jemanden toll finden willst, attraktiv finden willst, lieben willst, wurde mir geraten, dann schau doch einfach mal in den Spiegel. Ich glaube, das sagt ziemlich genau das aus, was die Influencer mit Me-Time und Self-Love und so weiter beschreiben und was dann auch in dem politischen Spektrum eine Rolle spielt, dass man entweder vereinsamt und sich radikalisiert und nur noch Hassbotschaften an Politiker verfasst oder man sagt dann ja, ich mache hier Me-Time, habe wieder irgendein neues Nachhaltigkeitsprodukt, das ich mir zuführe.
Genau, also in Rentenrepublik begegnen wir das auch immer wieder. Es ist sehr verführerisch über die pandemie, jetzt zu viel zu schreiben. So im Sinne von SETA, ich habe es schon immer gesagt, Einsamkeit ist ein Problem und so weiter. Aber wenn man dann genau hinschaut, wie der etwas langfristigere Trend, den du jetzt mit dieser Me-Time-Influencer-Touarei und so weiter, dass die Einsamkeit so ein modernes Problem ist, dass das mit dem iPhone im grunde in die Welt kam. Weil es ist ganz wichtig zu sehen, wir lesen auch gleich noch so ein Mingma Zitat, wo man das auch so im Hintergrund schwelen sieht. Wenn man sich mit seinem iPhone befasst, gilt dasselbe wie beim Fernsehen, verbringt man die Zeit gerade nicht mit seinen freunden, auch wenn sie mit dem Raum sind. Und der Tag hat aber nur 24 stunden. Also jenseits aller inhaltlichen Argumente gilt auch dieses Zeitargument. Und Nils Mingma schreibt das hier wie folgt. Und da kann man jetzt die Fridays for Future und die querdenker mal in eine funktionale Ecke stellen. Das sind Menschen, die sich sehr viel mit sich und der Welt im Großen und Ganzen befassen, das aber nicht mit anderen. So viele Demos gibt es ja dann auch nicht. Und klar, Schüler haben immer noch sehr viel Kontakt mit anderen im Klassenraum und so weiter. Die brauchen dann nicht einen Freitag vor dem Rathaus oder so. Aber dieses Prinzip inhaltlich auf Abwägen. Und das meine ich jetzt nicht so negativ bei den Freien für Future, aber inhaltlich sozusagen auf eigenen Wegen und das dann noch alleine. Und Mingma schreibt in der süddeutschen, und das wird hier zitiert, als der Alltag noch kommunikativ durch Großfamilie, Firma, Nachbarschaft, Kirche und Gewerkschaften geprägt war, während die größten historischen Verirrungen noch vor dem Mittagessen ausgeräumt wurden, heute hingegen werkeln viele Menschen an ihren privatideologien wie einst modellbauer im Hobbykeller an komplexen Holzschiffen. Das könnte man jetzt in die eine Richtung drehen, wie du es in deinem Tag eben hattest. Ja, der Organisationsgrad ist einfach zurück. Heute befasst man sich nicht mehr an der Arbeitsstelle, am Küchentisch, wie auch immer mit Politik. oder, und das würde ich eben sagen, da muss man auch mal drüber nachdenken, man hat sich halt damals in Sozialität, aber nicht mit Politik befasst. Also sozusagen, man muss zwei Sachen in die Gleichung reinnehmen. Nicht nur, man hat mit sozialem Kontext über Politik gesprochen, sondern man war in sozialem Kontext und der war aber unpolitisch. Und das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, das wird heute immer wieder übersehen. Wir können heute uns die ganze Zeit über Politik informieren, gerade wenn uns langweilig ist. Dann machen wir nämlich Twitter auf und werden durchpolitisiert, sind dann aber einsam in dem Moment. Früher haben die Leute wirklich nur Tagesschau geguckt, wenn überhaupt. Und das war eine viertelstunde. Diese idee von den 70ern, 18ern, das war ja die Hochzeit der Zeitung, da haben ja alle Zeitung gelesen. Nee, niemand hat da Zeitung gelesen. In den Jahr 2000 haben mehr Leute Zeitung gelesen als 1980. Also da gibt es immer eine ganz große Verklärung der Vergangenheit. Damals hat man sich ja noch richtig mit Politik befasst. Und die Antwort ist nein, damals hat man sich gar nicht mit Politik befasst, sondern da stand einfach anderes im Mittelpunkt.
Ich denke an meine Großeltern, die Zeitungen ja natürlich gelesen haben, weil sie die Tageszeitung abonniert hatten, was dann hier in diesem Fall die Rheinzeitung ist. Aber die wurde natürlich nicht gelesen wegen der Politik. Also ich würde sagen, wahrscheinlich haben meine Großeltern nicht alle Minister aufsagen können. Aber die haben die Regionalzeitungen gelesen, erst mal wegen der todesanzeigen, wen hat man schon überlebt, und wegen der lokalen Politik, die aber nur bedeutet, wo findet die Kirmes statt, oder wer ist jetzt der jahrgangspräsident oder sonst irgendetwas. Das heißt, es wurde zwar die Zeitung geliefert, und die war auch vorhanden in Form von, da ist Politik dabei, aber diese Politik wurde überhaupt nicht in dieser Weise konsumiert. Und ich glaube auch, dass die bundesrepublik sich traf vor dem Fernseher und die Tagesschau guckte. Ich glaube, das war Standard. Wenn man dann sich mehr für Politik interessierte, dann schaute man noch die Tagesthemen, aber die einfachen Leute schon nicht, die waren nämlich meistens dann schon im Bett. Und das war es eigentlich. Das heißt auch, die Politik war im eigenen Wohnzimmer gar nicht häufig zu sehen. Also man hat dann mal den bundeskanzler am Abend für zwei Minuten gesehen. Ich kann ja heute den ganzen Tag mit Olaf Scholz zubringen, wenn ich möchte.
Genau, wenn man ins Eingemachte geht, es gab in Deutschland niemals Millionen und Millionen von überregionalen Politikseitenlesern. Ja, gab es einfach nicht. Das ist alles legende. Und zu diesem Einsamkeitsding hier im Text machen sie noch mal einen ganz schönen kleinen Bogen. Ken Jepsen und Sarah Wagenknecht stellen uns nicht nur eigene politische ideen vor, wie es anders sein könnte, sondern sie vertreten das auch als Einzelkämpfer. Und wenn man das so liest, denkt man, das stimmt. Ken Jepsen, das war ihm ja ganz wichtig. Ich in meinem Keller und Sarah Wagenknecht sehen wir ja auch nur als die Solistin, sozusagen, seit an Beginn, seit wir sie sehen. Und da kommt auch diese Attraktivität mit her. Man erkennt sich selbst so ein bisschen. Man wird nicht nur inhaltlich repräsentiert und hängt sich dann so ideen an, sondern man sieht auch im Fernsehen jemand, der nicht ein riesiges Kanzleramt und so weiter, sondern Einzelkämpfer. Also ist man da besonders offen für solche Charaktere. Und die Schlussproante gefällt mir eigentlich am besten. Dieser Freier sagt, ja, wir erleben hier auch, dass sich Freundschaften überleben. Die zerbrechen einfach an Streitfragen. Das kennen wir in der AfD. In der AfD gibt es ja fast keinen Abgeordneten, von dem es nicht heißt, er hat sich mit seiner Familie überworfen. Also ist ja ein grundlegendes Ding da drin, wie sie alle völlig raus sind aus ihren sozialen Kontexten. Was zu diesem Paradox führt, dass Menschen das, was ihnen eigentlich am meisten helfen würde, also nämlich Sozialität und Solidarität zu finden, dem wird die größte Absage erteilt. Ich mache mich mit euch nicht gemein. Ich will mit euch nicht reden. Man spielt dann höchstens so nach. Ich bin hier auch Presse. Ich habe auch Rechte, wenn irgendwer kommt und so. Ja, aber dass man einfach mal... Nee, du bist hier nicht Presse. Du bist Publikum. finde mal Leute, mit denen du gemeinsam Fernsehen schaust, anstatt hier selbst Fernsehen zu spielen. Nee, bei den querdenker Demos macht jeder sein Handy an und will so selber das Fernsehen sein. Und sie spielen am ende hier so sehr schön mit einem Begriff. Da ist auch noch mal der Konfliktforscher Andreas Zick zu nennen mit dem Zitat, eine starke, kohärente Gesellschaft erzeugt herdenimmunität. Jetzt kann es sein, dass wir am ende der pandemie weniger gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt haben als zuvor. Und ich würde sagen, den Begriff herdenimmunität, den wir ja schon wieder so ein bisschen ausräumen, weil Drosten sagt, mir gefällt Bevölkerungsimmunität viel besser. Ich würde sagen, herdenimmunität ist gar nicht so falsch. Wir sollten weniger auf die Immunität und mehr auf die herde abstellen. Wir brauchen jetzt wieder herden. Wir brauchen jetzt wieder herden bildende Maßnahmen, um dann Immunität herstellen zu können. Und herdenimmunität so als soziales Konzept, das man so spielerisch einfach reinbringt, dieses bildet, banden und so weiter. Das hat mich irgendwie ein bisschen getriggert. Das finde ich eine gute idee. Da sollte man mal dranbleiben. Hashtag herdenimmunität.
Ja, wir blicken auf den Fachkräftemangel in Europa. handelsblatt hat da mal zwei Seiten vollgeschrieben. Wie gehen eigentlich die verschiedenen länder damit um? Ich will nur so ein paar Punkte benennen. Es ist ganz erstaunlich. schweden vermisst in naher Zukunft 70.000 Fachkräfte. Die braucht man dringend. Man hat da einige digitale Unternehmen zum Beispiel. Aber woher die Leute bekommen? Vielleicht kann man sie locken mit Steuererleichterungen. Und Spitzenverdiener sollen jetzt in schweden weniger Steuer zahlen müssen. Beziehungsweise ab 9.000 Euro soll es so sein, dass man nur 75 Prozent seines Gehalts überhaupt der Steuer geben muss. Und also 75 Prozent werden dann versteuert. Und diese anderen 25 Prozent darf man grundsätzlich steuerfrei behalten. Das ist da ein Vorschlag, der gemacht wird. Das heißt, der Bedarf ist so groß, dass viele Firmen Programmierer gar nicht mehr nach schweden holen, sondern ukrainische Fachleute direkt in Kiew beschäftigen. Die Ukraine spielt da ohnehin eine gewisse Rolle bei diesem Fachkräftemangel. Also das ist immer noch so eine Möglichkeit, wo man immer hofft, Fachleute zu bekommen. Aber auch da ist ja mit einer gewissen Knappheit umzugehen. Tschechien, da ist es so, dass die Arbeitslosenquote die niedrigste in der gesamten EU ist. Also von allen eu-ländern, die lag im Dezember 21 bei 2,1 Prozent. Und da kann man sich vorstellen, da fehlen viele Leute. Für Tschechien war die Ukraine das wichtigste Rekrutierungsgebiet. Aber diese Rekrutierung gestaltet sich immer schwieriger, weil auch andere länder das erkannt haben, zum Beispiel Polen. Die Regierung, also die tschechische Regierung, hat daher bilaterale Verträge mit weiteren Staaten abgeschlossen, welche die Entsendung einer beschränkten Zahl von Arbeitskräften vorsehen. Solche Übereinkünfte gibt es etwa mit osteuropäischen ländern, aber auch mit Indien oder den Philippinen. Und man möchte jetzt auch so ein Punktesystem in Tschechien einführen nach kanadischem Vorbild. Und jetzt als letztes Beispiel. Wir haben die Szene im Auge von den Flüchtlingen, die da irgendwo in den wäldern hausen und teils erfrieren vor Polen. Und die dürfen auf keinen Fall rein. Und zugleich hat Polen einen Fachkräftemangel oder generell einen Mangel an Arbeitskräften. Jetzt weiß ich, dass da nicht überall Fachkräfte sind, aber man kann jetzt mal sagen, wie irre das ist, dass man, schon aus unmittelteren gründen ist es irre, aber auch sonst, dass man sagt, um Gottes Willen, wenn diese Leute kommen, also statt mal zu überlegen, vielleicht kann man ja auch was mit ihnen machen, volkswirtschaftlich gesprochen jetzt mal rein. Ja, also so verhält sich Polen. Was macht aber Polen stattdessen? Also die Ukraine haben wir schon gehört, das ist wichtig. Georgien, Armenien und Russland. Da gibt es überall Arbeitsmigranten her, die nach Polen kommen. Man hat jetzt da beschleunigte niederlassungsverfahren, also dass die schneller dort bleiben können, auch viele Polen haben aber in den vergangenen Jahren das Land verlassen. Und die Lücke, die füllten dann einwanderer aus der Ukraine. Das ist aber auch jetzt schwierig. So viele bekommt man nicht. Und was macht man jetzt? Private Vermittlungsfirmen suchen ständig in neuen ländern nach potenziellen Arbeitskräften. Mittlerweile schon in Nepal, bangladesch und auf den Philippinen. Also das ist polnische Arbeitspolitik. Man signalisiert nach außen hin, hier darf niemand rein, der nicht eine polnische identität hat. Wir lassen die alle draußen und diese furchtbaren bilder, die dabei entstehen, die dann den Rechten helfen. Und zugleich hat man private Vermittlungsagenturen beauftragt, sucht bitte mal Nepal, bangladesch und Philippine, ob nicht mal doch vielleicht jemand hier hinkommen möchte zum Arbeiten.
Ich traue mir ja auch gelegentlich Pointen zu in Rentenrepublik, werde ich eine reinschreiben. Das kommt ja 2022, 2023 ist ja schon das erste Jahr Rentenrepublik, also 65. Lebensjahr für den Jahrgang 64 und so weiter. Da beginnt es ja dann. Und wenn wir uns jetzt mal überlegen, als politische Geister, 2015, letztes Jahr 2021 wurde noch gesagt von der CDU, 2015 darf sich nicht wiederholen. Und jetzt hast du gerade gesagt, ich weiß ja auch, dass in Polen im Gebüsch nicht ausgebildete Fachkräfte sitzen, sondern Familien mit kindern. Und wir werden in unserer Lebzeit, und es wird nicht so lange dauern noch erleben, dass wir hier wirklich offene Grenzen, so wie das ich auch Graeber nicht vorstellen konnte, dass wir einfach sagen, ja der Nationalstaat, das ist ja nur unsere Sackgase, die man uns rein manövriert, weil Eigentum musste ja geschützt werden, pipa po. Und dass man dann wirklich umschlägt. Vollbeschäftigung wird ein Wort sein, das wird uns in fünf Jahren Schauer über den Rücken jagen, wenn es in den Nachrichten kommt, wie bisher nur Arbeitslosigkeit. Und zum Thema, die sind ja alle nicht ausgebildet. 2015, dieses Jahr, was ich nicht wiederholen durfte, war ja das einzige Jahr, wo Deutschland mal jünger geworden ist. Und zwar nur, weil die ausländer, die hierher kamen, so jung waren, dass sogar die restliche deutsche Gesamtbevölkerung, also deutsche und nicht deutsche, die auf deutschem Grund und boden dann waren, insgesamt jünger wurden. Die deutsche Bevölkerung wurde älter, aber die Bevölkerung in Deutschland wurde jünger. So und 2015 ist jetzt 2022 sieben Jahre her. Wer 2015 in die sechste Klasse kam, schreibt jetzt Abitur.
Ja.
Also kommt jetzt ins letzte Abiturjahr. Schreibt nächstes Jahr die Abitur.
Ist mit der Ausbildung jetzt fertig?
Ist mit der Ausbildung fertig, wie auch immer. Wir haben also in unserem Kopf einen unglaublich kurzen Zeitraum 2015. Das ist wie gestern. Und gleichzeitig haben wir auf einem politischen Themengebiet, wo es immer heißt, ja, das kann man gar nicht organisieren, das überspannt ja mehr als eine legislaturperiode, wie auch immer, eine Bewegung, wo man sagen hätte, wir müssen 2015, es fällt uns heute nicht schwer zu sagen, dass ja, muss man als Chance begreifen für Deutschland. Nach all den Problemen, die man in diesen Texten da liest, die du uns gerade vorgetragen hast.
Ja.
Und das finde ich wahnsinnig erstaunlich, dass diese träge, träge Demografie uns plötzlich hier wie so ein Fingerschnips, so ein politischer Fingerschnips vorkommt. Dass wir einfach sagen, nee, die kommen natürlich nicht als wertige Fachkräfte, aber wir können innerhalb von zehn Jahren aus 15-jährigen Menschen Ärzte machen, die alles können, müssen, was sie, was wir von ihnen verlangen. Und diese zehn Jahre sind ein absolut überschaubarer Zeitraum. Also mit dem kann man wirklich politisch handeln, wenn man denn handeln will. Das finde ich immer wieder erstaunlich, wenn man es mal so runterbricht auf so Jahreszahlen. Also 2015 einfach. Darf sich das echt nicht wiederholen, dass wir da jünger wurden als Deutschland und die Leute freiwillig hierher kamen. Frisches Ausbildungsmaterial, wenn man es mal richtig schlimm sagt. Aber ja, da steckt doch einiges an Handlungsmöglichkeiten drin, das auch die Welt wirklich ein bisschen besser machen kann.
Und wir sprechen ja hier nur über Spitzenfachkräfte, die da zum Teil gesucht werden oder Fachkräfte allgemein. Aber dann in schweden werden ja dann wahrscheinlich die neuen CEOs von Spotify oder was weiß ich gesucht. Aber es wird ja dabei ausgeblendet. Es gibt natürlich auch ganz viele Kräfte, die fehlen, bei denen es sich aber durch diese privaten Agenturen und so kaum lohnt, da Leute nach bangladesch zur Suche nach solchen Arbeitskräften zu schicken. Aber auch im Servicepersonal und so weiter und so fort. Also wo man auch Leute, die vielleicht schon eine andere Berufsausbildung haben, die dann fliehen nach Europa, umschulen könnte. Also es wird ja nicht so sein, dass in irgendeiner Weise da eine Massenarbeitslosigkeit einsetzen würde, wenn man mehr Menschen aufnehmen würde. Ganz im Gegenteil. Es ist total absurd und ich kann das kann das gar nicht fassen, dass so irrational darüber aber offenbar in allen europäischen ländern berichtet und diskutiert wird. Denn sonst hätte sich ja so eine demografische Erkenntnis mal durchgesetzt. Und dann würde man also eigentlich müsste man sobald das wiederkommt. Ja, kann sich Deutschland das leisten? Wie viel dürfen wir aufnehmen? Normalerweise müsste man die Leute dann zur Seite holen und ihnen sagen, verstehst du, das ist jetzt so wie mit der Impfung. Ja, also wir brauchen jetzt auch nicht wieder hundertmal darüber diskutieren, ist die Impfung, hat die noch irgendwelche schlimmen Folgen für uns oder so? Das gehört jetzt einfach zum modernen Dasein dazu, dass man das akzeptiert, dass Impfungen gut sind. Genauso gehört das auch dazu, dass man mal diesen alten Diskurs von das Boot ist voll und was weiß ich, gänzt sich hinter sich, dass einfach diesen Unsinn nicht mehr mitmacht, sondern einfach nur mal sagt, ja genau, volkswirtschaftlich. Was wäre dann jetzt besonders wichtig? Wie könnten da auch die ganzen Arbeitgeber entsprechend sich noch mal in Stellung bringen? Und wie könnten wir die Schulen umgestalten, um von Anfang an da mehr kulturellen Austausch zu ermöglichen, damit auch ja nicht erste Ghetto-Bildungen oder so etwas entstehen? Das wären die pragmatischen Fragen, die zu stellen sind, aber diesen Diskurs vermisse ich. Und ich glaube, er herrscht zumindest hier in Europa in keinem Land. Je nachdem, was ich jetzt hier lese, gibt es da zumindest kaum Hinweise drauf.
Es ist viel schlimmer. Ich habe mir ja so einen Protagonisten rausgesucht für mein Buch Jens Spahn. Niemand in der CDU kennt sich mit der Demografie aus, außer Jens Spahn. Der kennt sie aber gleich besser als alle anderen mitglieder aller anderen Parteien noch. Und es ist wahnsinnig verrückt, wie Jens Spahn auf der einen Seite weiß, wie er für die CDU Wahlkampf macht, wie man nämlich die Alten bezirzt und sagt, wir lassen euer Deutschland in Ruhe, macht euch keine Sorgen. Ihr werdet hier nicht belästigt von irgendwelchen ausländern. Fünf Minuten später steigt er ins Flugzeug, fliegt nach Bulgarien und besucht dort irgendwelche Schulen, wo die jungen mädels Deutsch lernen, um dann später in Deutschland Pflege zu machen. Und das ist einfach absurd. Und da gehört so viel Ehrlichkeit, so viel Transparenz einfach mal rein. Na ja, apropos Transparenz. Eine Sache fand ich irgendwie hochinteressant. Das ist nur ein ganz kleiner Text im Economist zum Thema Wall Street and The Real Winner der GameStop Saga. Denn wir wissen alle, wer die richtigen Gewinner waren am ende. Wer hat eingesagt? Natürlich die großen Finanzmarktakteure. Aber 28. Januar 2021, also jetzt ein Jahr her, war es eben, dass GameStop 483 Dollar wert war. Also 200 Mal mehr als zu den üblichen Zeiten. Und gleichzeitig war dieses GameStop-Ding, obwohl es recht viele Marktteilnehmer sowieso immer gibt und auch viel Geld im System ist. Aber dieser 28. Januar, als GameStop auf dem Gipfel seiner Marktkapitalisierung war, das war gleichzeitig der Tag, an dem so viel Aktien gehandelt wurden, wie niemals zuvor und auch seitdem nicht mehr. Also absolut peak busiest busiest ever trading day. Und dieser Text läuft auf die Pointe hinaus, dass Spencer Jacob vom Wall Street Journal ein Buch geschrieben hat über dieses ganze Narrativ. Da haben es die Einzelnen, die Einzelkämpfer aufgenommen und haben die großen Hedgefonds in die Knie gezwungen. Also citadel und Goldman Sachs sind dann aber trotzdem die Gewinner gewesen. Die haben nämlich sowohl die einen rausgepaugt, als auch sich dann da bereichert. Irgendwo ist das Geld ja hingeflossen, dass die ganzen Einzelnen in die einzelnen Aktienkäufe getan haben und dann nie wiedergesehen haben. Und der Punkt, der hier im Text glaube ich super wichtig ist, ist, dass wir es hier mit einem Finanzmarkt gebaren Ereignis zu tun haben, bei dem wir keinen investigativen Journalismus brauchen, um in Detail aufzuschlüsseln, was hier passiert ist. Weil nämlich alles in Öffentlichkeit passiert ist. Alles. Und das fand ich irgendwie eine krasse Beobachtung, nachdem wir jetzt über zehn Jahre dieses ganze High-Frequency-Trading, da blickt da keiner durch, das passiert alles in millisekunden. Und wer soll das noch? Und nicht mal die Clearingstellen kommt da irgendwie hinterher. Und hier haben wir so ein wirklich bedeutendes historisches Ereignis, das uns aber komplett so offen da liegt. Wir alle Management-Entscheidungen so weit kennen, weil sie alle mit betenden händen von den Milliardären im Fernsehen vorgestragen wurden und man gar nicht intern irgendwie und so was machen musste. Und das, was bis jetzt geblieben ist, sind eben so Begriffe wie Gamma-Squeeze und Rehypothecation und so was. Und ich finde, das ist auch ein ganz guter Anlass aufzurufen, sich diesem Thema Wirtschaft allgemein wieder so zu nähern, dass man jetzt nicht immer so dieses große Mega-Investigative, also es muss schon eine GameStop, eine Cum-Ex-Sache sein. Wir wollen jetzt wirklich wissen, was hat der Bürgermeister Olaf Scholz mit irgendwelchen Bankern gesprochen, sondern wir können sehr viel über diesen Finanzmarkt jetzt einfach lernen, indem wir uns einfach angucken, was da passiert. Man muss es einfach nur aufgeklärt beobachten und sollte nicht mehr so viele Geheimnisse da haben. Auch immer wie es immer heißt, Cum-Ex ist ja so kompliziert und so. Nee, wenn man sich für die Protagonisten von Cum-Ex, wer hat sich wirklich bereichert, dann klar, das ist dann kompliziert. Aber für das Prinzip Cum-Ex braucht man jetzt keinen investigativen Journalisten oder so, sondern das reicht sich einfach mal anzuschauen, wie die Gesetzeslage ist, wie die Handlungen waren, wie die Geldströme sind und zack, liegt halt alles offen. Und das fand ich irgendwie, ja, es ist halt jetzt wieder Arbeit, die man machen muss, aber keine, die man ungerne macht, sondern hier können jetzt Geschichten geschrieben werden.
Ganz sicher. Und ich glaube, dass man viel mehr auf diese Geschichten auch blicken sollte und dann nicht diesen sinisteren Bösewicht ausmachen muss, mit dem man dann irgendwie eine Geschichte noch anheizen kann. Eigentlich ist das mit GameStop ein ganz schöner Fall, um ein bisschen überhaupt zu verstehen, wie die Börse funktioniert, um so ein paar Grundsätzlichkeiten zu begreifen. Und das ist tatsächlich alles sehr, sehr transparent. Und da muss man nicht investigativ zu Sache gehen. Ich möchte auf ein Interview verweisen mit dem Journalisten Ronen Steinke. Der hat ein Buch veröffentlicht, das heißt, vor dem Gesetz sind nicht alle gleich. Die neue Klassenjustiz. Ich habe das Buch nicht gelesen, aber ein Interview in der Zeitschrift Konkret. Und da wird er gefragt, wie ist denn das mit prekär lebenden Menschen? Sind die in irgendeiner Weise benachteiligt vom System? Und dann sagt er, man würde davon ausgehen, dass dem, der es bitter nötig hat, zu stehlen, eher verziehen wird oder er zumindest milder beurteilt wird. Wer aber im deutschen Recht stiehlt, weil er es nötig hat, fällt in die Kategorie gewerbsmäßigen Diebstahls. Und der ist eine schwere Straftat als normaler Diebstahl. Wer also stiehlt, weil er sich bereichern will oder irgendwelche Luxusgüter haben will, gilt als normaler Dieb. Wer stiehlt, weil er davon seinen Lebensunterhalt bestreiten will, fällt in die Kategorie Berufsverbrecher und wird wesentlich schärfer angefasst. Vor Strafgerichten verteidigen sich dann daher manche mit der Beteuerung Ich bin gar nicht so arm, wie ich aussehe. Nur um eine mildere Stadt, das ist also total absurd, war mir überhaupt nicht klar. Er geht dann noch weiter darauf ein, wie sind das so mit Verbrauchsmittel, Diebstahl. Früher gab es im deutschen Recht ein bisschen Rabatt für Leute, die aus Not gestohlen haben. Den sogenannten Verbrauchsmittel, Diebstahltomaten im Supermarkt oder so etwas. Heute gibt es das nicht mehr. Das wurde abgeschafft und das heißt, es gibt heute keine gnade mehr für Leute, die stehlen, weil sie Hunger haben. Was es noch gibt, ist Diebstahl geringwertiger Sachen unter 25 Euro Sachwert. In solchen Fällen kann man das Verfahren leichter einstellen, aber es wird keine Rücksicht mehr darauf genommen, ob der Dieb Hunger hatte oder nicht. Im Gegenteil, das wird ihm eher zur Last gelegt. Mundraub gab es im Prinzip sowieso nie und er bringt dann hier einen besonders tragischen und zugleich kuriosen Fall, und zwar von einer suchtkranken Elendsprostituierten in Hamburg. Weil sie gegen eine in Hamburg geltende Sperrgebietsverordnung verstößt, landet sie regelmäßig vor Gericht und bekommt eine Geldstrafe aufgeprummt, die sie nur stemmen kann, indem sie wieder auf den Strich geht. Die Justiz treibt die Leute in die Kriminalität. Also es ist ganz schockierend zu lesen, auch wie das dann ist mit den Pflichtverteidigern. In 90 Prozent der Fälle stehen Leute vor Gericht, die keinen Verteidiger auf Staatskosten bekommen. Für Laien ist es kaum möglich, in der juristischen Welt durchzublicken. Schließlich muss man ihr Recht jahrelang studieren. Wenn auf der einen Seite ein Staatsanwalt und ein Richter oder eine Richterin sitzen und von der anderen Seite keine juristischen Gegenargumente kommen, dann ist es sehr schwer, zu seinem Recht zu kommen. Und auch hier hat eine Anonymität Einzug gehalten, die furchtbar ist. Ein Trend der letzten Jahre ist ein immer unpersönlicher werdendes System des Strafens. Ich meine damit vor allem den sogenannten Strafbefehl, den es zwar schon länger, aber seit einiger Zeit inflationär gibt. Man kann auf den Prozess verzichten und den Beschuldigten einfach ein schriftliches Urteil per Post zuschicken nach dem Motto, was haben sie zu ihrer Verteidigung zu sagen? Wenn dann keine Antwort kommt, dann gilt man als schuldig und vollkommen klar ist, dass da keine Rücksicht genommen wird auf Leute, die kein Deutsch sprechen, die vielleicht Analphabeten sind, die irgendwelche Probleme haben oder da einfach scheu vor haben. Oh Gott, wie soll ich jetzt darauf reagieren? Ich mach mal lieber nichts oder da muss ich das wohl hinnehmen. Diese Personalisierung, dieses Verlagern ins Schriftliche geht klar zu Lasten der Schwachen, sagt Steinke. Also interessantes Interview, vermutlich auch ein interessantes Buch. Gibt auch ein paar Radio-Interviews, habe ich jetzt gesehen, mit Steinke, die ich aber noch nicht gehört habe. Ja, doch sehr wichtiges, aber unterschätztes Thema wohl.
Ja, das vornehmliche Ziel guter juristischer Arbeit ist ja, Sachen schnell erledigen zu können. Und bis aufs Strafrecht, wo ja immer noch das Mündlichkeitsprinzip wirklich bis ins Letzte durchgepeitscht wird, haben wir das nicht mehr. Diese Strafbefehle kennt man ja vor allem aus jetzt nicht mehr so sehr. Jetzt haben wir ja wieder kostenlose Kinoanbieter, oder was heißt kostenlos, aber so Monats-Abo-Kinoanbieter, von den illegalen Downloads, dass dann Menschen immer Briefe bekamen, die irgendeine Maschine ausspuckte, wo es hieß, wir verurteilen sie hier zum ökonomischen tode, weil sie eine Serie heruntergeladen haben, die ihnen sehr gut gefällt und sie waren nicht bereit, als student dafür 30 Euro zu bezahlen. Und wenn man drei Mal auf den Brief nicht geantwortet hat, gilt man als verurteilt. Und während du darüber sprach, dachte ich auch wieder, zum einen Graeber, ja das ist dieses Gefängnis, in dem wir jeglichen gesunden Menschenverstand ausgesperrt haben, aber auch an dieses Auto fahren. Du kannst in Deutschland ein Zwangsgeld dafür kriegen, deine Strafe für kostenlose ÖPNV-Nutzung und so weiter, dann kommst du ins Gefängnis. So viele Tagesätze musst du absitzen, wenn du das Geld nicht hast. Gleichzeitig kannst du mit deinem mercedes jedem 5000 Euro aufbrummen. Kannst dich gar nicht dagegen wehren, diese Subventionen sind längst bewilligt. Dein Leben wird verkürzt um ein Jahr. Diese zwei Arten Umgang mit Mobilität, super wäre es eigentlich, wenn man sich das mal wirklich vor Augen führt, dass es schlimm und zu ändern ist.
Ja, auch wenn man das jetzt mal mit Fallsparken oder so vergleicht, was da einem aufgebrummt wird, dann ist das natürlich nicht vergleichbar mit dem, was da dann Leuten droht, die schwarz waren. Also man könnte unendlich viele Sachen jetzt anführen, auch interessant, dass es gibt natürlich sehr viele Blitzanlagen, unter denen ich nicht allzu sehr leide. Aber mitunter ist man auch als Autofahrer jetzt inzwischen genervt, weil man gar nicht mehr weiß, wo jetzt gerade 100 und wo 120. Also hin und wieder wird man mal geblitzt. Aber was er erstaunlich ist, es gibt halt so Wege, die zum Beispiel zu Golfplätzen führen, wo man dann auch noch mal mit den 400 PS so richtig raufkrachen kann. Da wirst du niemals einen Blitzer sehen, weil natürlich sonst der polizeipräsident, der ja auch mit den Kumpels abends da golfen geht, einen auf den Deckel bekommt.
Ja, und weil das alles Arbeit macht, widersprechen ja alle erst.
Ja, genau. Und die Hälfte von denen haben auch noch Jura studiert, die dann den Golfschläger schwingen und die widersprechen dann. Also auch das ist natürlich Klassenjustiz, wenn man so möchte.
Ja, es ist ganz wichtig, allen zu widersprechen. Also wer keine Briefe haben will, der muss erst mal allen anderen widersprechen. Die kommen, egal warum. Und sei es nur um Zeit zu schinden oder wie auch immer. Aber es ist immer wieder so ein Tipp. Es gibt ja hier diesen einen, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie er hieß. Der hat damals einen sehr guten Aufschlag gemacht beim Cars Communication Kongress. Also den Hackern, die ja sehr häufig Polizeibesuch bekommen, gesagt hat, redet nicht mit den Polizisten, redet mit den Staatsanwälten, die mit euch dann reden. Aber nicht mit den Polizisten. Das führt in die Irre. Und so heißt es auch, wenn ein offizieller Brief kommt, erst mal antworten. Egal womit. Erst mal zeigen, ihr seid da. Und im Zweifel, das hatte ich ja dann mit dem Finanzamt auch, wegen wie viel Steuern wird jetzt auf Podcasteinnahmen gezahlt. Am ende ist es dann auch besser, wenn tatsächlich ein Jurist auf einen Juristen antwortet und man das nicht versucht, irgendwie selber zu machen. Aber das verschlinkt das alles Geld. Das ist schon ein echtes Problem. Gut, das Homeoffice ist natürlich überall präsent. Exklusive Daten aus Langzeitstudie. Die Wahrheit über das Homeoffice in fünf Grafiken in der Wirtschaftswoche. Es ist nicht so spektakulär, wie sie es anhört. Es sind nur Nuancen. Sie sagen auch häufiger, die Nachkommastelle zeigt hier. Aber es ist trotzdem ein Trend. Nun gut, die Uni Leipzig Hannes Zacher genau genommen hat ende 2019, also vor Ausbruch der pandemie, eine Langzeitstudie zum Thema Homeoffice begonnen. Es gibt also eine Grundgesamtheit von Menschen, die immer mal befragt werden, wie sie sich so fühlen und wie leistungsfähig sie sind. Er selbst ist Professor für Arbeits- und Organisationspsychologie und ich finde es gut. Und das zeigt auch so ein bisschen, wenn man jetzt sagt, ja die Arbeits- und Organisationspsychologen kümmern sich jetzt auch ums Zuhause. Das zeigt so ein bisschen, wo der Trend hingeht, so insgesamt, wie damals die Erfindung des Internets und vor allem eBay. Also im eBay-Zeitalter, ich sehe dich ja wieder, viele kennen ja dich vor deiner Bücherwand. eBay-Zeitalter heißt, an jedem dieser Bücher hängt ein Preisschild. Und du kannst dir überlegen, ob der Verkauf jetzt für den Preis ist oder nicht. Und so gilt das nicht nur für Bücher, da geht es ja immer los. Das kennen wir von Amazon, alles, was man zu Hause hat. eBay hat das Zuhause zum Supermarkt gemacht. Und so finde ich es interessant, dass jetzt die Arbeitsorganisationspsychologen auch so langsam nach Hause kommen und fragen, wie geht es einem denn so? Und es werden also tausend Beschäftigte gefragt aus verschiedenen Bereichen, wie geht es ihnen? Eingebettet hier in große Studien, Bertelsmann Stiftung. In dem Falle hat die Volkswagen Stiftung das mitfinanziert. Also man sieht auch, die großen Stiftungen wollen jetzt mal wissen, wie ist es so im Homeoffice? Und na klar, wir kennen so alle die Standarddinger. Man begegnet sich nicht mehr in der Kaffeeküche wie auch immer. videokonferenzen, Mailkontakte, reicht das eigentlich, um ein kollektives Gemeinschaftsgefühl zu schaffen, von dem auch der Arbeitgeber Synergien und Produktivität erwartet, ja oder nein? Und die Grafiken sind dann doch hinsichtlich dieser kleinen tendenzen, die man immer wieder besprechen möchte, interessant. Nämlich zum einen, man fühlt sich einsamer, das ist klar. Man fühlt sich auch zunehmend einsamer. Aber darunter leidet nicht die Produktivität und auch nicht die zufriedenheit mit der eigenen Arbeitsleistung, die man erbringt. Das hat ja viele durcheinander gebracht. Homeoffice, was heißt denn das? Ich sitze jetzt zu Hause. Ich kriege irgendwelche E-Mails, muss das dann bearbeiten und wieder zurückschicken. Viele Leute haben sich dann erstmal an Arbeit gestürzt, weil sie gar nicht wussten, was ist denn jetzt der Maßstab für ich habe genug gearbeitet. Denn man war irgendwie nach drei stunden fertig und faulenste sich plötzlich. Man hat gar nicht mitbekommen, dass man den Rest der Zeit mit Kollegen verbrachte, weil die Zeit gab es nicht mehr und plötzlich dachte man, man sei faul. Man wusste nicht mehr, wie viel arbeiten die anderen eigentlich gerade. Man will ja nicht hinten dran sein und so weiter. Das hat sich wohl soweit eingependelt. Und wenn man sich diese fünf Grafiken hinsichtlich zufriedenheit, Einsamkeitsgefühle und Produktivität anschaut, kommt man zu der Einsicht, dass wir hier wieder einem ganz gefährlichen Trend obliegen, dass die Unternehmen nämlich sagen, wir sind mit der Produktivität zufrieden. Die Arbeitnehmer selber sagen, hiermit kann ich meinen Lebensunterhalt bestreiten. Gleichzeitig diese beiden positiven Trends aber ergänzt werden durch einen negativen, nämlich ich fühle mich einsam. Mir ist hier zu wenig los, ich komme hier gar nicht auf neue ideen, niemand inspiriert mich, irgendwie ist es langweilig. Und das ist natürlich dadurch, dass es hier jetzt ganz klar so einen Anreiz für die Unternehmen gibt, es da, wo sie es anbietet und bisher bewährt hat, zwei Jahre, es durchaus so zu belassen, steckt dann doch wieder so eine kleine Gefahr hin, dass wir uns hier die ganzen querdenker heranzüchten, die sich fragen, was mache ich mit meiner Freizeit? Na ja, ich gucke mal schnell ein paar youtube-videos an.
Und hast du ein bisschen rum. Ja.
Genau. Sie betonen, es sind die Nachkommerstellen. Aber ich würde sagen, ja, ja, es sind immer nur die Nachkommerstellen. Aber am ende schlägt sich dann halt doch groß durch. Denn wenn es heißt, mehrere zig Prozent der deutschen Arbeitnehmerschaft sitzt zu Hause. Also hier sollten sich die Arbeits- und Organisationspsychologen nicht nur quantitativ, finde ich, damit beschäftigen, was hier vor sich geht, sondern auch qualitativ. Man muss hier Trends entgegenwirken. Sonst geht das nicht gut aus.
Ein letzter Text, der sei nur kurz angemerkt. Im Weltraum scheint die Sonne immer heiß, der von Riffreporter. Vielleicht kann ich dann doch das Auto behalten, wenn genügend Energie anders gewonnen wird. Denn man könnte ja auch Solarpanels, sage ich mal, Solarkraftwerke viel mehr im All platzieren. Das ist eine idee, schreibt der Autor Karl Urban in diesem Artikel, die schon Isaac Asimov hatte, 1941. Nun im Dezember 21 sagte dann die Europäische Raumfahrtagentur mit ihren Experten, also das Konzept ist jetzt eigentlich bereit für einen industriellen Ansatz. Und da sind natürlich sehr viele Schwierigkeiten. Es wird technisch ein bisschen erklärt, wie das Ganze funktioniert. Das heißt aber dann auch, die Technik könnte ein Problem der globalen energiewende hin zur Netto-Null-Emission im Jahr 2050 lösen. Nachts und beruhigend Wetter im Winter mangelt es an den global wichtigsten erneuerbaren Energiequellen an Wind und Sonne. Im geostationären Erdorbit ist dagegen immer Tag und das Kraftwerk im All könnte jederzeit gleichmäßig Energie liefern. Und man könnte dann auch diesen Stromspeichern überbrücken. Man muss ihn natürlich auch zurückbringen. Man kann ja nicht einfach sagen, man sammelt das da um. Es muss ja irgendwo dann auch nie auf der erde ankommen. Das geht dann über Antennen. Die brauchen eine gewisse Größe. Das wird erläutert. Ich kann das dann immer nur so halbnachvollziehen, weil mir da physikalisches Verständnis fehlt. jedenfalls ist es so, dass es sehr viel leichter geworden ist, im finanziellen Sinne leichter geworden ist, schwere Dinge ins All zu bringen. Also hier gibt es mal eine Rechnung. 1979, da sagte man, man braucht 400 Dollar. Man braucht eigentlich für einen Kilogramm, müsste man nur 400 Dollar ausgeben müssen. Dann würde sich das lohnen, wenn man sagt, wir müssen da ja unglaublich schweres Gerät raufbringen. Also wir sprechen da bei einer Leichtbauweise von 7600 Tonnen. Und wenn man jetzt sagt, ein Kilo kostet 400 Dollar, dann würde sich das lohnen. Nur damals kostete ein Kilogramm raufzubringen 20.000 Dollar. Das heißt, das wäre so immens viel zu viel Geld, dass das auch niemand machen würde. Und deshalb kann man jetzt aber eher sagen, es ist immer mehr möglich, weil inzwischen ein Kilogramm zu transportieren ins All nur noch wenige tausend Dollar kostet.
Dank Elon Musk.
Ja, es steht da natürlich ausdrücklich, aufgrund von SpaceX und so weiter, sind also jetzt Raketenstatt günstiger und ist dann auch der Transport günstiger und all das. Das heißt, da ist in gewisser Weise bald etwas möglich, was bislang einfach nicht finanzierbar war. Aber das ist auch in dem Artikel zu lesen. Das sagt dann Leopold Samara, das ist einer der Experten. Ein solches Kraftwerk ist kein klassisches Projekt für eine Raumfahrtagentur. stattdessen müssen nun Energieunternehmen erkennen, dass die Beschäftigung mit dem Weltraum nicht nur mit Science Fiction zu tun hat. Also die Hoffnung ist hier, dass die großen Energieanbieter vielleicht sagen, ach ja, wenn wir jetzt bald nicht mehr Bohrinseln und so betreiben können. Ich meine, das sind ja auch enorme finanzielle Aufwendungen. Dann könnten wir uns mal aufs Weltall verlagern. Wir werden sehen. Also vielleicht wird dann BP oder was schon das bald erkennen, denn man kann nicht darauf sitzen, dass der Staat das komplett regeln wird. Und naja, vielleicht haben ja auch diese Unternehmen tatsächlich ein Interesse daran. Also ist noch viel Zukunftsmusik natürlich drin in dem Ganzen, aber zumindest auch eine interessante Überlegung.
Also ich bin streng dagegen.
Ja.
Das führt uns in die Irre. Wir haben 2020 im Dezember diese Elon Musk Rakete uns angeschaut. Der hat nämlich da ihren Testflug gemacht. Neun Meter Durchmesser, fünf Meter Höhe oder so. Das war so gigantisch groß. Man kann da ganze Einfamilienhäuser drin unterbringen. Eine der besten ideen, die auch angedacht wurde, war ja Desert Tech. Ja, im Weltraum scheint immer die Sonne, aber das macht sie auch auf der erde. Und es gibt Gebiete auf der erde, da scheint sie so zuverlässig, dass wir das einfach nutzen, bis hin zu ausbeuten können. Natürlich zusammen mit den Völkern, die da leben. Wir dürfen nicht noch mal die Anfänge vermasseln, so wie Graeber uns das schon vorhielt. Und wir kennen von Claudia Kemfert, da wird sie ja nicht müde zu betonen, Grundlast und Grundlastfähigkeit sind Mythen. Wir brauchen keine Grundlastfähigkeit mehr. Wir können das Energienetz so managen, dass wir da mal ein bisschen Wind, da mal ein bisschen Sonne hinzufügen und trotzdem auf zwei Prozent mehr Schwankung ist es nicht, kommen also diese idee der Taxonomie. Wir brauchen die Atomkraft für Grundlast und so weiter. Das ist ja nur vorgeschobener Blödsinn. Plus wir haben den Auftrag, Afrika zu befrieden, denn da werden noch die nächsten Jahrzehnte mehrere milliarden Menschen geboren. Dagegen kann man gar nichts machen. Dagegen will man auch nichts machen. Und zwar aus guten gründen. Was sollte man dagegen machen? Gleichzeitig brauchen die dort sowohl eigene Energie als auch ein Wirtschaftswachstumsprogramm. Und das können wir ihnen bieten. Wir haben einen European Green Deal. Und wenn wir gesagt hätten, der ganze Quatsch mit Gaskraftwerken und Atomkraftwerken, die wir jetzt investieren wollen, dieser ganze Blödsinn. Nee, wir machen jetzt einfach mal wirklich eine friedenstechnische, energiepolitische verbrüderung mit Afrika. Und das Katapultmagazin hatte mal diesen kleinen Punkt auf die afrikanische Karte gemalt, den man als Fläche bräuchte, um über Solaranlagen ganz Europa zu versorgen. Und dieser Punkt ist im grunde nicht zu sehen. Also meine etwas vulgäre These ist, die Überdachung Spaniens mit diesen, wo das Obst runterwächst, Gewächshäusern, ist ungefähr hundertmal mehr Überdachung, als wir bräuchten, um in Afrika Solarpanele so aufzustellen, dass sie Europa versorgen. Plus, wir haben jetzt die ersten Konzepte, auch deutsche Autobahnen zu überdachen. mercedes hat jetzt ein Auto vorgestellt, das aus sehr viel gewachsenen Materialien besteht. Plus einfach mal Solardächer auf den Autos. Denn ja, sie stehen halt viel rum und sie stehen in Helligkeit rum. Man braucht ja nicht direkte Sonneinstrahlung. Die hindert ja sogar durch die krasse Erwärmung der Solarpanele nochmal die Technologie. Wir brauchen nur Helligkeit. Die haben wir hier gegeben. In Afrika können wir dann auch die Hitze noch ein bisschen ausbeuten. Und diese Solarthermie dann nochmal mit diesen Türen, wo dann Wasser und so weiter. Das wäre alles möglich und das Geld dafür ist auch da. Und jetzt schon wieder in den Weltraum zu fliegen, um da irgendwelche Dinge aufzubauen.
Das ist dann der falsche Anfang. Das ist der falsche Anfang, den man dann nimmt. Aber nachdem ich das jetzt gelesen habe, dachte ich schon, naja, es könnte doch wieder so ein Anfang sein, der Elon Musk begeistert, der neue Investoren lockt. Wenn du Leuten sagst, wir könnten da ein friedensprojekt in Afrika zugleich noch draus machen, da kriegst du ja niemals einen CDU-Politiker für. Also wenn du denen sagst, ich hab eine tolle idee, wie man noch ein paar Leute in irgendwelche Minen bringen kann in Afrika, dann würden die immer noch mal ihre Lobbykräfte wirkmächtig ausbreiten. Aber ich befürchte, es wird eher sowas hier sein. Und dann aber...
Das ist Don't look up.
Das ist eine Don't look up idee. Wahrscheinlich in diese Richtung. Ich finde aber interessant, dass es tatsächlich möglich ist. Also das hätte ich jetzt technisch... Also wenn das stimmt, was hier beschrieben wird, dass das technisch so gut möglich ist, bereits hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht.
Wenn das möglich ist, wie einfach wäre es dann wirklich möglich, in Nordafrika solche Dinge aufzubauen. Es gibt die erde, wir kennen sie ja als Globus mit einem riesigen Russland und einem ganz kleinen Afrika, das so ein bisschen unter Europa rumhängt. Wenn wir jetzt diese Perspektive mal wechseln und Afrika dorthin malen, wo sonst immer Russland ist und Russland unterhalb Europas und wir bauen die gleichen Verzerrungen ein, dann kriegen wir mit, wie riesig Afrika eigentlich wirklich ist. Und ja, da leben viele Menschen und es werden noch sehr viel mehr, aber im Vergleich, wir kennen ja das Harald-Lesch-Argument, selbst wenn alle Chinesen und alle inder nach Amerika gehen, ist da immer noch nicht ernsthaft von Bevölkerungsdichte zu sprechen, mathematisch gesehen. Das gilt in Afrika umso mehr. Wir verdrängen da niemanden, weder Biomasse Mensch, noch Biomasse Tier, noch Biomasse Pflanze, sondern das ist einfach totes Gebiet. Und da kann man einfach Sonne ernten. Die Sonne scheint auch auf der erde, da muss man nicht in den Weltraum. Das ist so wahnsinnig.
Und wir haben ja in Davos den vizepräsidenten von Nigeria gehört, der da flehte, dass auf jeden Fall Gas als Übergangstechnologie bleiben muss. Das muss er ja nur sagen, weil man genau das, was du jetzt eben skizziert hast, noch nicht angestoßen hat. Und würde er wahrscheinlich da sitzen und sagen, ja, Gott sei Dank brauchen wir kein Gas mehr. Aber da man das gar nicht erst offeriert und dann von der Leihennummer sagt, ja, wir können da noch viel nutzen. Man hat erst drei Prozent des Potentials oder so, aber dann nicht wirklich was drauf folgt. Ist die Situation ja so verfahren, wie sie ist?
Solarkraft heute vier Kilowatt die stunde, vier Cent pro Kilowatt. Das ist nichts im Vergleich zu Atomkraftwerken, Gaskraftwerken, Wasserspeichern in Norwegen, weil wir in Deutschland vergessen haben, die Nordsee an süddeutschland anzuschließen. Das sind alles wahnsinnige, bescheuerte Sachen, die da vor sich gehen. Und jetzt noch in den Weltraum zu fliegen mit Solarplatten, das ist einfach der totale Wahnsinn. Gut, damit ist der Salon hier auch abgehandelt und der Januar abgeschlossen. Es gibt nichts mehr zum Januar zu sagen. Wir sind gespannt, was der PO auf freitelt.
Ach so, wir sollten vielleicht noch ganz kurz sagen, was wir als nächstes lesen wollen, weil manche sich ja doch vorbereiten. Und zwar hatten wir wieder an ein wirtschaftliches Buch gedacht, oder? Dann würden wir Kampf der Nationen lesen. Ja, wie der wirtschaftliche Wettbewerb unsere Zukunft zerstört. Von Patrick Kaczmareck, das ist bei West End erschienen, also Kampf der Nationen, wie der wirtschaftliche Wettbewerb unsere Zukunft zerstört. Und da soll auch die europäische Wirtschaftspolitik unter anderen Grundvoraussetzungen stattfinden, wird da gefordert. Und man muss sich von diesem merkwürdigen Wettbewerbsmantra verabschieden, sagt der Autor. Wir sind sehr gespannt. Flassbeck lobt das Buch, Bofinger lobt das Buch. Also wir sind gespannt, ob wir uns dem anschließen können.
Und nur 224 Seiten kann man also mal schnell weglesen, wie ein Klappentext von Graeber. Ich habe auf der Webseite noch ergänzt, das werde ich aber dann in der großen Folge auch noch mal sagen, eine E-Mail-Adresse mailatneuezwanziger.de, denn viele wollen uns immer direkt erreichen und schaffen es dann nicht so genau. Wenn ihr die Adresse benutzt, erreicht ihr Wolfgang und mich. Wir kriegen dann jeweils einzelne Mails, die wir auch von unserer Seite leicht aussortieren und einsortieren und verordnen können, weil die nämlich dann mit dieser E-Mail-Adresse mailatneuezwanziger.de verknüpft ist, sodass wir das schön filtern können und ihr keine Sorgen haben müsst, dass ihr uns damit nervt. Und wenn ihr Audio-Kommentare habt, wir hatten nämlich jetzt auch im Fernsehpodcast wieder zwei, die eigentlich Neue-Zwanziger-Material sind, ganz explizit. Dann schickt ihr doch an diese E-Mail-Adresse, ihr hättet immer auch wieder gedacht, ach komm, machs hier wieder mit Handy-Nummer und so weiter, aber ist gar nicht notwendig, denn alle haben jetzt ein Smartphone. Smartphones haben eine Diktaturfunktion, man spricht einfach rein, was man sprechen will und aus dem Ich-Teile-das-mal-Menü schickt man es einfach per E-Mail an die mailatneuezwanziger.de, dann können wir das hier besprechen. Denn wenn wir eine große Folge, also eine Monatsfolge machen und dann eine Woche später den kleinen Salon-Teaser, dann können wir ja da darüber reden, was ihr gehört habt in der großen Folge. Also dann kann man das kurz aufgreifen. Es ist vielleicht gar kein schlechter Platz dafür.
Dürfen nur nicht so lange sein.
Dürfen nicht so lange sein, ansonsten würde ich auch sagen, wir schneiden einfach auf den Kern zurecht, sodass wir es hier…
Wie auf der Leserbriefseite einer Zeitung, da wird ja auch gekürt.
Schickt einfach, schickt einfach, aber ihr seid euch dann sicher, wir gehen dann nochmal redaktionell so rein, dass ein 7-Minuten-Kommentar auf die 90 sekunden zurückgekürzt wird, den wir dann auch hören gemeinsam und dann kurz besprechen, wenn sich es natürlich anbietet. Das ist jetzt immer nur… Es ist nicht so wie im Fernsehpodcast, wo ich im grunde jeden Audio-Kommentar im Nachgang nochmal spiele, sondern wir würden das dann hier direkt aufgreifen. Und genau, ihr könnt euch selbst begrenzen, ansonsten begrenzten wir euch dann. Aber ihr könnt erstmal einfach schicken.
Einen Hinweis habe ich auch noch, ein Hörer und eine stunde später eine Hörerin haben mir aufgrund des Leihmutterschaftsthema ein Feature aus dem Deutschlandradio empfohlen, und zwar über Leihmutterschaft in der Ukraine. Und das ist sehr interessant. Und das würde ich jetzt auch mal noch mit hier in unsere lange Liste anfügen. Wer sich dafür interessiert, sollte sich das anhören. Das ist aus dem Dezember 21.
Sehr gut, ja, das ist sogar aktuell. Sehr gut. Na dann sehen wir uns ende des Monats wieder. Dann hoffentlich Corona vorbei. Es warten ja andere Themen. Wir wollen ja auch dann wirklich über Olaf Scholz, seinem Pullover reden.
Ganz genau.
Gut, haut rein, Leute.